BEGIN WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SUCH DISSING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMIN MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISEMPOWERMENT ALONE
WILL BE USING WE'LL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPIT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAITING PERIOD WHAT YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE UNMETERED YOU'LL
BE RATED ADDRESS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE YOUR PRESS TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FOOD FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING IS CUSTOMER IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAYBE REMOVE THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR IF THE CONNECTION'S
MUTE. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME AREAS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME TO SPENCER
JUST THE NEWS THE ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED. PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- DO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. I MISS SITTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY IT'S SO
MINUTE EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
WHICH IS TWO MINUTES TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
ALL THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS THEIR
NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION
POSITION ON MEASURES. TO MAKE
IT CLEAR UP FRONT THAT EACH
SIDE WOULD GET THE SAME AMOUNT
OF TIME. BUT EACH PRIMARY
WITNESS WHAT TWO MINUTES. TWO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. PER BILL
AND THEN IF NECESSARY FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE OF THE MEASURE. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESIDENTIAL BILLS LET'S
STATUS QUORUM MANAGING COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WE DON'T.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE WERE WE ARE VERY
CLOSE TO A QUORUM WE NEED ONE
MORE MEMBER. ONE MORE MEMBER.
SO. ALL RIGHT I KNOW THAT 50%
OF THE REPUBLICANS ON THE
COMMITTEE ARE HERE- WE'RE
LACKING DEMOCRATS.
ALL RIGHT SO
WE- WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY FOUR
BILLS. ON CALENDAR HERE TODAY.
ACTUALLY I'M SORRY- THIRTY TWO.
SO IF WE GET ONE MORE MEMBER WE
WILL COMMENCE. OUR HEARING. IN
THE B. FINISHED WHILE THE SUN
IS STILL UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY AND SO- AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- ALL THE PREVIOUS
ADMONITIONS APPLY WITH RESPECT
TO WITNESSES AND TESTIMONY AND
PRESENTATION SO- SILLY MEMBER
AROUND THE LAW- IF YOU CARE TO
PRESENT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE A.
B. TWO SIX THREE WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE- WE WOULD BE
GRATEFUL. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SEVEN NUMBER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY THREE THE HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND LEADERSHIP AND
DETENTION ACT TAKES STEPS TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL PRIVATE
DETENTION FACILITIES IN THE
STATE MUST ABIDE BY STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC ORDERS. AT PRESENT
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SEVEN
PRIVATELY OWNED CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITIES THAT HAVE A CAPACITY
TO HOLD SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
THESE FACILITIES POISE A UNIQUE
AND CRITICAL CHALLENGE WITH
RESPECT TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND OVER THE
LAST YEAR THEY HAVE BEEN THE
SITE OF MASSIVE OUTBREAKS.
OUTBREAKS IN THESE FACILITIES
CAN QUICKLY OVERWHELM LOCAL
HOSPITALS AND THREE MEDICAL
RESOURCES THREATENING COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY. CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITIES THAT HOUSE
IMMIGRANTS HAVE REUIREMENTS IN
THE FEDERAL CONTRACTS WITH
RESPECT TO AND SAFETY. THIS
INCLUDES LANGUAGE REQUIRING
EACH FACILITYTO COMPLY WITH
CURRENT AND FUTURE PLANS
IMPLEMENTED BY FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
ADDRESSING SPECIFIC PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS WOULD
INCLUDE PLANS FOR TESTING OR
VACCINATIONS FOR COVERT
NINETEEN TO HELP MITIGATE THE
SPREAD INSIDE OF THESE
FACILITIES. BY CLARIFYING THAT
ALL PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE MUST
ABIDE BY STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
ORDERS EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THREE
M. SHARES NECESSARY STATEWIDE
COORDINATION THAT WILL SECURE
OUR STATE DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY MANY
OF OUR STATE'S LOCAL COUNTY AND
CITY HEALTH OFFICERS AND
DEPARTMENTS. ADDITION GROUPS
IMMIGRATION RIGHT ORGANIZATIONS
AMONG MANY OTHERS AND AS A
BIPARTISAN AUTHORED BILL THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. THANK YOU A
SEVEN MEMBER OR ON THE LEFT-
BEFORE WE PROCEED- ON THIS BILL
WE WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I
SEE BUT A 100% REPUBLICAN
DELEGATION IS HERE- IF WE
MANAGE CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL THE PURPOSE
OF A QUORUM. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BIRD
HERE AMBERG HERE BOARD YES.
PORGES PRESENT HEAVY AT ALL DID
I SO DID I SO HERE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HERE HERZBERG JONES
JONES HERE LAYERED HERE LAYERED
HERE STERN WHITE CASKEY HERE
WHY CASKEY HERE WEINER. YOU
HAVE- SEVEN PRESENT AND HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ALL RIGHT
WE'RE STILL ON FILE I'M NUMBER
ONE A. B. TWO SIX THREE LET ME
MAKE ONE OTHER HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENT- EARLIER AG ARE
TWELVE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE WAS
LISTED AS A ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT IS NO LONGER ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND WILL
BE. PRESENTED FOR A VOTE- ALL
RIGHT CONTINUE ON WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. TWO SIX THREE-
I BELIEVE EUNICE CHOU IS A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT PRIMARY
WITNESS AND SUPPORT MODERATOR
IF THIS SHOW IS AVAILABLE IF
YOU WOULD OPEN THE LINE.
COLLINSON LINE OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EUNICE CHOU I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU'S NATIONAL
PRISON PROJECT WHERE I WORK ON
BEHALF OF IMMIGRANT DETAINEES
FACING UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CONDITIONS OF CONFINEMENT.
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THREE IS A
CENTRAL LOOK LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT THE LIVES OF VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN IMMIGRATION DETENTION
IN THE LAST YEAR TWENTY ONE
PEOPLE DIED IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION FACILITIES THE
HIGHEST IT HAS BEEN IN FIFTEEN
YEARS. THOUSANDS MORE HAVE
CONTRACTED COVEN NINETEEN DUE
TO THE FAILURE OF THE TENSION
OPERATORS TO ENSURE SAFE
CONDITIONS AND THE TENSION.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO MORE
WE HAVE SEEN REPEATED PATTERNS
OF NEGLIGENCE AND MISCONDUCT BY
PRIVATE DETENTION OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA. IMMIGRANT DETAINEES
MAY BE IN THE LEGAL CUSTODY OF
A FEDERAL AGENCY CALIFORNIA HAS
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO REGULATE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PEOPLE IN
DETENTION FACILITIES INCLUDING
THOSE WHO HAVE IMMIGRANTS.
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE POWER AND
THE AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS INCLUDING
THOSE OWNED AND OPERATED BY
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES.
HOWEVER IT'S QUITE COMMON THAT
THESE AGENCIES DON'T ALWAYS
REALIZE THEIR AUTHORITY AND
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THREE WILL NOT
ONLY BENEFIT PEOPLE IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTERS
BUT ALSO THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THESE FACILITIES AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN
FACILITIES OWNED AND OPERATED
BY PRIVATE PRISON CORPORATIONS
OFTEN HAVE PERVERSE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO PAY LOWER WAGES
AND CUT CORNERS ON HEALTHCARE
FOR DETAIN PEOPLE AND
COMPUTATIONAL SAFEGUARDS FOR
WORKERS. AMONG OTHER
PROTECTIONS EIGHTY TWO SIXTY
THREE WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT CAL
OSHA REGULATIONS ARE MANDATORY
FOR THESE FACILITIES PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF-WORKERS CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
NATION IN PASSING COMPREHENSIVE
AND CONSTITUTIONALLY SOUND
LEGISLATION. FOCUSED ON
ENSURING PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERSIGHT BY THE STATE IN THE
FACILITIES THIS BUILD BUILD
FROM THAT LEGAL FRAMEWORK AND
URGENTLY NEEDED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC COULD SAVE HUMAN LIVES
AND CLARIFY THE ROLE AND.
RESPONSIBILITY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERSIGHT IN THE FACILITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SHOW- I'M
TO HAVE TO TURN THE COMMITTEE
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR- I'LL BE
BACK SHORTLY HAVE TO PRESENT A
BILL IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO
THUNDERBOLT JUST IF YOU WOULD
DO THE HONORS. THERE ARE. OTHER
OR- ONE TWELVE OR. YOU ARE DEAR
TO THE SENATE GALLERY YEAH. IT
IS PERFECT FOR THE FACT THAT.
OKAY NOW THAT WE HAVE LOST OUR
FEARLESS CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE- WILL BE- CONDUCTING-
THE COMMITTEE FROM- FROM MY
SEAT HERE- MOVING ON TO ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY. THING NONE-
MOVING ON TO- WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHICH TESTS FIND
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO SIX THREE-
SEEING NONE OVER THERE- MOVING
ON TO- FOLKS. VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY FOLKS IN THE QUEUE-
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
A B. TWO SIX THREE AND IF SO.
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE US- ACCOUNT.
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE ARE WE HAVE
SEVENTY Q. CAN YOUI'D LIKE TO
REMIND THOSE IN THE QUEUE- TO
IDENTIFY- THEIR NAME OPPOSITION
AND AFFILIATION. I PERSONALLY
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GIVEN
THAT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS SUPPORT.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JACKIE GONZALES INTEGRATED AND
ADVOCATE. FOR LINE ONE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAPPENING
SURE MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION GOT A TICKET ON
PRISONS AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR FIVE OAKLAND EIGHTY TWO
SIX THREE. THANK YOU THANKS TO
THE TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JENNIFER POP THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE CELL THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE TREE LINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL
RICHARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND THE COOKER TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS
THIS IS NOT AN OFFENSIVE BOOKS
ALONG WITH NEXT GEN POLICY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
SIX THREE THANK YOU. CURRENTLY
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ORDER
ANY ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORTERS AND ARE
GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY FORMAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY. SEEINGNONE ANY IN
OVERFLOW ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO A. B. TWO SIX THREE. ALSO
OVERFLOWING THEY'RE MOVING ON
TO TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY FOLKS IN THE QUEUE
I WISH TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
A. B. TWO SIX THREE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A. B. TWO SIX THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE. TIMES.
AND AT THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- NOW
THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. SENATOR LAYERED
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL
AND I'M PREPARED TO MOVE IT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. BY ALL
MEANS WE HAVE. IN CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHORS WELLS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL AS MY- COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED THANK YOU. SENATOR
DURAZO. THANK YOU I AM A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL- I THINK IT'S-
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT TO.
SEND A MESSAGE OF WHAT WE-
TOLERATE HERE IN THE STATE
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. ANY
OTHER MEMBER WISHING TO COMMENT
SAYING NONE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AROUND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A- THE MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL WAS SENT- LAYERED- ON
A. B. TWO SIX THREE- CHIEF
COUNSEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE YES THIS IS
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THREE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER ADAM WITH THAT
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
LEHRER THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AMBERG. BARGES FIVE FORGES HI
CARRIE AT ALL THE RUSSELL THE
RUSSELL I. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
HI CHRIS BURKE. JONES JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED ICE STERN. BY
CAL SKI HI MY CASKEY I WINNER.
A SENATOR YOU HAVE SIX TO THEIR%
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO LEAVE IT
ON CALL WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THIS
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER. SENATOR ALL
WE- WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
AND IT IS NOTED IN OUR GENDER
WITH ITEMS THIRTY TWO HAVING
BEEN REMOVED FOR CONSIDERATION
AND I WOULD MOVE THE CONSENT
AGENDA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT UP- I DON'T KNOW IF CENTER
AMBER WE SHOULD DO THAT LATER I
THINK WE CAN JUST GO AHEAD AND
DO IT NOW- PETER. I'LL BE-
RECITING THE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WHILE AT A
NUMBER FOR THEM TO DO THE
AUTHORS WILL. YEAH OKAY THE
FOLLOWING REPORT A. B. SIX
SEVEN ZERO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERONE FILE ITEM SIXTY B.
THIRTEEN FIVE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHANNEL.
FOLLOWING NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
SIX FORTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLLY WITH AMENDMENTS. ITEM
EIGHT A B. SEVEN EIGHT ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY. ITEM NINE
SIX NINE FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE WITH AMENDMENTS
NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B. TWO NINE
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOLERA. EIGHTEEN A. B. FOUR
NINE FOUR SEVEN MEMBER MAY.
NINETEEN AJ ARE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY. FILE IN
TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE ELEVEN BY
SOMEONE OR MERIT SUCI. FALLEN
TWENTY ONE A. B. NINE NINE
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON TWENTY TWO A. B.
EIGHT SEVEN THREE BY SOMEONE
ROSS TWENTY THREE A. B. NINE
FOUR FIVE ISOMER MEMBER
ROMMEL'S. FALLEN TWENTY SEVEN
E. B. THREE ONE FIVE BY SEVEN
MEMBERS STONE OR MAKE CERTAIN.
THAT WAS NOT THE ONE THAT WAS
REMOVED IS THAT CORRECT IN CAPS-
AND NUMBER TWENTY NINE TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE- AND FINALLY FILE ITEM
THIRTY B. B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AND THERE IS A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BY SENATOR LAYERED. COUNCILS
LIKE CULTURAL. THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH A MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED- AMBERG
GORGEOUS FIVE FORGES I HAVE A
ZERO. IT ALSO THE ADDRESS SO I
CONSIDER THIS HI WHEN SELES I
HEARD SPURRED JONES HI JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WACO SKI I WINNER.
YOU HAVE SIX TO ZERO POINT 1%
ON CALL WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THIS- CONSENT ITEM ON CALL AND
JUST FOR HOUSEKEEPING HOW MANY
BILLS NOW THAT WE'VE GONE
THROGH THE CONSENT DOES SENATE
JUDICIARY HAVE TODAY. A LOT. IS
THAT THE CATTLE IT IS THAT A
LUMINOUS OKAY. SURE- ALL
RIGHTS- WE ARE MOVING ON TO A
B. ELEVEN TO SIX IF THAT'S
CORRECT AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM- THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT A B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS EIGHT. WE'RE ALL AWARE
OF THE ALARMING INCREASE IN
HATE CRIMES AND TRAGICALLY.
ORDERLY RIGHT INTO THE CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM TWENTY TWENTY REPORT
TO THE NATION. A CRIME TOTALS
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN HIT THEIR
HIGHEST LEVEL IN OVER A DECADE
WITH SEVEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN INCIDENTS
REPORTED. FBI DATA REVEALS THAT
TWENTY NINETEEN WAS ALSO THE
DEADLIEST YEAR ON RECORD FOR
HATE CRIMES WITH FIFTY ONE
MURDERS. AND WHICH WAS A MORE
THAN 1100% INCREASE OVER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN TWENTY TWENTY ANTI
ASIAN HATE CRIMES SURGED BY ONE
HUNDRED AND 49% AND HATE CRIMES
AGAINST GAY MEN JUMPED NEARLY
30% TO SEVENTY CRIMES. AND ANTI
TRANSGENDER HATE CRIMES ROSE
ABOUT 26% ALREADY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT AS REPORTED A
66% INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES
OVERALL AND A 26% INCREASE IN
HATE CRIMES BASED ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. BLACK PEOPLE
REMAIN THE NUMBER ONE TARGET
FOR HATE CRIMES IN AMERICA AT
TWICE HE LEVEL THAT THEY
REPRESENT IN THE POPULATION.
WELL WE HAVE SOME DATA ON THE
NUMBER AND TYPE OF HATE CRIMES
THAT ARE BEING PERPETRATED.
EXPERTS SAY THAT THE FBI DATA
LIKELY UNDERCOUNTS THE NUMBER
OF HATE CRIMES IN AMERICA BOTH
BECAUSE MANY VICTIMS DO NOT
REPORT INCIDENTS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPORT HATE CRIME DATA TO THE
FBI. SO THE FBI RELIES ON THE
VOLUNTARY REPORTING OF MORE
THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PARTICIPATING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT MANY ARE NOT
DOING SO. LAST YEAR 86% OF
AGENCIES DID NOT REPORT A
SINGLE HATE CRIME INCLUDING AT
LEAST SEVENTY ONE CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THIS IS ACCORDING TO
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
THE C. COALITION. DO THE
STAGGERING STATISTICS AND
CHALLENGES OF MONITORING
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING THIS
DATA IT IS CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD USE BETTER
TOOLS AND DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS
TO HELP US TRACK. AND REPORT
THIS INFORMATION FOR THE STATE.
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF
HATE WILL MONITOR AND ASSESS
CURRENT TRENDS RELATIVE DAY
CRIMES PRODUCE ANNUAL REPORTS
ON THESE TRENDS AND MAKE POLICY
RECOMMEND STATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR. AND
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO HELP
THE SAFETY AWARE OF ADDRESS AND
HOPEFULLY REDUCE INSTANCES OF
THESE CRIMES. THE COMMISSION IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHO IS PERPETRATING
THESE CRIMES AND WHO'S BEING
TARGETED. WHERE THEY'RE
OCCURRING AND HOW WE CAN
DEVELOP POLICY SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS AND REDUCE THE
INSTANCES OF THESE CRIMES I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE PROFESSOR BRIAN
LEVIN THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE
AND EXTREMISM AT CSU SAMBAR TO
DINO. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS WAS
STATED I BELIEVE WE HAVE
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN ON THE
LINE. MODERATOR CAN YOU CONFIRM.
I AM ON THE LINE. WE CAN HEAR
LOUD AND CLEAR PROFESSOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YOUR PERSONAL
NUMBER BY SHEER FORCE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME I AM THE
DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER OF THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HEAT
EXTREMES ON AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARD YOU KNOW
FOR NOW TWENTY TWO YEARS WE ARE
NON PARTISAN AND I AM A
LIFELONG. INDEPENDENCE
CRITICALLY WE'VE SEEN A 31%
INCREASE ACCORDING TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S LATEST
REPORT. WHICH JUST CAME OUT.
THIS MONTH MOREOVER. 3282%
INCREASE THAT WE FOUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY OVER TWENTY SIX
MAJOR JURISDICTIONS MARSHALL
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN PLACES
THAT HAVE SHOWN SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES INCLUDING TEXAS 18%
IN NEW YORK CITY WHICH IS AGAIN
A NEW IF WE LOOK AT THE 66%
INCREASE IT WAS JUST REFERENCE
IN LOS ANGELES FIVE HUNDRED AND
70% INCREASE JUST YOU'RE- IN
NEW YORK CITY AND WHAT WE FOUND
ANTI ASIAN HATE CRIMES ALONE.
ENTRY USUALLY CURRENT LOAN LAST
YEAR NATIONALLY ONE HUNDRED AND
46% IN THE FIRST QUARTER. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY PER. AND HE
CONTRADICTS OR EVEN SINCE THEN
WE SHOULDN'T BRING TO IN SOME.
THE MEDIC INCIDENTS IN THREE
WEEKS IN MAY AS MUCH AS THE
WHOLE FIRST. AND WAS ALSO WITH
REGARD TO EXTREMISM SOME
TERRIFYING. DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS
THE IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM. WE'RE
SEEING DIVERSIFICATION. WITH
REGARD TO HOW GROUPS TO
ORGANIZE SOURCING SHELLS AND
VIOLENT LONERS INDEED IN FRESNO
WHICH WE SAW. THREE OR FOUR
YEARS AGO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
A TRIPLE RACIAL HOMICIDE
PRINCES BUT ALSO SEEING
REGIONAL. HELD THESE. ENTITIES
ARE OPERATING SO THAT IS
SOMETHING AND ALSO THEY ARE
OPERATING ON OUR COURT BASIS
AND WHAT I USE. YOUR DINING
FROM A BUFFET OF HATRED WHICH
CROSS THE IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM
FOR INSTANCE WE'RE LOOKING AT.
ABOUT AN 80% INCREASE LAST YEAR
IN ANTI BLACK HATE CRIMES THEY
ARE A HUNDRED AND. 10% INCREASE.
ANTI AGING A 100% PERCENT AND
ALONG WITH THIS MACHINE
DIFFERENT CAMPAIGN. YOU NEED IF
YOU WANT TO THE LAST WEEK OF
THE WHERE I'M SPEAKING TO
IMAGINE. OR RABBI WHICH EIGHT
TIMES WE SAW A BLACK SEPARATIST
MILITIA BECOME THE SUBJECT OF
THE MASSACHUSETTS STATE POLICE.
OVER THE WEEKEND IN LOS ANGELES.
WHY TO CONCENTRATE. IN FRONT OF
US. AND WE- LOOK. RECHARGE
MASSACHUSETTS. THE TROOPER
AMERICAN MURDERED THAT BEING IN
THE AS A HATE CRIME BOTTOM LINE
IS WE ARE ENTERING A DISTURBING
TIME AND WHAT WE NEED. STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS CRITICAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WHICH YOU
ALREADY HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH IT THIS COMMISSION WILL.
HAVE NO FEAR OR FAVOUR WITH
REGARD TO YOUR FUTURE BY LOCAL
MAPS ARE COMING FROM I WANT. TO
THANK FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART. THIS OCCURS HERE SOME
UNDER. YOUR SERVICE AND TWICE
YOUR BROTHERS OR YOUR- ALL
RIGHT EFFORTS IN PARTICULAR
WITH RESPECT TO THE GENOCIDE.
AND WE HAVE FOR INTERVAL FOR
INSTANCE GET. WITH SUCH THINGS
AS LABELING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AS SUCH SHE WAS VERY
INTERESTING TIMES YOU
DEPLOYMENT WE DO FROM
DIVERSIFICATION OF
DECENTRALIZATION
REGIONALIZATION. ALLAH CART.
FORMATION HATRED AND INDEED I
MET WITH YOU. JUST THE OTHER
WEEK AND HE IS COMMITTED THAT
HE TRUE WILL APPROACH THIS IN A
NONPARTISAN MANNER I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU AND I. WOULD
REQUEST AND FIND BOTH. OF YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO OUR STATE AND NATION THANK
YOU PROFESSOR- WE GIVE YOU THE
FULL ALLOTTED- FOR MINUTES
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE ONLY-
SPEAKERS OF THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME IN YOUR SCHEDULE-
LET'S MOVE ON TO A WITNESS IS
IN THE SENATE GALLERY. ANYONE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE MOVING ON INTO OVERFLOW IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF A B. ELEVEN TO SIX.
ALSO SEE NONE MOVING ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY FOLKS IN THE QUEUE. IN
SUPPORT OF OUR A. B. ELEVEN TO
IF SO. GIVE A HEAD COUNT.
GERMAN IF YOU WERE TO IN
SUPPORT OF THE- ELEVEN TWENTY.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY THERE IS TO IN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OPPORTUNITY
NINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
HEALTH FOR YOUNG COURT. CONNECT
TO THE TO LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR KERR NUMBER
CALL THE SHOTS HOW YEAH HI TO
ME CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- MODERATE CAN YOU MAKE A
FINAL REQUEST TO SEE IF ANYBODY
ELSE WISHES TO EXPRESS. THEIR
SUPPORT BY IDENTIFYING THEIR
NAME POSITION- AND AFFILIATION.
CHECK OUT IF YOU WISH TO COME
IN AND SUPPORT. THE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME- WE DECLINED
ONE OH TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY LINE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JAN THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN THE COURT OF THE
CELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WATER
THAT CLOSE UP. THE OTHER FOLKS
YOU KNOW ONE MORE LINE ONE OF
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS GOING TO ORDER FROM THE
ISRAELI AMERICAN CIVIC ACTION
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK EARLY THERE'S
NO MORAL NO NO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- FOLLOWING THE SAME-
BROACHES ON WITH A SUPPORT
WE'RE GOING TO NOW BE MOVING ON
TO ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYONE-
IDENTIFIED AS AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS- LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
GALLERY ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE MOVING
INTO OVERFLOW ALSO SEEING NINE
MODERATOR CAN YOU- CHECK THE
LINES IF THERE ARE FOLKS
WISHING TO- EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN TO SIX. IT US A
SHARE TO THE GOVERNMENT AND
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN POINT SIX
SIX FIVE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ON YOUR PHONE'S KEYPAD. ONCE
AGAIN FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE P. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX FIRST ONE ZERO
PLEASE. MR SHARPLESS TIME THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS OVER THE PHONE
AN OPPOSITION THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA DO IT ONE LAST TIME JUST
MAKE ONE LAST SHOT OUT TO ANY
FOLKS WISHING. TO OPPOSE A BI
ELEVEN TO SIX- CERTAINLY MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN PROPOSITION THE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ON YOUR PHONE'S
KEYPAD. AT THIS TIME- RIGHT NOW
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE PUBLISH.
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW I'M MOVING.
TO THE FLOOR. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WISHING TO- POSE
QUESTIONS SIR WHAT CASKEY I
HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW THAT
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE PASSED DR
PANS S. B. SEVENTEEN WHICH SET
UP AN OFFICE OF A RACIAL EQUITY
AND THEN IN THE BUDGET WE ALSO
GAVE UCLA SOME MONEY TO STOP A
API HEY SO HI THEY WILL BE
GIVING A REPORT COLLECTING
INFORMATION GIVING IT BACK TO
US- THIS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THIS COMMISSION IS TO STAND ON
ITS OWN. IS THAT THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT OR IS THERE SOME
COORDINATION IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S AT ITS CORE THERE'S
THIS. BAD MO JO THAT'S GOING
AROUND IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET A HOLD ON AND THAT YOU KEEP
PEOPLE IN AND GET
RECOMMENDATIONS HOW DO YOU SEE
THAT. IF YOU SEE IT INTERACTING
WITH THOSE OTHER ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN BOTH OF THE SORT OF
LIBERTY WHICH TAKE THE QUESTION
YES THANK YOU- AND THANK YOU
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- THE- JURISDICTION OF
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATE
HATE WOULD BE- JURISDICTION IN
THE BROADEST SENSE- THE FUNDING-THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO AND
THE- PAN LEGISLATION WERE. VERY
SPECIFIC AND THERE'S NO REASON
WHY IN THE FUTURE- FUNDING LIKE
THAT OR BILLS LIKE THAT COULD
BE WRAPPED INTO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE OF THE
COMMISSION- FOR WORK IN
COORDINATION WITH THE
COMMISSION. OKAY ANYTHING ELSE
SENATOR. THANK YOU- I HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS- WHAT IS THE
FEDERAL. DEFINITION OF HATE CAN
YOU DESCRIBE THAT I'M SORRY I
DON'T HAVE THAT TO EVERYBODY
WITH HIS PROFESSOR LEVIN'S
STILL ON THE LINE ELEVEN EXCUSE
ME. YES I AM SIR PROFESSOR G.
DONE IS THERE A FEDERAL
DEFINITION FOR HATE OR HATE
CRIME. ABSOLUTELY A CRIMINAL
ACT W. CLARK MOTIVATED TO GO
THE WHOLE. FOR ME TO SELECTION
ALL OF OUR TARGET. ON BEING
COVERED IN THE STATUTES SUCH AS
RACE RELIGION SEXUAL
GENDER IDENTITY IN ADDITION OUR
MANDATE WOULD COVER. WHO ARE
ACTING. WITH VIOLENCE TO
PROMOTE THESE PARTICULAR GOAL
SO FOR INSTANCE IF THERE WOULD
BE A GROUP THAT WOULD TARGET
WHITE REPUBLICANS EVEN COME
UNDER THE AMBIT AS WELL GOT IT
AND IS THERE A STATE WHERE.
UNDER LAW. AND I'M SORRY REPEAT
THAT PLEASE WHAT. IS THERE A
STATE EQUIVALENT IN CALIFORNIA.
NO BUT THERE ARE IN OTHER
STATES. IS IT YOUR EXPECTATION
THAT YOU WOULD YOU BE USING
FEDERAL DEFINITION FOR WHAT
WOULD GO INTO THE HEAT
JURISDICTION OF SUCH A-
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE OR
COMMISSION. TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
GENERALLY YEAH. I'M SORRY
PROFESSOR AND I'M MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- BLOOM EXCUSE
ME. GO AHEAD SIR I'M TEMPTED TO
SAY IN GENERAL YES BUT I THINK
WE WOULD USE THE FEDERAL-
DEFINITION OF GUIDANCE. OKAY- I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL HERE IS
THAT IF WE DID HAVE IT I DON'T
KNOW IF IT EXISTS IF WE HAD
THAT. INSTRUCTIONAL DEFINITION-
AND- WE HAVE SEEN
EXTRAORDINARY- AMOUNT OF
VIOLENCE PERPETRATED AAINST.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY I MEAN THIS IS BEEN A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT. AMERICAN
AMERICAN HISTORY. WHAT I. ARE
THERE ANY SAFEGUARDS IN THIS
THAT TIE INTO POLITICAL SPEECH
MEANING THAT IF THERE IS A
MESSAGE THAT IS PUT FORWARD BY
AN ORGANIZATION OR A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT IS POLITICAL
IN NATURE. WOULD THAT BE A
TARGET FOR REVIEW BY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. BECAUSE OF ITS
CONNECTION TO VIOLENCE.
POLITICAL SPEECH IN AND OF
ITSELF- IS CERTAINLY NOT THE
TOPIC- OR JURISDICTION OF THE
PROPOSED COMMISSION. NO DOUBT
I'M I'M I'M I'M A LITTLE. COOL
CONCERNED IF WE START GETTING
INTO A NONDESCRIPT HATE
JURISDICTION- BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE APPARENTLY ONE FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT WE COULD BE
VEERING INTO- AREAS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE TRADITIONAL
INTUITIVE UNDERSTANDING OF A
HATE CRIME. SO ARE THERE ANY
SAFEGUARDS FOR THE JURISDICTION
THE CREATION OF THE
JURISDICTION FOR THIS TYPE OF
COMMITTEE. I THINK A PROFESSOR
LEVIN MAY BE. THE BEST PERSON
TO ADDRESS THAT QUESTION TOO.
YES YOU WILL BE MY PLEASURE AND
I ECHO YOUR CONCERNS THAT'S WHY
IT MUST BE A VIOLENT PREDICATE
STORY NEWS. WE STARTED HOW DID
WE NATURALLY INCREASING THREATS
AGAINST ELECTED OFFICIALS
PRESENT I THINK THAT WOULD COME
UNDER THE AMBIT BUT THERE MUST
BE A CRIMINAL PREDICATE WITH
DISH AND THE SUPREME COURT HAS
BEEN VERY CLEAR IN WHAT. WHAT
WHAT THE JURISDICTION GENERALLY
IS ABOUT THE PERMISSIBLE STATUS
WITH REGARD TO PUBLISHING THESE
KIND OF THINGS SO FAR. IN THE
ABSENCE OF DESPAIR WITH ME. ONE
SECOND. ONE THE WORDS AS OF IT
I YOU FOR THROUGH THE WEEKEND
TWENTY THREE BOTH FIRED SPEAK
SENATORS NOW ABOUT. NO I JUST
WANT. OUR COMMUNITY TO AT THE
CONDITION OF THE ABLE TO LOOK
AT UP WOULD YOU. THE GROUPS
THAT ARE BY THE OTHER. FORTY
SOME OF. ARE THE PRODUCT THANK
YOU- AND I MY LAST IS. I'M A
LITTLE. THAT THE FEDERAL-
ASSEMBLY OF INFORMATION- YOU
KNOW ON HATE GROUPS AND HATE
CRIMES IS NOT GIVING US WHAT WE
NEED. THAT WE NEED TO CREATE A
STATE. ENTITY FOR THIS. SITE AS
SOMEONE IN THIS WILL BE MY
LAST. DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
AS TO. WHY WE'RE DEEMING THOSE
FEDERAL ACCUMULATIONS TO BE
DEFICIENT FOR OUR PURPOSES THAT
THE DEFICIENCY IS AS DUE TO THE
LACK OF REPORTING- ON THE PART
OF MANY JURISDICTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AND TO- SO AS LONG
AS THE F. B. I.'S NOT
REUIRING- REPORTING. AND
RETRIEVING THAT INFORMATION.
THERE'S THE P. I THINK- THE-
STATISTIC WAS ABOUT 85% OF THE
JURISDICTIONS SO WE'RE NOT
REPORTING AND- AS IF THAT'S THE
CASE WERE CLEARLY GETTING
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION AND
THAT'S WHY. WE NEED TO. MAKE
SOME EFFORT SOME SUBSTANTIAL
EFFORT HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO
RETRIEVE THE INFORMATION FROM
OUR OWN JURISDICTIONS. OKAY SO
IT'S BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES ARE NOT MANDATING-
THE PRODUCTION OF THOSE. HATE
CRIMES THAT THEIR DATABASE IN
THEIR ANALYTICS ARE DEFICIENT
IS THAT ACCURATE THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY. ALL RIGHT- WE
HAVE OUR LEADERS BACK- WHAT DO
YOU WISH TO TAKE OVER RIGHT NOW
OR HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS- I
HAVE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU
CENTER BOARD JUST FOR YOUR
VALIANT EFFORTS AS CHAIR
APPRECIATED THANK YOU ALTHOUGH
I KNOW THAT THEY'RE STILL ITEMS
ON FILE SO. IF YOU IF YOU
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T CLEAR THE FILE.
ONLY TWENTY NINE LEFT TO GO.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER MIKES
UP- CANCER WOULD YOU- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THAT'S RIGHT WE
SPENT SO MUCH TIME A SEVEN
MEMBER DO YOU WISH TO MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS- JUST AT- THAT
THE PROVISION OF THE BILL IN
ANSWER TO- IMPARTIAL ANSWER TO-
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
VICE CHAIR. THE THE BILL
PROVIDES THAT IN ALL OF ITS
ACTIVITIES THE COMMISSION SHALL
SEEK TO PROTECT CIVIL LIBERTIES
INCLUDING SPEECH SO THERE IS-
SOME PROTECTION BUILT INTO THE-
THE BILL AS IT STANDS NOW AND-
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
AND YOUR TIME AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK DERIVE A- THANK YOU. IS
THERE A MOTION. SETTLER ZERO
AND THEN SHE CAN ALSO BE CALL
THE ROLL S. THIS IS ABC ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
BLOOM WHEN THE MOTION BY
SENATOR LEHRER THE MOTION IS
DEEP PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI. AMBER
GUY BURGESS. PORTIS NOT VOTING
CAPITAL AREA I'D ASAL DRESS SO
I GO. GONZALEZ I HER BERG JONES.
LAYERED LAYERED ICE. WHITE
HOUSE. WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER.
WINNER I. HAVE SEVENTY ZERO SO
FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU OUR NEXT
DAY I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURNER HORRIBLE OFF. HERE TO
PRESENT- ITEM NUMBER. THREE
EIGHTY SIX SIX. SEVEN IN
LEICESTERSHIRE MEMBERS. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS THANK YOU
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I
LIKE TO THINK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE EXCELLENT WORK ON
THIS BILL IT WAS A GREAT DEAL
BEFORE YOUR STAFF MADE IT
BETTER SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
EPISODIC PLOT FAILURES HAVE
CAUSED HUMAN INJURY AND SEVERAL
DEATHS IN RECENT YEARS. ON JULY
TWO TWENTY SEVENTEEN A WOMAN
DIED AFTER SHE FELL HUNDRED
FIFTY FEET FROM THE SEASIDE
BLUFF IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WHEN
THE GROUND BENEATH HER CRUMBLED
THE CLIFF HAVE BEEN BATTERED BY
WINTER STORMS AND COLLAPSED. ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINETEEN THE
SAME WITH THIS GIRL WOMAN AND
HER DOG WERE RESCUED ANOTHER
WOMAN REMAIN TRAPPED AFTER THE
EDGE OF A CLIFF AT FORT FUSION
FUNSTON SORRY COLLAPSE ON TOP
OF THEM WEARING ONE VICTIM
UNDER TONS OF DIRT THE TRUMP
WOMAN'S BODY WAS NEVER
RECOVERED. ON AUGUST TWENTY
NINETEEN IN MY DISTRICT THREE
PEOPLE WERE FATALLY CRUSHED
WHEN A BLUFF CLASS AND
INSIDIOUS BEACH IN MY HOMETOWN.
THE VICTIMS ARE PART OF A LARGE
FAMILY GATHERING THAT DAY AND
HOW THE CLUB OF CLUBS A FEW
MINUTES EARLIER THE. DEATH TOLL
WOULD HAVE BEEN HIGHER INCLUDED
CHILDREN. IN ADDITION PUBLIC
THINK CONCERN ARE RUNNING.
THREATENED CLIFFTOP DEVELOPMENT
THE STATE. INCLUDING HIGHWAYS.
RAILWAYS WASTEWATER OIL.
NATURAL GAS AND NUCLEAR
FACILITIES. UNIVERSITIES
SEVERAL CRITICAL MILITARY BASES
AND NUMEROUS STATE BEACHES AND
PARKS. WHAT IS MISSING RIGHT
NOW AS OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SCIENCE. AROUND BLAH FIGURES.
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESSES THAT
DRIVER FEEL YEARS. PRE MAPPING
IS A MAGNITUDE OF EROSION. AND
THE TIMING OF CLOUGH IS
ESSENTIAL FOR COASTAL
MANAGEMENT. AND BUILDING
RESILIENT AND SAFE COMMUNITIES.
AT SIXTY SIX IS THE FIRST STEP
IN CREATING AN EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM FOR BLOOD
FIGURES. MUCH LIKE WE HAVE FOR
EARTHQUAKES. THE RESEARCH WILL
FOCUS ON THE DELMAR BLOCKS AS
WELL AS BEACONS BEACH. AN
ACTIVE. LANDSLIDE AREA IN
INSIDIOUS. THIS RESEARCH WILL
PROVIDE THE SCIENCE TO DEVELOP
IN PHASE TWO THE EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM IT IS MY
HOPE THAT EVENTUALLY WILL HAVE
WARNINGS FOR THE FAILURES ON
OUR WEATHER APPS MUCH LIKE WE
DO. FOR HIGH WIND ADVISORIES OF
FLOODING OR HIGH SURF
ADVISORIES. THIS INFORMATION IS
CRITICAL TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER IN THE FACE
OF SEA LEVEL RISE. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU IS BIG HERE BECAUSE
OF THE NARROW IMMUNITY FROM
LIABILITY FOR THIS SPECIFIC
TYPE OF RAL WORLD RESEARCH.
WHICH IS LIMITED TO THE
MEASUREMENTS PREDICTIONS AND
WARNINGS OF THE SCIENTIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
PROFITEERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY OR
DAMPER CHIEF CAMPUS COUNSEL AT
UCSD. AND DEPUTY MAYOR RIGHT
ONE FROM THE CITY OF TOMORROW.
ALL RIGHTY- MISTER PARK OR
DEPUTY MAYOR WHARTON. IF EITHER
YOU ARE ON THE PHONE PLEASE
PLEASE MAKE YOURSELF KNOWN. ON
THE ON. THE MARKET ON THE PHONE
AS WELL ALL RIGHT LET'S START
WITH YOU MUST PARK. GO AHEAD. I
THINK YOU'RE ON BOARD. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAN PARK AND I AM THE CHIEF
CAMPUS COUNSEL FOR UC SAN
DIEGO. AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNED A HOLE
ABOUT BRINGING FORWARD THIS
THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. A. B. FIFTY SIX
TIMES CRITICAL RESEARCH INTO
THE CAUSES AND WARNING SIGNS OF
LANDSLIDES- THIS KNOWLEDGE WILL
HELP. BUILD A WARNING SYSTEM
ONE DAY. THAT WILL. PROTECT THE
LIVES AND PROPERTY OF THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
REASON WE'RE HERE TODAY IS
BECAUSE- AB SIXTY SIX CONTAINS
THE TARGETED LIMITED.
LIMITATION OF LIABILITY
PROVISION. LIMITATION OF
LIABILITY MAYBE SIXTY SIX
INSURERS THE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE SCIENCE OF LANDSLIDES WILL
BE DEBATED AND RESOLVED IN THE
PUBLIC FORUM AND NOT IN
COURTROOMS. AB SIXTY SIX IS
DESIGNED TO OPERATE MUCH LIKE
THE LIMITATION OF LIABILITY FOR
GOOD SAMARITANS. THAT IS
CURRENTLY OPERATIONAL. LAW
IMITATION OF. INCURRED PUBLIC
CITIZENS TO RENDER AID TO WHO
ARE IN DISTRESS. BY SHIELDING
THESE GOOD SAMARITANS FROM
LAWSUITS IF THE AID THEY RENDER
IS LESS THAN PERFECT. THE
PUBLIC POLICY BEHIND THIS LAW
IS THAT THE RISK OF THEM
PERFECT EIGHT IS BETTER THAN NO
AID AT ALL. SIMILARLY AB SIXTY
SIX ENCOURAGES THE SCIENTISTS
WITH THE BEST CHANCEOF
FIGURING OUT HOW WHY WHEN AND
WHERE LANDSLIDES ARE LIKELY TO
OCCUR. TO DEVELOP THIS
KNOWLEDGE AND SHARE IT WITH THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS OUR
BELIEF THAT BY ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
LANDSLIDES AND BLOCKED
COLLAPSES. EIGHTY SIXTY SIX
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
BY SAVING LIVES AND PROTECTING
PROPERTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
W. MEHR WARTEN. I THANK YOU MY
NAME IS DWIGHT WORDEN I'M THE
DEPUTY MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
DELMAR JUST HERE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY LOOKS LIKE GUESTS HAVE
OCCURRED IN DELMAR TO THE SOUTH
TOWARDS PINES AND YOUR NORTH
INTERMEDIATE ROADING UNSTABLE
OCEAN BLUFFS COLLAPSE ON
UNSUSPECTING BEACHGOERS ON THE
BEACH. THIS PUBLIC SAFETY RISK
WILL GET WORSE THE FEATURES
NARROW DUE TO SAM LAW THE
MOBILE RISE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THERE'S MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ATTEND THE NARROWING
BEACH AND COMPETE FOR SPACE
NEARER TO THE ERODING BLUFFS
THIS RISK EXISTS ALONG THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE AFTER
THE ACTION MORE DEATHS ARE
INEVITABLE. DEVELOPING A
WARNING SYSTEM IS THE ANSWER
PUBLISHED STUDIES SHOW TWENTY
NINE WARNING SYSTEMS WORLDWIDE
ARE IN PLACE BUT NONE YET IN
CALIFORNIA. WARNING IS CHEAPER
AND LESS ENVIRONMENTALLY
INTRUSIVE C. WALLS ARMORING AND
STRUCTURES TO TRY AND FIGHT
NATURE TO KEEP WHAT STABLES
SCRIPTS INSTITUTE IS PERFECTLY
POSITIONED TO DO THE DATA
COLLECTION AND PILOT STUDIES
BEACONS AND DELMAR CALLED FOR
BY AT SIXTY SIX TRIPS ALREADY
HAS EXTENSIVE DATA FROM YEARS
OF BEACH INVOLVED MONITORING IN
THE AREA STRIPS HAS TOP WORLD
SCIENTISTS SCRIPTS KNOWS THE
BEACONS AND DELMAR AREAS.
INCLUDING THE REAL REAL RISKS
ALONG THE BLOCK SCRIPTS CAN USE
THE EXISTING STUDIES FROM
AROUND THE WORLD AND WILL NOT
BE STARTING AT GROUND ZERO. THE
CITY OF DEL MAR HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING WITH SCRIPTS
AND WELCOMES EIGHTY SIXTY SIX
WE'RE A TOWN OF FORTY TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE WELCOMING TWO
MILLION PLUS PEOPLE PER YEAR TO
THE BEACH WE WANT THEM TO BE
SAFE AND WE CAN'T FOR MANY
REASONS FINANCES BAYERN MENTAL
AND PERMITTING ARMOR THE BLOCKS
TO PREVENT OSS FALLS. AB SIXTY
SIX PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEACE G. PILOT STUDIES TO
DEVELOP WARNING SYSTEMS TO SAVE
LIVES WITHOUT DAMAGING BEACHES
AND BLUFFS WARNING SYSTEMS ARE
NON INTRUSIVE AND RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVE COMPARED TO THE
OPTIONS THAT'S A GOOD. THING
AND WORSE DURING DOING I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT MAY BE THREE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- OTHER
WITNESSES SOME. OF ABC SIX I
SEEN OF THE GUYS C. A ROOM
TWELVE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
UP THOSE ON THE PHONE THEM UP.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SOME OF AB.
SIXTY SIX. HE'D LIKE TO COME IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FOUR IN Q.
FIRST WE GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ARTISTS
FIND SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THECITY EVENTS NEED US AND FOR THE
SAME UNICODE SUPPORT AT SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SHARING CONSULT
IS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT OF THE V.
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS ALIGNED ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE MOVE ON TO NINE ONE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS KURT BLACKBURN ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
SPANDEX AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
PRIMARY WITNESS AN OPPOSITION
LISTED- I SEE NONE OF THE
GALLERIA SEE NONE OF ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB. SIX SIX WE WOULD BE
GRATEFUL. DON'T MAKE YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY SIX THANK. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE FLOOR OF QUESTIONS COMMENTS
I SEE SORT OF BORED JUST YES.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK HERE. I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR-
PURSUING THIS I'VE SPENT A GOOD
AMOUNT OF TIME. IN THIS AREA
AND I UNDERSTAND IF ANYBODY HAS
GONE OVER OFF- TORREY PINES FOR
EXAMPLE- THE EROSION THAT IS
HAPPENING THERE IS. NOT ONLY IS
IT ENVIRONMENTALLY SCARING BUT
FROM A PHYSICAL STANDPOINT YOU
CAN'T EVEN WALK ALONG THE BLUFF
UNDERNEATH IT BECAUSE THERE
HAVE BEEN FATALITIES OVER TIME
HI THIS IS ABSOLUTELY HUGE I'M
I'M DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING IT. BUT MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS THERE'S NOT
APPROPRIATION ATTACHED TO THIS
BUT NUMBER ONE WHY ARE WE-
ORIENTING THIS TOWARDS SCRIPTS
AND SCRIPT STEPS AGAIN TESTED
BUT WHY THEM AS OPPOSED TO
REACHING OUT TO. THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND OTHER- OCEANIC
RELATED ORGANIZATIONS- AND- IN
IN NATURAL. PROTECTION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COULD DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND THREE
WOULD THIS BE ESSENTIALLY A
SOLE SOURCE. TYPE OF
APPROPRIATION AT SOME LATER
POINT WHEN IT DOES HAPPEN- CAN
YOU COMMENT ON THOSE TWO ITEMS
YES- THOUGH TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN THE BILL HAS ALREADY
BEEN SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR SO
THE MONEY'S THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNED SO FIRST QUESTION. THINK
TAKES CARE OF THE THIRD
QUESTION TO THE SECOND QUESTION
IS WHY SCRIPTS SO THIS IS A
VERY PARTICULAR TYPE OF SCIENCE
OF UNDERSTANDING WHY PLUS FEEL.
SCRIPTURES ALREADY STARTED WITH
LIGHTER STUDIES IN THIS AREA
AND THE SCIENCE THAT WE DEVELOP
BEHIND LOVE FAILURES FOR THIS
AREA. IS APPLICABLE STATE WIDE
SO IT EVEN THOUGH IT'S YOU KNOW
DOING IT FROM TORREY PINES
OCEANSIDE IT IS- BE APPLICABLES
STATEWIDE AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
DONE THE SCIENTIFIC WORKS OF
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. DOESN'T
DO SCIENTIFIC STUDIES OF- YOU
KNOW Q. PHYSICS AND ON THAT
TYPE OF STUFF THAT'S WHAT
SCRIPTS AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
USING SCRIPTS THEY'VE ALREADY
DONE IT THEY HAVE THE KNOW HOW.
AND THEY HAVE THE SCIENTISTS
WHO CAN ACTUALLY DEVELOP THE
SCIENCE BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN I
WENT TO SCRIPT AND SAID I WANT
TO EARLY MORNING WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM FOR BLOOD
FIGURES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY SAID HOLD ON
FOR A HORA FIRST WE HAVE TO GO
BACK AND WE NEED TO KNOW WE
KNOW BLESS FEEL AND WE KNOW
AFTER THE FACT ONE OF THE FIELD
WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO PREDICT
IT. SO THAT'S THE FOR THE
EIGHTY SIXTY SIX OF THE FIRST
PHASE OF A THREE PHASE PLAN
THAT I HAVE AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL JOIN ME IN THAT JOURNEY-
TO CREATE THE SCIENCE AROUND
THE PHILLIES INCLUDED EARLY
WARNING NOTIFICATION SYSTEM ALL
RIGHT SO WE DON'T HAVE JUST TO
BE CLEAR WE DON'T HAVE ANY SOLE
SOURCE. RELATED ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE END OF THE MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND CAPABLE OF
CONDUCTING THE STUDY. AND THAT
THE YOU IDENTIFY THAT THERE
DOLLARS ARE ALREADY IN THE
QUEUE- I THINK THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC AND-
BECAUSE I DO SUPPORT. IT MAKE
THE MOTION AT THE PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU- BOARD JUST MORE THE
BILL. SAYING NO OTHER MICRO.
RAISED- SO REMEMBER. BURNER OR
BOX DO YOU CARE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLE. THERE
CENTER BOARD JUST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS IS AT SIXTY SIX
A PRICE OF A MEMBER BURNER FOR
BASH WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
BORDERS THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER HI. AMBER
BY PORGES GORGEOUSI CAN BE AT
ALL. YET ALL I DID I SO. DID I
SO I WENT ON THIS. ONE SO THIS
I. HURTS BURG. JONES LAYERED-
LAYERED ICE STERN. WHITE HOUSE
SCHEME BY BY CAL SKI I WINNER.
WINNER I. GIVE THE EIGHT SO FAR
ALL RIGHTY WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL NEXT WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHT B. FOUR EIGHT
ZERO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAL.
CLOSURES THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY A
MEASURE THAT WILL STRAIN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION AGAINST LOCAL THREATS.
TO THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY INCLUDING THE ABILITY
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
DIRECT A FACILITY OR A PORTION
OF THE FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS
THAT. COST AND EXPOSURE. IN
CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES HAVE JURISDICTIONS
OVER THE BUSINESSES THAT HANDLE
OR GENERATE HAZARDOUS WASTE
MATERIALS AND THAT POSE A RISK
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. LOCALLY A CERTIFIED
UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY ALSO
KNOWN AS KOUBA IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LAWS AND THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER HAS GENERAL THIRTY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH
EXPANDED THIRTY. ONLY AFTER A
COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED CURRENTLY. SOME
FACILITIES THAT EMIT HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES CONTINUE TO OPERATE
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT EET
REGULATORY MINIMUM STANDARDS TO
CEASE OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY. A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES BEING THE EXIDE
BATTERY RECYCLING FACILITY IN
VERNON CALIFORNIA WHICH-
CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSED FAMILIES
AND RESIDENTS OF MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. AND OUR URROUNDING
COMMUNITIES TO DANGEROUS LEVELS
OF TOXIC LET. THE DELAY TO SHUT
THIS FACILITY DOWN LED TO
EMISSIONS FROM THE PLANT
CONTAMINATING MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND. OF OUR RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ACROSS A NUMBER OF
pCOMMUNITIES INCLUDING BOYLE
HEIGHTS IN EAST LOS ANGELES AND
I WOULD JUST SAY. NOT ONLY-
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES PARCELS
INCLUDING SCHOOLS AND PARKS.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY WILL ENABLE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT
THE FACILITY OR A PORTION OF
THE FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS.
THAT HAVE EXPOSED OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HARMFUL TOXIC
MATERIALS UNTIL THE ISSUE WAS
CORRECTED. FOR THE PAST TWO.
YEARS I HAVE WORKED TO BRING
GREATER AUTHORITY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE ACTION AGAINST THE
THREATS OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH. I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT I TOOK
THE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION WHO HAVE NOW GONE
NEUTRAL. THE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
COUPONS TO FOLLOW DEPARTMENT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS REGULATIONS WITH
RESPECTS TO REPORTABLE AMOUNTS.
INTO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ADOPTS ITS REGULATIONS
ON THE SUBJECT. I HAVE ALSO
ADDED LEGISLATIVE INTENT WITH
RESPECT TO DESCRIBING WHAT
IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL THREAT
IS GIVEN THAT THERE IS NO
STATUTORY DEFINITION FOR THE
TERM AT THIS TIME. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE. ON THIS
VERY URGENT ISSUE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. AVAILABLE
TO TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE AND
SUPPORT IS JUSTIN ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER I JUST
MILAN. IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. READING.
MANY MEMBERS JUST TO LEARN
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE COOPERS
THIRSTY THANK YOU ALSO FOR
STICKING WITH THIS ISSUE IT'S A
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
AND THANKS TO LA COUNTY PEOPLE
ARE CO SPONSORING THIS BILL
WITH US BECAUSE OF THE- WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION THAT WE HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT IT'S JUST MYSELF
TESTIFYING AND I WANT TO CUT TO
THE CHASE. WE HAVE. BALANCED
BILL HERE. EXOGAMY AND ALSO IN
THE NECESSARY SAFETY AND DUE
PROCESS. WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
LEAD COUNSEL IN CRAFTING THIS
LANGUAGE AND AT THIS STAGE WHAT
I CAN DO IS- WHICH I BOUGHT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MILAN ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE NOW ON THE PHONE
LINE. MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY. WE'D ALL BE GRATEFUL.
YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN JUST A MOMENT.
OKAY WE GO TO LINE TWO OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM NIELSEN MCMURRAY BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BUT-
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE JUST A MOMENT.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
R. I. C. ONE MOMENT THAT THE
DISPUTE UP.
MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE AND SUPPORT. YES I WOULD
GO TO LINE TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
BIRTHDAY COMING WITH THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PALCO SPONSOR ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE MODERATOR IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ANYWAYS
DOES FIVE OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY SEE NONE. REAL ONE
TWELVE SAYING NONE- ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHES TO MAKE
THEMSELVES HEARD IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY. FOUR EIGHTY. IF YOU
LIKE THE COMMON OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY. PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THE TIME. AT A TIME
THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE
ALREADY THANK YOU I SEE SAID A
WHITE HOUSE THESE MICROPHONES
RAISE ENOUGH COME DUE NEXT AN
EARLIER. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
SITTING HERE IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THE STAFF REPORT PORT POINTS
OUT THAT VIRTUALLY ALL THE
NOTICE HEARING AND REVIEW
PROCEDURES. IN THIS BILL ARE
IDENTICAL TO EXISTING
HAZARDOUS. MATERIALS LAWS IN
THIS LAW ADDRESSES SPILLS AND
RELEASES IN THE- THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES FOR THE REVIEW OF
ADMINISTRATIVE DECISIONS. ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
BY FILING FILING A WRIT OF
MANDATE SO. I WOULD MOVE TO
BILL AND APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND
THE STAFF FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
SUCH A- WELL CRAFTED MEASURE.
ALREADY APPROVED AND APPLAUDED
CENTER LAYERED. I WOULD SAY THE
SOONER OUR CASKET JUST ACTUALLY
MADE THE APPROPRIATE POINTS
WHICH IS SPEAKING TO THE
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION. AND
WHAT IS IMPORTANT IN THE BILL
ON THE POLICY WHICH MIGHT NOT
BE DIRECTLY IN FRONT OF IT.
THIS IS A LOGICAL NEXT STEP.
BECAUSE THE COOPERS FLY UNDER
THE RADAR MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE IF YOU IF
THEY HEARD OF THOUGHT MAN YET.
THEY'RE VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
UNDERGROUND HAZARDOUS
SITUATIONS OVER GROUND AND THEY
PROVIDE A REGIONAL OR BROADER
RESPONSE THAN JUST A SINGLE
AGENCY AND SO GIVING THEM THE
AUTHORITY. AN EMINENT THREATS
IS A GOOD PUBLIC POLICY MOVE
AND THERE'S A REASON THAT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION. IN THE
ANALYSIS AND SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKIS MOTION. THANK YOU
SIX ALERT ALL RIGHT. SIR
RUSSELL THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
AUTHOR- I KNOW BECAUSE WE SHARE
AN OVERLAP DISTRICTS THAT. THE
ISSUES- BASE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES- WORK OF.
EXTRAORDINARY EXTRAORDINARY
DANGER AND CONCERN AND I'M GLAD
THIS SHE HAD PUT THIS BILL
TOGETHER THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO SAYING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRILL. THANKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THINK
THAT THE SENATORS FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT. GOOD
LEGISLATION TAKES TIME AND IT
TAKES BOTH OPPOSITION AND-
THOSE IN SUPPORT TO COME TO THE
TABLE TO ACTUALLY REALIZE. THE
INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN MY COMMUNITY B. EXIDE
BATTERY PLANT CONTAMINATION
THAT LED TO A USC STUDY. THAT
SHOWED THAT CHILDREN WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR BABY TEETH HAVE LEAD
IN THEIR BABY TEETH THERE'S NO
AMOUNT OF BLOOD THAT IS SAFE
FOR THE HUMAN BODY. AND WHEN
YOU BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT THE
ISSUES OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND
CLIMATE JUSTICE AND THE WAY IN
WHICH GOVERNMENT IS MEANT TO
PROTECT COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE
OFTEN PLACES WHERE WE GET TO
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PATH AND
ALIGN THE LAW TO ENSURE THAT
THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. ARE PROTECTED AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT WILL ENSURE THAT THERE
IS NO OTHER EXCITE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THAT HAVE
GONE TOWARDS THE CLEAN UP.
TOWARDS HOLDING DTC RESPONSIBLE
FOR THEIR NEGLIGENCE AND THAT
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE
DAY EXIDE FILE BANKRUPTCY WHICH
IS GONNA END UP BEING PAID FOR
BY ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM AND
BY THE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
THAT CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
BECAUSE OF THESE AWFUL-
REGULATIONS THAT WERE NOT TAKEN
CARE OF AND SO THIS IS A- A
RESPONSIBLE. AND PROACTIVE STEP
FORWARD IT IS A COMMON SENSE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THAT WILL
ENABLE OUR LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
ACT IN THE INTERESTS OF. OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND BETTER PROTECT
OUR EIGHTIES HELP AND SEE.
WHILE COORDINATING WITH THE
PROPER AGENCY AND I RESPECT
REQUEST AND I BUILT THANK YOU.
A MAN INTO CUSTODY CALL RULES
IN THE WHITE HOUSE KEYS MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU THIS IS
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE FAMILY
MEMBER CABRIO WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI. AMBER
I PORGES. WE HAD A- ZERO I DID
I SAW. THAT I SAW I HAD GONE
SILAS GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG.
JONES LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI. BY
CASSIDY I WINNER WINNER I. YOU
HAVE SEVEN TO ZERO SO AR
ALREADY WE'LL PUT THAT BILLING
CALL THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE A B. I
REMEMBER TEN A. B. ONE FOUR
EIGHT SEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER
GABRIEL. WHO IS PRESENT.
REMEMBER GABRIEL WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND KNOWN AS THE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION FUND TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VALUABLE RENTERS AND HELP
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS BEFORE
AGAINST. THIS BILL IS BASED ON
THREE KEY NOTIONS THE FIRST IS
THAT EVICTION DEFENSE IS KEY TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESSING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE'VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME AND MONEY FOCUSED
ON HOW TO HELP FOLKS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
NOT ENOUGH TIME TO FOCUS ON HOW
WE CAN PREVENT HOMELESSNESS IN
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST%
INSTANCE AND THE DATA MAKES
CLEAR TO US ON THIS THAT
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION IS KEY.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ON
AVERAGE EVERY SINGLE DAY TWO
HUNDRED SEVEN PEOPLE ARE PUT
INTO HOUSING AND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE BECOME
NEWLY HOMELESS SO EVERY SINGLE
DAY THE PROBLEM IS GETTING
WORSE AND WE KNOW THAT
EVICTIONS ARE PLAYING A KEY
ROLE IN DRIVING HOMELESSNESS
AND SO IF WE WANT TO BE SERIOUS
ABOUT ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
INFECTIONS THE SECOND IS THAT
LEGAL SERVICES ARE AN EXTREMELY
COST EFFECTIVE BEYOND. THAT
AFFECT A BIT AND AN OVERALL
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION AND AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES THE TENANT
PROTECTIONS THAT WE'VE ENACTED
RECENTLY ARE NOT SELF
EXECUTING. THAT THEY REQUIRE
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
LEGAL PROCESS AND RIGHTS AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES. WE ALSO KNOW FROM
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED AND
RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE INTO
THAT LEGISLATION. THAT RIGHT TO
COUNSEL PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS AND THIS IS. THE
RESULT OF INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS
THAT WAS DONE AROUND THE
SHRIVER PROGRAM AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AND WE KNOW THAT. IN
MOST CASES FOLKS WHO ARE
REPRESENTED IN A FICTION
PROCEEDINGS ARE 30% MORE LIKELY
TO BE HOUSED. A YEAR LATER
BASED ON THE LONGITUDINAL
STUDIES THAT THEY'VE DONE
FOLLOWING FOLKS WHO ARE IN A
FICTION PROCEEDINGS HORTON WHO
WERE WHO WERE REPRESENTED. AND
WHO WERE UNDER REPRESENTED. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE YOUR THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PROVEN TO SAVE
TAXPAYER RESOURCES AND ANALYSIS
A BIT. OF FICTION DEFENSE
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES FOUND
THAT FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR
INVESTED THERE'S ABOUT FOUR
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS A
PUBLIC BENEFIT AND AVOIDED
COSTS AND SO THE PROGRAM THAT
WE- ARE PROPOSING TODAY- IS
CAREFULLY CRAFTED TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS. AND
AREAS OF EXPERTISE. AND THE
THIRD PREMISE ON WHICH THIS
BILL IS BASED IS THAT
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM. WE KNOW THAT 90% OF
LANDLORDS ARE REPRESENTED-
COMPARED TO APPROXIMATELY 10%
OF TENANTS. AND THEN. AND THAT
THIS BILL IS GOING TO HELP
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE REPRESENTATION DOESN'T
CHANGE THE SUBSTANTIVE LAW IT
DOESN'T CHANGE LEGAL RIGHTS OR
DUTIES IT DOESN'T PUT A THUMB
ON THE SCALE. IN MERELY MEANS
THAT EVICTION PROCEEDINGS ARE
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE DECIDED.
BASED ON THE FACTS AND THE LAW
RATHER THAN SIMPLY ON THE
ABILITY TO AFFORD AN ATTORNEY
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO HELP
FOLKS. SECURE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
IN A MANNER THAT IS GOING TO
HELP SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES IT'S
GOING TO SAVE TAXPAYER
RESOURCES. AND IT'S GOING TO
HELP OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM LIVE UP
TO ITS IDEALS. AND THAT'S PART
OF THE REASON THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF MORE THAN FIFTY. NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY AND FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON BEHALF OF ONE
OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS TO SASHA
HARMON FROM THE INNER CITY LAW
CENTER. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU SALOON NUMBER GABRIEL I
WANT TO WELCOME OUR GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY WERE PLEASED TO SEE
CALIFORNIA'S COMING TO WATCH
THEIR GOVERNMENT ACTION
PARTICULARLY YOUNG PEOPLE SO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY-
ALL RIGHT. TURNING TO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS. THE ALEXANDER
HARDEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS ALEXANDER HARD AND
OFTEN IN A SOFT HARD AND WITH
THE INNER CITY LAW CENTER ARE
PROUD TO. BUY INTO FORTY FIVE
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
BUT IT'S STILL A GOOD
INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY THAT WILL HELP BENEFIT
NOT ONLY FOR THE LOW INCOME
RENTERS FACING EVICTION BUT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE COURT IN
OUR STATE OF THE WHOLE. BILL
INVENTED PROVEN MODEL THAT IS
EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFECTUATE ANY AFFECTION
PROTECTION THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
BONOBO CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
DOES NOT EXPAND OR INCREASE THE
RATE DEPENDENCE WITH RESPECTIVE
ACTIONS. BUT RATHER MAKE THE
PROTECTIONS ALREADY IN PLACE
REAL. PERTINENT LUCKY ENOUGH TO
FIND AN ATTORNEY. CONVICTION
PROTECTIONS ARE MOSTLY WORKING
AS INTENDED TO KEEP THE HOUSE.
HOWEVER THE TENANTS ARE UNABLE
TO. TO SECURE UNLIMITED LEGAL
RESOURCES I'VE EXPERIENCED A
RANGE OF CHALLENGES TRYING TO
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS IN COURT.
EVEN WHEN THE PROTECTIONS APPLY
TO ABOUT. PROGRAMS FUNDED BY A
COURT EIGHTY FIVE AND WHAT.
I'VE BEEN FOUND TO DROP IT
IMPROVE CASE OUTCOMES FOR
TENANT TO GO I'M REPRESENTED A
PARK RATE DESCRIBED BY SOME
NUMBER GABRIEL. LOCAL OF ALL
BEEN SHOWN TO RESULT IN
NUMEROUS DOCUMENTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NOT ONLY IN THE FORM
OF DECREE SHELTER AND RELATED
SERVICE PARTS BUT ALSO FROM
INCREASED COMMUNITY STABILITY.
AT THE SAME TIME THE VICTIM
PREVENTION PROGRAMS CAN FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE COURT TO
DECREASE FILINGS REDUCED ERROR
COMPILING THINK CORPORATE THAT
THERE IS AN INCREASED
RESOLUTION OF CASES INCLUDING.
BEFORE THEY EVER REACH THE
COURTHOUSE STEPS. FINALLY
PROGRAM FUNDED UNDER THE CAN
IMPROVE RACIAL EQUITY IN CASE
OUTCOMES AND HELP STABILIZE THE
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY. RESULTING IN
OTHER UNQUANTIFIABLE BENEFITS
LIKE IMPROVED SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
BY CHILDREN WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
BE DESTRUCTIVE. THIS BILL WILL
HELP ENSURE THE STATE'S
ELECTION PROTECTION AND RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ARE
SUCCESSFUL WILL RESULT IN
CRITICAL SAVINGS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE
TO SHARE IN AND CONTRIBUTE TO
AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE EUROPE. THANK
YOU MR HARDEN ALL RIGHT OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE IN THE GALLERY WHENWINDSOR ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE AND ONE TWELVE. LET'S TURN
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY ONE FOUR EIGHT SEVEN.
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL IT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A B. ONE FOUR EIGHT
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE HAVE CURRENTLY
ELEVEN IN Q. FIRST TO GO TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR TURN NUMBER WILL
BE AT THE LEAST SHOP ON HALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHOULD AFTERNOON LIBBY SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF S. E. I. U.
CALIFORNIA AND FROM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS HE NEVER COLLEGE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. I LIKE TO GO TO LINE TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE
WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE V. ONE FOR EACH OTHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ALEX
KEPPLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GLORIA CHEUNG CALLING
WITH THAT FAMILY VIOLENCE THE
PILOT PROJECT IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON HE
SCORED THE WINNER WITH HOUSING
NOW- STATEWIDE COVERAGE AT THE
ADVOCACY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I COULD GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER PAUL WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER INSTRUCTOR
FOR THE BEST THANK YOU THANK
YOU. CONNECT TO THE TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH ORIC
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY IN OUR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA STAFF
MEMBERS PARTNERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA RENTERS AND THEIR
PETS HOW. THANK YOU. I LIKE TO
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS PRISCILLA MARTINEZ
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF. THE
NEEDLES AND FRIENDLY STRONG
SUPPORT ET. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FOR TENANTS IN THE
SANDBOX GENE. THANK YOU. BUT I
COULD GO TO LINE ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ALEX ARE SOLANO
VIROLOGISTS PROGRAM SPECIALIST
ON THEIR CATHOLIC CHARITIES
THAT BROUGHT IN AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO PUSH OUR SUPPORT FOR A.
B. FOURTEEN NINETY. EIGHT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
A MORAL LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND
TENANTS IN SANTA CAN VALLEY AND
OTHER RURAL COUNTIES WHO ARE.
MOST VULNERABLE TO TOO HIGH
PROPERTY RETIREMENT LITTLE
ACCESS TO FREE LEGAL SERVICES-
WE NEED TRADITION PARTY TO HELP
KEEP FAMILIES HEALTH WHICH IS
WHY WE SUPPORT. AT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LAUREN KLEIN
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE TO TWELVE PLEASE
BUT I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBER MY NAME IS TINA
MCCANN ERICKSON AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF A BOY PLEASE
SUPPORT AT A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FROM LA COUNTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT GO TO LINE TWO
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS RICHARD SHOULD BE READ
I WOULD PAY FOR THE VALLEY
CENTER IN MODESTO AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE HOW LONG. FANS
PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
WE GO TO LINE TWO OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
ANTHONY I'M AT THE PLATE IN THE
VALLEY MAY SAID HERE IN
MODESTO- WE STAND STRONG WITH
TENANTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ANOTHER ROLE I'M
COUNTIES ARE MOST LIABLE HI HOW
WOULD YOU RATE. AND WHO HAVE
LITTLE ACCESS TO LEGAL SERVICES
YOU DO NEED SUFFICIENT FUNDING
CARE KERR FAMILIES WHEN I WAS.
IN THE VALLEY I SUMERIAN
SUPPORT POINTS. AT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CONTAINING THE NEIGHBORHOOD
LEGAL SERVICES OF LA COUNTY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT FINANCIALLY
ABLE OF ONE FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. GOT
IT THANK YOU. TO GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
PETER AND OFFENSIVE THE TROIKA
REPRESENTING NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTOR PORTED AT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS AJ
HUDSON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATE. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE LIENT TO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR UNION
HEALTHY WITH FAITH IN THE
VALLEY AND I AM CALLING ON-
FROM BURFORD KNOWN LOCATION-
INTO STRAWBERRIES ON SUPPORTED
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
MODERATE CAN YOU GIVE US AN
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY OTHER
FOLKS ON THE LINE. THERE'S ONE
MORE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE TIGHTNESS OF THE
MOTOR IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
NUMBER ANYTIME CLEAN AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
MODERN ORDERS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S TURN
NOW TO OPPOSITION I'VE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION-
DEBORAH CALLED CARLTON IN
JENNIFER'S SEX. THIS GIRL KNOW
YOU ON THE PHONE. YES I AM
THANK YOU SIR GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- DEBRA
CARLTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION FIRST I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT WE DO
NOT OBJECT TO THE FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION ABOUT THE EVICTION
PROCESS WHAT WE DO OBJECT TO
HOWEVER IS THE METHOD USED BY
ATTORNEYS TO RECEIVE THIS MONEY
WHEN IT COMES TO DOUBLE DELAYS
THE DECREASE IN THE COURT. WE
ALREADY HAVE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LEGAL DEFENSE
PUTTING ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
IN LOS ANGELES AND ANOTHERNINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN SAN
FRANCISCO YOU KNOW THIS BILL
INCLUDES FINDINGS ABOUT THE
SUCCESS RATE WHEN DOLLARS ARE
USED TO PROVIDE FOR LEGAL
DEFENSE. IRONICALLY HOWEVER
WHILE ATTORNEYS CAN HELP
TENANTS TO BLADE TO DELAY THEIR
OBJECTION IN NEARLY ALL CASES
THE TENANT IS EVENTUALLY
AFFECTED AND NOT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T PAY THE RENT IN MANY
CASES BUT HOWEVER THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT OWNERS ARE NOT IN
THE BUSINESS TO EVICT TENANTS
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE. AND IT'S
TOO TIME CONSUMING YOU KNOW YOU
CALL THIS A HOMELESS PREVENTION
FUND IF YOU'RE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS
YOU SHOULD PROVIDE FUNDS TO
HELP TENANTS PAY THEIR RENT
WHEN THEY ARE TEMPORARILY
UNABLE TO DO SO WITH THESE
DOLLARS THEY WOULDN'T FACE AN
EVICTION THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
THEIR CREDIT CARD AND THEY
COULD STAY IN THEIR RENTAL
UNITS INDEFINITELY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING. I ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARLTON. SPEC. AFTER
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JENNIFER STACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE'RE
TODAY WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. WHICH
ESTABLISHED OF THE HOMELESS THE
HOMELESS PREVENTION FUND TO
PROVIDE FREE LEGAL SERVICES TO
TENANTS IN THE PACIFIC WITH
ALLSTATE THE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES SHALL NOT BE PROVIDED
TO HOUSEHOLDS WHOSE INCOMES
EXCEED. 80% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. HOWEVER THE BUILDER
CONTAIN AMONG OTHER THINGS A
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWED ANY
TENANT REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME ELIGIBILITY. ACCESS TO
FREE LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDED
UNDER THE BELT. CONSIDERABLY A
LITTLE ENCOURAGING HIGHER
INCOME TENANTS TO ACCESS AN
ABUSE FREE LEGAL SERVICES. AT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FAILS TO
REQUIRE EVEN THE STYLE
VERIFICATION UNDER THE PENALTY
OF PERJURY AS PROOF OF THE
TENANT INCOME ELIGIBILITY.
SIMPLY STATED THE BILL PROVIDES
AN EXPANSIVE FUNDING SOURCE OF
FREE LEGAL SERVICES THE
TENTATIVE INCOME MAY WELL
EXCEED THE 80% LIMITATION. IN
INCOME AND ENCOURAGES TENANTS
YOU CAN AFFORD LEGAL COUNSEL TO
INSTEAD ABUSE RESOURCES THAT
MUST BE RESERVED FOR STATE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WHO CANNOT
AFFORD REPRESENTATION. I THINK
TO BE A RESOURCE IN THE
CREATION OF PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THOSE IN NEED.
UNFORTUNATELY AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED BECAUSE EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CONTAINS THIS AND
OTHER LOOPHOLES THAT WILL MOST
CERTAINLY BE ABUSED. THEY ARE
MUCH RESPECT WE OFFER NO VOTE
ON A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE OF THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE. IN
OPPOSITION TO A B. ONE FOUR
EIGHT SEVEN. YOU LIKE TO COME
IN OPPOSITION AND THAT AB ONE
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN. S. ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. WE HAVE ONE IN Q.
TWO AND Q. ONE MOMENT.
TO GO TO
LINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS WRONG
KINGSTON REPRESENTING SEVERAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS- THREE
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES
WHICH IS ALL OF SOUTHERN R. LA
COUNTY. INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATIONS
COVERING THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL IN OPPOSITION WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IN OUR-
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. I
NEED TO GO TO LINE TWO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CATAMARAN WITH- IN
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE ONE MORE
JUST A MOMENT. WE GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD- HI MY NAME IS RUTH SO
START WITH YOUNG INVINCIBLE- WE
ARE A PUBLIC POLICY NONPROFIT
THAT SEEKS TO EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR AGE-
BARGAIN RATIONS ON YOUNG ADULTS
AND THOSE IN COLLEGE WORKING ON
NOT- INTO BANKING THAT WE ARE
FACING LIFE ALTERING LEGALLY.
SEPARATION FINDING IT NECESSARY
TO INSURE THE LIVES OF OUR
FUTURE LEADERS AREN'T SHATTERED
WHICH IS WHY WE SUPPORT AT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN R. E. Q.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. NO ALL RIGHT AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE NO
THANK YOU. LET'S LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER- I SEE NO
MICROPHONES RACE EXCEPT FOR
CENTER COVER EUROS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR. PROPOSING
THIS BILL- I YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THE- THE ISSUES
BETWEEN LANDLORD AND TENANT BUT
QUITE FRANKLY- SOME OF THE
PRACTICES I HAVE BEEN TO GET
RID OF TENANTS HAVE BEEN PRETTY
OUTRAGEOUS DURING THIS VIRUS
AND- PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR LEGAL
RIGHTS ARE AND THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO BE REPRESENTED IF
THEY NEED TO GO TO COURT AND SO
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
I'M PREPARED TO MAKE THE MOTION
WHEN THE CHAIRS. ALL RIGHT
READY- SEEING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISE THE SENATOR-
CABRERA MOVES THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIELLE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. BY THANK YOU
JUST WOULD THANK THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU CENTER COVER YOUR OWN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. A
MAN CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY A
FAMILY MEMBER GABRIEL WITH A
MOTION BY. SENATOR KIRBY AT
ALL. THE MOTION IS DO PASS-
BERG HI AM BERG I PURCHASE.
ZERO CAREER I DID ALSO. THE
REST SO I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BURG. JONES LAYERED-
LAYERED I STERN WHITE HOUSE E.
Y. CASKEY I WINNER. WINNER I
YEAH OF SEVEN TO ZERO SO FAR
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL ON THE NEXT BILL IS ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN A. . FOUR FIVE
ZERO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ- AND- I'M GOING TO
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
WELCOME. SOMEONE EVER
CONSOLIDATES PLEASE PRESENT A
THING FOR FIVE HOURS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN VERS EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY WAS W. NEUTRON
INDEPENDENT PARAMEDIC
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW BOARD RIGHT
NOW THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY ISSUES
PARAMEDIC LICENSES CONDUCTS
DISCIPLINARY INVESTIGATIONS AND
PROSECUTES COMPLAINTS THEY HOLD
THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO MAKE
FINAL DETERMINATIONS AND
SERVICE INVESTIGATOR PROSECUTOR
JUDGE AND JURY. WHEN TAKING ANY
ACTION REGARDING PARAMEDIC
LICENSES. OTHER PARAMEDICS MAY
APPEAL AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE EVEN AFTER A LONG PROCESS
IT IS SIMPLY A PROPOSED
DECISION AND GOES BACK TO M.
SET FOR THE FINAL
DETERMINATION. NO OTHER
CALIFORNIA ISSUED MEDICAL
LICENSES LEFT IN THE HANDS OF A
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE A
FINAL AND BINDING DECISION WITH
SUCH DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF THE LICENSEES. EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY- ESTABLISH A BOARD
OF MEDICAL PEERS AND MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC TO BRING BALANCE AND
FAIRNESS TO THE PARAMEDIC
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORTS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE HEALTH TODAY I HAVE ON
THE LINE CHRISTY DOWN THE
COMPANY PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. MISSPELLED MY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS CHRISTINA I'M ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. BELIEVED TO BE
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE- OUR
OFFICERS SAID EVERYTHING AND
MORE I THINK I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THIS IS A BROKEN SYSTEM
THE BILL WILL. PROVIDE REMEDIES
AND DUE PROCESS TO THESE
PARAMEDICS PLACING FIXING
LICENSURE ACTIONS AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION HERE. THE BILL
MAKES APPROPRIATE FINDINGS TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT OF
ACCESS TO FINAL DISCIPLINARY
DETERMINATION THE PARAMEDIC
LICENSEES IS. PROTECTED WHILE
ALLOWING DUE PROCESS FOR THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE. OR
TAKEN TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE AUTHOR AND PURGE YOUR I
HOPE TODAY EXCELLENT NOW LET'S
MOVE TO THE SENATE GALLERY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ONE
TO TESTIFY HE SEEING NONE. OF
THE WITNESSES A ROOM ONE ONE
TWO TO TESTIFY FOR IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR FIVE OH THERE ARE
NONE. SO LET'S MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES TESTIFYING VIA
TELEONFERENCE SERVICE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FOUR FIVE OH. MODERATE
COMMENTS. OF A. B. FOUR FIVE L.
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. VERY
GOOD LET'S. LET'S HEAR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
IS HERE FROM OPPOSITION YSR WE
HAVE NO FORMAL OPPOSITION- THAT
I KNOW OF HIS OR ANYBODY HERE
IN THE CALORIE- TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR FIVE A
LITTLE FIT. ROOM ONE ONE TWO I
SEE NOBODY IN ROOM OE ONE TWO
AN OPPOSITION- LET'S GO TO THE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. FOUR
FIVE OO. LET'S BEGIN. THE LADY
COME IN OPPOSITION OF A B. FOR
BRAVO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE VERY
GOOD LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
FOR INFECTED- MEMBERS. IS SET
IN MOTION THAT I SEE FROM
SENATOR WINNERS- IT IS- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAYING
NONE. OF THE SEVEN MEMBER YOU
CAN PLEASE CLOSE THEY CAST
THEIR VOTE- CHIEF COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A
MOTION- WINNER YES THIS EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY WITH THEM AT BAY BY
FAMILY MEMBER- GONZALEZ. WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. FOR JESS
PROBABLY AT ALL. COPYRIGHT I
DID I SAW. THAT I SAW I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS BURKE
JONES LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI MY CASKEY I
MEAN- WINNER I THINK YOU HAVE
SIX TO ZERO SO FAR OKAY WE'LL
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER. TWELVE ON
OUR CALENDARS SOME MEMBER GRAY-
IS HERE READY 2% ON. AB TWO
THREE SEVEN THREE HAVE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU- BUSH CHAIRMAN
SENATORS EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN PROHIBITS PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS FROM TERMINATING THE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE OF
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR DEPENDENTS
DURING A WORK STOPPAGE FOR A
STRIKE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS I UNDERSTAND
I BELIEVE MONICA DAILY OWN AND
JANICE ON. O'MALLEY COLOR COLOR
ZERO ARE ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY
MYSTERIO. IF YOU'RE THERE
PLEASE PROCEED. YES THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONICA BAILEY ON I AM THE
EXECUTIVE TREASURE AFTER ME
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE.
REPRESENTING SERVICE WORKERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE JANITORS. THE
GROUNDSKEEPERS. CAFETERIA
WORKERS AND MEDICAL ASSISTANCE.
YOU THE STATE LEGISLATURE GAVE
US THE RIGHT TO STRIKE. AND
WHEN WE THE WORKERS INSIDE
EXERCISE THAT RIGHT. WE DO SELL
AFTER WAITING ALL OTHER OPTIONS.
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO ON STRIKE WE
SACRIFICE. WE ARE PAID WE MAKE
THAT SACRIFICE IN THE HOPE WE
CAN IMPROVE OUR LIVES AND THAT
OF OUR FAMILIES. HOWEVER THERE
IS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR USING
MEDICINE FOR LIFE SAVING
TREATMENT AS A WEAPON AGAINST
EXERCISING THAT RIGHT. FOR US
WE EXPERIENCED A RECENT THREAT%
AT UC SANTA CRUZ WHEN THEY
INFORMED US THAT IF WE REMAINED
ON STRIKE THAT WE WOULD LOSE
OUR FAMILY HEALTH COVERAGE. THE
HERD ACTOR YOU SEE NEW THAT IS
STRIKING LEADER SADDAM WAS
BATTLING BRAIN CANCER. WE THINK
ASSEMBLYMEN GREAT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL WHICH
HELPS CLARIFY THAT THE
WEAPONIZATION OF HEALTHCARE IS
NOT PERMITTED IN THE STATE WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR LEE SEOW. PLEASE
PROCEED. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE MEMBERS- JENNIFER NOW
LEGALLY DO A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE MEMBERS OF
ACNE THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
ALONG WITH MANY OF OUR
STALLIONS THE CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCILS ACROSS THE STATE TO
BELIEVE. THAT WITHHOLDING AN
EMPLOYEE HEALTH CARE WHILE I'M
STRAIGHT. APPALLING AND
UNLAWFUL. THE CODE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC DEMONSTRATED
UNMISTAKABLY. PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT EVERYONE. THERE SHOULD
NEVER BE AN AT ANY INCENTIVE TO
REJECT PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES THE DAMAGE TO
THEIR FAMILIES INTO THE ENTIRE
POPULATION CAN DO THIS AFTER.
ALLOWING EMPLOYERS TO WEAPONIZE
ACCENT HEALTHCARE SIMPLY TO
GAIN AN ADVANTAGE IN THEIR
NEGOTIATIONS. NOT ONLY
INCREDIBLY UNFAIR BUT DANGEROUS
OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY. THE FACT
THAT THERE IS NO EXISTING
STATUTORY PROHIBITION AGAINST
PUT THEM FOR YOU AT AN UNFAIR
DISADVANTAGE AND EVEN THE
THREAT OF SUCH ACTION BY AN
EMPLOYER SERVES TO WEAPONIZE
HERE IN THE RETENTION OF
BENEFIT. UNFAIR SCARE TACTIC
SHOULD NEVER BE USED. TO
DISSUADE AN EMPLOYEE FROM THE
EXERCISE OF THEIR RIGHT UNDER
THE LAW. EMPLOYERS MUST BE
PROHIBITED FROM CONTINUING TO
BENEFIT FROM THE DEGREE JUST
BEHAVIOR. THE CALIFORNIA LABOR%
FEDERATION BELIEVE THAT D. B.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD. TO
ENSURING THAT ALL PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS COULD STILL RECEIVE
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE. DESPITE
MAKING THE DIFFICULT DECISION
TO GO ON STRIKE. WE CAN GET
SOME WOMEN GRAY FRINGE WE DO
SHIP ON THE BILL TO PROTECT OUR
PUBLIC SECTORS. WORKERS AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU OKAY LET'S MOVE
TO THE SENATE CALORIE OTHER
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY DID LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE
WILL TURN OUR ATTENTION TO ROOM
ONE ONE TO SEEING NOBODY THEIR
FAITH TESTIFY MODERATOR LET'S
START THE US HEARING FROM
SUPPORT WITNESSES WAITING
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE.
SERVICES YOU MAY BEGIN. LIKE A
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWO
THREE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT FIRST WE
GO TO A LINE ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LADIES SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
S. E. I. U. CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT IN MEXICO
TO MINE TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
CONSTANT BUT SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
PORT STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE TWO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MICHAEL YOUNG WITH
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ALSO STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK MICHAEL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WORK
FOR YOU. BACKGROUND. THANK YOU
FOR THE- NEXT. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE TWO FOURTEEN. I HAVE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CATAMARAN
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THE MEDICAL GO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
SHARE WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES. CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AVAILABLE
AGAIN I'M A UC BERKELEY JUNIOR
CUSTODIANS NICE TO COURT A. B.
DIVISION SEVEN. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO NINE TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANGEL GUERRERO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS EIGHTY NINE.
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NINE TO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN JUST LATER BY THE
LOCALS ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL
COMMITTEE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE MEXICO
TO LINE ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE
RIGHT BACK I AM A SENIOR
STUDENT AT UC RIVERSIDE AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY SEVEN. WHAT AN
EXCELLENT LINE OF ONE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DONNA MCKINLEY ROLAND PARK
ACTIVE CAMPING I AM IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. TWO THREE SEVEN. THE
MEXICO TWO NINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
OSCAR ROMEO I WORK FOR UCLA I'M
UP OF WORKER I'M TO FOUR
EIGHTY. TWO THIRTY SEVEN. NEXT
TO THE TO LINE TWO THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON THE HOUSE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY TWO. OR TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. VERY
GOOD- LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT IS
HERE TO SPEAK ON A PROPOSING HI
A. B. THREE THREE SEVEN. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
ONE TWO IT SAYS FINE OPPOSITION
SAYING NONE LET'S- GO BACK TO
THE- THE- TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS. WHO
WAITED TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
A. B. TWO THREE SEVEN. PLEASE
BEGIN. YES IF YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY SEVEN PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO BE JUST A
MOMENT- WE GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS TERRIBLE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. VERY GOOD
LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC CARE VERY
IMPACTED- MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS- A SIMILAR GRAY I
NOTICED THAT IN THE OPPOSITION
IT WAS FILED BY U. C. THEN THE
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SAY.
THEY INDICATED THEY'VE NEVER
PROACTIVELY LOOK TO CUT OFF
DURING A STRIKE THE HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS OF FOLKS IN THAT THEY
INDICATE THAT MOST OF THE TIME
THE STRUCTURE A FEW DAYS AND
THAT IN THEIR CURRENT LAW IF
THE- IF THE EMPLOYEE WORKS HALF
A MONTH IN THERE- A BENEFITS
WOULD CONTINUE. TO SORT OF AN
INDICATION THAT IT MAY BE. MAY
NOT BE NECESSARY WHAT DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THOSE.
OF FORMAL OPPOSITION. YEAH I
THINK. THERE'S A STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT CURRENT LAW DOES
PROTECT WORKERS FROM THIS
EGREGIOUS PACTICE HAVING SAID
THAT I THINK- CODIFYING THIS
PRACTICE AND THIS NORMAN
HOPEFULLY ALL OF THIS BILL ONLY
SPEAKS. TO PUBLIC EMPLOYERS I
WOULD HOPE THIS BECOMES THE
NORM WITH EVEN PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS IT IS JUST
UNCONSCIONABLE AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS- DURING THE PANDEMIC AS
MANY SMALL. AND LARGE
BUSINESSES- STRUGGLED TO ADAPT
TO BASICALLY CHANGING
CONDITIONS BY THE DAY. WE DON'T
WANT SOMEBODY'S HEALTH CARE. TO
GET LOST IN THE SHUFFLE. OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT AND SO I THINK
MAYBE TWO THIRTY SEVEN- MAKES
THAT. MESSAGE SENDS THAT
MESSAGE FRANKLY MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS THE PRACTICE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- THIS IS OUR
EXPECTATION AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I THINK IT IS A
CRITICAL BILL EVEN IF- YOU SEE
OR ANYONE ELSE FOR THAT MATTER
ASSERTS THAT. THEY CURRENTLY
DON'T ENGAGE- IN DISMISSING-
EMPLOYEES DURING A- WORK
STOPPAGE OR STRIKE OKAY AND
THEIR HEALTH CARE I KNOW I-
HAVE GREAT INTEREST IN LAST
YEAR'S BILL BY THERE YOU ALSO
AUTHORED AB THREE TO FOUR-
WHICH HELP PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE STAFF REPORT.
IS HE TALKED ABOUT THE ACTIONS
THAT- THE UNITED AUTO WORKERS-
THE FACE WITH IT IN AN ACTUAL
STRIKE THAT WAS. MY TRADITIONAL
MODEL OF THE BAD EMPLOYER
HURTING THE AND- THE EMPLOYEE
I'M IN AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION
I'M GONNA STAY OFF THE BILL
TODAY JUST TO JUST TO BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T HAD DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE- THE
OPPOSITION. BUT I SEE TO WRITE-
SENATOR ALSO YOU HAVE YOUR MIKE
UP. YES THANK YOU- I'M REALLY
GLAD THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
INTRODUCED THIS BILL- THERE IS
AN IMBALANCE CLEARLY AN
IMBALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN
WHETHER IT'S A PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE EMPLOYER IN THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS. WHERE IF THE
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY WERE. THAT
WORK FOR THEM WANT TO GO OUT ON
STRIKE THEY HAVE TO. THEY HAVE
TO CONSIDER EVERYTHING FROM
WHETHER THEY'LL HAVE INCOME OR
NOT HAVE INCOME. AND THE FACT
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO FACE
ALSO THE LOSS OF HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THE EMPLOYER WOULD STOP
PAYING FOR THAT HEALTH CARE
THAT IS NOT A PASSIVE DECISION
THAT MAY BE. THIS IS A VERY
SPECIFIC AND DELIBERATE
DECISION. THAT WOULD BE MADE I
SEE IN THE OPPOSITION COMMENTS-
THAT THERE IS A BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT SAYS. YOU SEE CURRENTLY PAYS
FOR COVERED HEALTH CARE COSTS
DURING THE STRIKE AS LONG AS
THE EMPLOYEE WORKS AT LEAST
HALF THE HOURS WE MUST NOT A
STRIKE. AND IF YOU'RE ON STRIKE
YOU KNOW WORKING HALF THE HOURS
SO CLEARLY THE POLICY OF UC AND
IN THIS CASE I'M JUST REFERRING
TO THEM BECAUSE OF THEIR
RESPONSE. CLEARLY THEY'RE
MAKING A DECISION THEY WOULD
MAKE A DECISION TO NOT COVER
HEALTH CARE DURING THE STRIKE.
THEY'RE ALREADY THOSE EMPLOYEES
ARE ALREADY HAVING TO FACE NO
NOT HAVING ANY INCOME. AND THEN
ON TOP OF THAT I THINK THIS
IT'S AN ABUSE OF THE POWER- I
THINK IT'S INHUMANE AND I'M
REALLY GLAD TO SEE THAT- WE'RE
ADDRESSING THIS NOW. FROM AND
THE FACT THAT WHEN THEY SAY
ALSO THAT THE UNIVERSITY DOES
NOT IMPEDE AN EMPLOYEE'S RIGHT
TO STRIKE. THE FACT ALL BY
DENYING THEM ON BY ACTIVELY
DECIDE DECIDING NOT TO PAY FOR
THE HEALTH CARE THEY ARE THAT'S
AN EXAMPLE OF IMPEDING THAT
EMPLOYEES RIGHT TO STRIKE SO I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND-
I WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THIS AS WELL THANK YOU.
OTHER MEMBERS. A SUMMARY
BROTHER THAT- A SECOND SENTENCE
OKAY SORRY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I KNOW IT'S HARD DURING
UP THERE AND SING THE GLARE
BUT- I TOO WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT'S IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT- THIS IS A
PRACTICE GOING ON. IN OUR STATE.
AND SO- OF COURSE I WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL I'D LIKE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR- BUT AS THE
STATE IS MAKING. INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND HEALTH
CARE FOR FOLKS. THIS MAKES NO
SENSE WHATSOEVER. AND SO I
REALLY- YOU KNOW KNOW THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TAKING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THAT SENSE TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOLKS TO FIND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO STRIKE. THEY
HAVE COVERAGE FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES THAT IS A BASIC
RIGHT THANK YOU. I SEE NO OTHER
MIKES UP OF SEVEN OR GREATER
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU-
SENATORS FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS AND DELIBERATION I DO
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT BILL
AND I'LL JUST SAY THIS I HAVE A
YOUNGER SISTER WHO LIVES WITH
TYPE ONE DIABETES AND SHE'S
LIVE WITH THAT CONDITION SINCE
SHE WAS TWO YEARS OLD. AND IF
MY MOTHER WERE FOR THE POSITION
OF LOSING. HER HEALTH CARE
STANDING UP FOR HER RIGHTS AND
HER PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT AND SHE
HAD TO CONSIDER THE LOSS OF
HEALTH CARE WHAT THAT
PRACTICALLY MEANS FOR MY LITTLE
SISTER. OR ANY OTHER FAMILY
FACING SIMILAR CONDITIONS IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE AND- ALTHOUGH AS
WE SAID THIS DEBATE YOU CAN
POINT TO. A CURRENT LAW WHICH
SOME ARGUE PROHIBITS THIS
PRACTICE ANYWAY- I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE FROM SACRAMENTO A
CLEARLY IN STATUTE I OPENED UP.
SAYING THAT THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
TERMINATING HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DURING THE WORK
STOPPAGE OR STRIKE PERIOD THE
END. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION-
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU I
VOTE. THIS AFTERNOON. AND THERE
IS A MOTION BY. SENATOR ALSO-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN BY A
FAMILY MEMBER GRADE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DID ASO MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG BOARD YES W. AT ALL. I
DID I SO DID I SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG HURTS
BERG I JONES. LAYERED LAYERED
ICE STERN. WAKE HOUSEKI. WHY
CASKEY NOT NOT VOTING WINNER
WINNER I HATE THAT. SIX TO ZERO
SO FAR- GOOD WILL PUT THAT
MATTER ON OUR CALL THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE ON THE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN IT'S A B. ONE ONE FOUR
FOUR FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEON FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS
GOOD AFTERNOON A SIMILAR GROUP-
LEE YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN SENATORS I
WOULD LIKE TO START RETHINKING
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY
TEAM TO DRAFT SOME GREAT
AMENDMENTS THAT I BELIEVE
STRENGTHEN OUR BILL. AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR TAKES A
THREE PRONGED APPROACH PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES. FIRST ENSURE THAT
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS AND
ONLINE DIRECTORIES PROVIDE
ACCURATE BUSINESS INFORMATION
SECOND IT PROHIBITS THIRD PARTY
PLATFORMS IN CHARGING
RESTAURANTS FOR RAPID CALLS
THAT DO NOT RESULT IN A PAID
ORDER AND THIRDLY THERE
REQUIRES ALL FUTURE CONTRACTS
IN A FOOD FACILITY. AND FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS INCLUDE
CLEAR INFORMATION OF ALL
POSSIBLE CHARGES OR FEES THAT
MAY BE INCURRED ON TO THE
RESTAURANT AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION LISTING WEBSITES WE
PARTNER WITH THE FOOD ORDER BY
FORM. AN INDEPENDENT ECONOMY
MANY BUSINESSES THAT HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO BECOME MORE LINE
ON THIRD PARTY FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM SURVIVE. GIVEN THAT
RESTAURANTS ARE EXISTENTIALLY
RELIANT ON THESE SERVICES
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT DISPARITY
IN BARGAINING POWER BETWEEN THE
PLATFORMS AND RESTAURANTS AND
DESPITE GROWING COMPETITION IN
THIS SPACE THE FOOD DELIVERY
INDUSTRIES PRIMARILY CONTROLLED
BY ONLY FOUR COMPANIES. UBER
EATS POSTMATES DOORDASH AND
GRUBHUB COMPRISE. 99% OF SALES
IN THE FOOD DELIVERY MARKET.
THE PANDEMIC IT IS CLEAR THAT
BIG MONOPOLIES HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CAPITALIZE ON THIS NEW
ECONOMIC REALITY. WHILE MANY
RESTAURANTS HAVE STRUGGLED TO
SURVIVE THIS IS EVIDENT WITH
OVER FORTY THOUSAND RESTAURANTS
THAT HAVE CLOSED THEIR DOORS IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE THESE FOOD
DEALER PLATFORMS HAVE GROWN.
THEIR PROFITS EXPONENTIALLY TO
THE XENA PHOBIC AND MISINFORMED
NARRATIVES SURROUNDING COVER
NINETEEN THESE IMPACTS HAVE
BEEN FELT EVEN HARDER. BY ASIAN
AND ASIAN OWNED BUSINESSES. IT
IS CRITICAL WE PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY TOOLS ARE PROTECTIONS
TO OUR SMALL BUSINESSES SO THEY
ARE ABLE TO SURVIVE RECOVER AND
THRIVE. HE MUST ENSURE THEY ARE
NOT BEING EXPLOITED BY BIG
TECHNOPOLIS THIS IS WHY WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE THE SILICON
VALLEY CHAMBER COALITION WHICH
IS MADE UP OF EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATIONS JOIN US IN SUPPORT
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY TWO WITNESSES AND SUPPORTS
RETHINKING FREMONT CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER. AND RESTAURANT OWNER OF
THE VERY TASTY MILK AND HONEY
CAFE AND MARK TURNER CHAIR OF
THE SILICON VALLEY CHAMBER
COLLISION. AND DRIVER AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME VERY GOOD OKAY.
COUNCILMEMBER CAME PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY GREAT
I GOT TO KNOW MANY TREES OKAY
NUMBER TAIWANESE RESTAURANT
OWNER IN THE CITY OF FREMONT
AND ALSO SERVED ON THE CITY
COUNCIL IN FREMONT IN THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF TO INDEPENDENT
MAKE LOCAL RESTAURANTS ARE
AMONG THE HARDEST HIT INDUSTRY
AND MANY RESTAURANTS CLOSE
THEIR DOORS FOR GOOD. I THINK I
RELY HEAVILY ON DELIVERY
PLATFORM FOR A STRONG ORDER
PRESS ON NOT BEING CHARGE
ANYWHERE FROM 25230% ON EAST
BEYOND THE NEED. FOR YOU OFTEN
FROM HER CUSTOMERS CUSTOMERS
ARE USING YELP LIKE YELLOW PAGE
NOW RESTAURANT THAT BEING
CHARGED WITHOUT KNOWING WHEN
CUSTOMERS CALL RESTAURANT SALES
ORDERS WE APPRECIATED SELF
REGULATE AND PREVENT HIDDEN
CHARGES. THAT PLATFORMS LIKE.
CHARGES OF RETRO FEES OUT OR
THAT THAT. IT PROCESSED OKEY
THAT. YOUR SUPPORT YOURSELF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR TURNER-
AHEAD. MR TURNER GO AHEAD. I
MOTOR DE WE HAVE MARK TURNER ON
THE PHONE LINE. SEEING THAT WE
DON'T LET'S SEE IF HE SHOWS UP
WELL HAVEN'T TESTIFIED LET'S
TURN THE SENATE GALLERY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE.
FOURTH SEEING THAT SEEING
THOUGH MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN. THAT ROOM ONE ONE TWO
QUESTION TEST BY MISTER TURNER
YOU ON THE LINE. OKAY-
MODERATOR HELLO. THE OPEN
NUMBER TO TURNER MARK TURNER GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
ALRIGHT FINE PLEASE PROCEED.
OKAY GOOD HI MY NAME IS MARK
TURNER I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
KILL RATE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND CHAIR OF THE SILICON VALLEY
CHAMBER COALITION. AS A FAMILY
MEMBER A MEMBER LEE MENTIONED
THE SILICON VALLEY CHAMBER
COALITION IS COMPRISED OF
EIGHTEEN CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
IN AROUND SILICON VALLEY
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES AND-
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES.
HOW TO SPONSOR A B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EARLY TO ENSURE THAT FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS AND ONLINE
DIRECTORIES. PROVIDE ACCURATE
BUSINESS INFORMATION TO PROTECT
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
UNNECESSARY FEES. PROVIDING
ACCURATE BUSINESS INFORMATION
WILL ALSO ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BY INFORMING THE
CONSUMER ABOUT WHO THEY ARE
ACTUALLY DOING BUSINESS WITH.
WHAT WE SAW DURING THE PANDEMIC
WAS A LOT OF BUSINESSES HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO BECOME MORE
RELIANT ON THIRD PARTY FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS. THE LOCAL
HEALTH RESTRICTIONS WE ALSO SAW
THAT THE AVERAGE RESTAURANT
PROFIT MARGIN FALLING BETWEEN
325% THESE FEES CAN ADD UP AND
CAN HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON SMALL BUSINESSES. IT'S NO
SECRET APPARENTLY SAW SOME OF
THOSE IMPACTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE GOT THEM
COMING UPON ALL OF YOU AT THE
STATE CAPITOL TO ENSURE OUR
BUSINESSES DON'T SUFFER THESE
CONSEQUENCES. BY PROVIDING
ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS AND LETTING THEM KNOW
ABOUT THE THAT THEIR THEIR
ACTIONS. MAY INCUR COSTS TO
RESTAURANTS A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR WILL HELP SUPPORT
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES BY
AVOIDING UNNECESSARY COSTS.
THAT CHIP AWAY AT THEIR ALREADY
SMALL PROFIT MARGINS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU A MOTHERLESS
TURNS. MEMBER INDIVIDUALS WE IN
THE TEST FIND SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FORTY B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR- ON THE LINE CAN YOU
PLEASE- PROMPTED. IF YOU LIKE
TO COME IN SUPPORT OF A P.
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FIRST WE GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF E. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
ALL. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE JUST A
MOMENT. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. AREN'T VERY GOOD OF LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE WITH
THE OPPOSITION UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE DAVID NELSON AND HANNAH
SMITH- ON THE PHONE TODAY
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION MISS
SMITH PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AMERICAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS HANNAH SMITH AND I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF GRANDPA. I'D
LIKE TO THINK SHARE ON BERGEN
AND STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON AT
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR IN REMOVING
ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS ON THIRD
PARTY LISTING WEBSITES. WE
REMAIN SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROVISION PROHIBITING THIRD
PARTY PLATFORMS FROM CHARGING
RESTAURANTS FOR ROUTE A CALL
BUT DID NOT RESULT IN BORDERS.
HOWEVER STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT REQUIRING
THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
RESTAURANT PHONE NUMBERS ON THE
THIRD PARTY LISTING WEBSITE.
CERTAINLY THE THAT HE WHEN THE
BIBLE AND GROWING RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY THAT IS ABLE TO
BALANCE INTEREST UNTIL EVERY
OPTION FOR DINERS. WHAT ABOUT
COMMUNITIES WORKING ALONGSIDE
AND WITH RESTAURANTS TO SUPPORT
THEIR GROWTH. GRUBHUB CONTRACTS
WITH RESTAURANTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTRY TO
PROVIDE PHONE ORDERING SERVICE.
I'M INTERESTED IN THIS BILL
REQUIRES POPCORN TWO PHONE
NUMBERS FOR THESE RESTAURANTS A
UNIQUE PHONE NUMBER OF THE
SERVICE THAT THEY ARE
CONTRACTED WITH GRUBHUB TO
PROVIDE. THE RESTAURANT
DIRECTION NUMBER. BEYOND BEING
CONFUSING FOR CONSUMERS THIS IS
AN UNPRECEDENTED REQUIREMENTS
IT WOULD HURT THE ABILITY FOR
RESTAURANTS TO RUN THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES AS THEY SEE FIT.
DURING THE SERVICE THAT WE
PROVIDE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
RESTAURANTS THEY'RE ABLE TO SEE
HOW THEIR ORDERS ARE BEING
GENERATED BY. I ON ORDER NUMBER
CONSTANT PHONE NUMBERS AND ABLE
REAL TIME MARKETING MEASUREMENT
AND ALLOW RESTAURANTS TO GET A
BETTER IDEA OF WHICH MARKETING
TOOLS WORK. BY GENERATING
ORDERS AND WHICH DO NOT. THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF THE BILL GO
BEYOND OLDER GENERATION
RESTAURANT CONTRACT ABOUT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS. FREQUENTLY AND
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WE HEAR
HOW THE SERVICE IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL BECAUSE OF THE
UNPRECEDENTED SHORTAGE OF
HOSPITALITY STAFFERS. IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT AS AN IMPORTANT
MEANS OVERCOMING LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. FOR RESTAURANT OWNERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. MAKE NO
MISTAKE. THIS BUDGET AT THIS
LEGISLATION WERE TO PASS IT
WOULD DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
MANY SMALL IMMIGRANT OWNED
BUSINESSES. WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING
WITH THE CHAIR NUMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR SOME TIME AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. MEETING AT THE
CAMP PROGRESS AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU DAVID
NELSON PLEASE PROCEED. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS DAVID
MALCOLM THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
REPRESENTING THEIR RESPECTIVE-
THOUSANDS OF APIAPI OWNED
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE DON'T
SUPPORT THE STATE- AND IMPOSING
RESTRICTIONS ON ALREADY
EXISTING CONTRACTS. THAT HAVE
BEEN SIGNED IN GOOD FAITH IT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
BUSINESS OWNERS. FRANKLY THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING WHEN
THEY GO INTO CONTRACTS WITH
VENDORS THAT HELP AND SUPPORT
THE BUSINESSES. SHOULD THINK
THAT THEY ARE DUPED OR THAT
THEY HAVE THE INABILITY. TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONTRACT WHICH
THEY ARE GETTING INTO I THINK
IT'S A DISCREDIT TO- THE
INTELLIGENCE OF ALL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO REFERENCE THAT FORTY ONE
PERCENT. OF PHONE ORDERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM BROKE
GRUBHUB COME FROM ASIAN
RESTAURANTS. THAT IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE STREAM FOR
API RESTAURANT. ANY. DISRUPTION
OR CONFUSION ABOUTSERVICE WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE BOTTOM
LINE OF ASIAN RESTAURANTS AND
ON TOP OF THAT AS WE ALL KNOW
THERE IS A WORKER SHORTAGE AND
THIS IS PART OF THE SERVICE
THAT IS PROVIDED IN THIS
CONTRACT BETWEEN IN THIS CASE
FOR A PUBLIC AND A PRIVATE AND
A PRIVATE RESTAURANT WE NEED TO
HONOR THAT AND WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF WHAT WILL HELP MAKE
BUSINESSES GROW. UP LIKE THIS
LIKE THIS HELP BUSINESSES TO
GROW I WOULD- I WOULD POSE THAT
IF. THESE SERVICES HAD NOT BEEN
IN EXISTENCE SINCE LAST YEAR WE
WOULD SEE EVEN MORE BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY WITH IMMIGRANT OWNED
BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS. OUT OF.
SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE POSED. THE
FILM WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION OF THE COMMON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU SAID A WHITE HOUSE
SKI- I RECEIVED A REPORT THAT
YOU MOVE STUFF ALONG QUITE
VIGOROUSLY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERIA C. NEWELL NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATE IF
YOU TWO OF THOSE. IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE FOUR FOUR FOUR. DO
YOU LIKE TO COME IN OPPOSITION
OF A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR IN
THE PRESS ONE TO DO AT THE TIME.
FIRST WE GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON WE ALL NEED TO ACT ON
BEHALF OF ACCENT AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE MORE JUST A MOMENT.
WE GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE EVEN ON
BEHALF OF NINE BLACK ELLIE.
THANK THANK YOU PEOPLE. THE
OTHER. NEXT PLEASE YOU. WHAT NO
ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE ALREADY-
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
BRING BACK THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS IN THE CHAMBER.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR CHAIRMAN I. WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR WE CAME TO
THE OFFICE AND SPENT SOME TIME
TALKING ABOUT. BY THIS MEASURE
HADN'T STUDIED BEFORE. BUT I
APPRECIATE. HIS TIME AND
WILLINGNESS TO. DISCUSS IT I
JUST. YOU'VE HEARD THE
ARGUMENTS SUNNY AND CONCERNS
ME. A LITTLE BIT HERE AND EAT
IT WAS THE ARGUMENT BY THE- ONE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE. AND I
LIKE TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS SORT OF SPONSOR STARTS ON
THIS- THERE'S A GAP CALLED OPEN
TABLE WHICH IS KIND OF A COOL
APP. IF IT'S A RESTAURANT WHAT
I DO IS I GO TO OPEN TABLE AND
I SAY- I WANNA RESERVATION
BECAUSE I'M HAVING DINNER WITH
SENATOR ALSO. IN THE TWO OF US
ARE GOING TO BE THERE THAT
NIGHT AND CAN YOU DO IT AND I
HOPE THE TABLE THEN CONTACTS
THE RESTAURANT. GETS THE
RESERVATION I HAVE A LITTLE
THING ON MY PHONE WHEN I GO
THERE IT SHOWS THAT. WERE
AVAILABLE FOR THAT. SO
BUSINESSES CHOOSE THE OPTION SO
THE QUESTION HERE IS THE YOU
KNOW HEY I DO UNDERSTAND THE
POINT ABOUT THE BARGAINING
DESPITE BARGAINING POWER THAT
YOU MAKE AS AN UNDERLYING IT IS
ALWAYS IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
AS WE SAW IN THE LAST BILL. AS
WAS DISCUSSED. FROM MY POINT OF
VIEW A BIT IF A BUSINESS WANTS
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE. COULD
THEY- HAVE AN OPT OUT PROVISION
THAT SAYS I WOULD RATHER I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE TELEPHONE
CALLS. DURING SOME OF THE
HOLIDAYS RECENTLY WHEN I TRY TO
GET STUFF DELIVERED TO THE
HOUSE RECALLED SOME RESTAURANTS
IS ONE IN PASADENA. WHICH I
LOVE AND THE LIKE AND WE TRIED
TO CALL THE TAKE THAT ORDER WE
COULDN'T GET IN ORDER TO THEY
WOULDN'T TAKE IT ON THE PHONE.
THEY MADE US GO TO THEIR APP.
OR GO TO SOME OTHER APP TO GO
TO DEAL WITH IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
SO BUSY AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE BURDENED BY IT. SO FOR
PURPOSES OF FLEXIBILITY IN THIS
KIND OF NEW WORLD WE LIVE IN
WITH THIS. THESE COMPUTER
THINGS IN THESE PHONE THINGS WE
GOT OUT THERE THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE SOME TIME AGO. WHY SHOULD
WE HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY WE
HAVE AN OPT OUT PROVISION THAT
SAYS OKAY IF I'M A BUSINESS AND
I WANT TO SIGN A CONTRACT AND I
WANT TO SUBCONTRACT OUT. TO
SOME COMPANY LIKE OPENTABLE. TO
DEAL WITH MY ORDERS OR WHOEVER
ELSE IT. MAY BE. WHAT DO YOU
WHAT YOU THOUGHT IN THAT REGARD
SO YOU DEAL WITH THIS TELEPHONE
ISSUE. BECAUSE THAT'S THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE FROM A
BUSINESS. IT ACTUALLY MIGHT BE
COMPLETELY AGAINST MY INTERESTS
IN TERMS OF HOW I CHOOSE TO DO
BUSINESS YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
YOUR. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
CENTER THROUGH THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I THINK THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE REALLY IS THE INFORMED
CONSENT INFORMED AGREEMENT. SO
YOU HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT IT MIGHT BE INSULTING TO
SMALL BUSINESSES THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONTRACTOR
SIGNING I WILL SHOW YOU THIS IS
FROM BROOKLYN SITE. THIS IS THE
CONTRACT THAT THEY SIGN. THAT
SAID. AND IT TOOK AWHILE FOR ME
MY TEAM TO EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
TEN EIGHT POINT. FINE FINE
PRINT RIGHT HERE. AND THERE IS
NO MENTION ABOUT CALL
FORWARDING I WILL LET YOU KNOW
THAT PRIOR TO THIS BILL BEING
INTRODUCED. AS PRIVATE
OPPOSITION THERE WERE TWO PHONE
NUMBERS LISTED BEFORE ONE THAT
WAS. A NUMBER CREATED BY
GRUBHUB ON YELP. I'M THE ONE
THAT DIRECTLY WITH THE
CUSTOMERS AND IN THE ANALYSIS
THERE WAS A- IT'S LIKE THEY GET
ADVICE PIECE THAT TALKS ABOUT.
WHEN CUSTOMERS GO TO COLD
COLDER THROUGH. THAT YUP
CRITICAL NUMBER EIGHT IT'S USED
AS A REFERRAL FEE A MARKETING
FEE THAT'S ASSESSED ON
BUSINESSES AND WE KNOW IT'S
SMALL RESTAURANT SMALL
RESTAURANTS. THE PROFIT MARGINS
ARE RAZOR THIN AND ADDING ON A
2230% MARKETING CHARGE
MARKETING CHARGE. REALLY HURTS
BUSINESSES SO IN THE COURSE OF
THIS BILL INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
YELP WHICH SUBMITTED A LETTER
OF NEUTRALITY. ACTUALLY
DISCONTINUED THE PRACTICE
ALTOGETHER SO THE PRACTICE OF
THE BILL IS. IS HOPING TO
ENSURE THAT NO LONGER EXISTS IN
THE REAL WORLD NOW. BECAUSE
THEY UNDERSTAND IT IS SERIOUS
BECAUSE THE REAL PART IS YOU
KNOW A BUSINESS SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY CONTRACT WITH AN OPEN
TABLE OR- ANY SORT OF DIFFERENT
VENDORS AND THIRD PARTY APPS.
BUT HE NEED TO BE KNOWING WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING INTO. AND IN
THE CASE OF CALL FORWARDING IS
A PROBLEM WITH THE CONSUMER DID
YOU KNOW THEY WERE CHARGING
RESTAURANT AND THE RESTAURANT.
WAS ENTIRELY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WAS HAPPENING. SO IF A
RESTAURANT WANTS TO SPEAK
WHAT'S HAPPENING THEY WOULD
HAVE TO GO TO SPEED THE MARKING
CHARGE WHICH- AND I HAD TO READ
THROUGH SEVERAL DOCUMENTS.
FALLS FROM EVERYTHING FROM
SOCIAL MEDIA TO PRINT MEDIA TO
PHONE ORDERS IT'S SUCH A HUGE
PART OF THAT. IF YOU'RE A SMALL
BUSINESS THAT'S WORKING. YOU
KNOW YOUR FAMILY AND YOU'RE
WORKING ALL THE HOURS YOU'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE THE TIME JUST.
RINSE THE WRINKLE FOR
EVERYTHING. AND THAT'S WERE
TRYING TO DO AND THAT'S WHY
WITH THE CHAIRS AND DOOR WITH
THE WORK OF THE CHAIR. HE ALSO
MORE DISCLOSURE LANGUAGE TO
MAKE OUT WHAT THESE FEES ARE
GOING TO BE SUCH A BETTER
INFORMED- GRIMMETT. CHECK ASK.
FOR THE QUESTION FOLLOW UP ON
THAT. THE MAJORITY LEADER YOU
MAY. THANK YOU KIND SIR. ON A
COMPLETELY ON THIS WHOLE WE
CALL ON THE LINE HE'S IN
CONTRACTS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SEE
THESE THINGS AND WE DEALT WITH
THIS INITIAL PRIVACY THAT WE
DEALT WITH OVER MANY MANY
YEARS. AND YOU SEE THESE THESE-
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE SO LONG
EITHER PHD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY SAY I COMPLETELY AGREE
THAT'S THE ISSUE. SO IF YOU
WANT TO DEAL WITH THIS LAW AND
SAY OKAY THESE HAD TO BE IN SO
MANY POINT TYPE. AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS- I'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT WOULD
REDUCE IN THAT REGARD. WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET TO IS. OKAY
INFORMED CONSENT. PUT A BOX ON
THERE RATHER THAN SAYING YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE PHONE NUMBER
IF I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
PHONE CALLS BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE SOMEBODY. IN OUR
CONTRACT OUT THOSE PHONE CALLS
TO SOMEBODY ELSE. WHY CAN'T I
AS A BUSINESS LIKE AN OPEN
TABLE. CHOOSE TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. NOW YOU CAN MAKE
SURE IT'S CLEAR. THAT WHEN YOU
SIGN A CONTRACT THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS IS WHY YOU'RE
DOING IT HERE'S THE CHARGE FOR
DOING IT. BUT WHY COULDN'T I
GIVE TO OPENTABLE TO SOMEBODY
ELSE AND NOT BE BOTHERED. TO
HAVE PHONE CALLS COME TO ME
AGAIN IF I WANT TO I CAN. BUT
WE'RE DOING AS A GOVERNMENT. IS
WE'RE MANDATING THAT THAT'S ON
THERE. AND THE QUESTION IS. WHO
WE PROTECTING. THE PROTECTION
DOESN'T OCCUR AT THE WITH THE
PHONE NUMBERS THERE. THE
PROTECTION OCCURS. TO THE
BUSINESS OWNER AT THE TIME THE
CONTRACTS SIGNED. SO THAT'S THE
INFLECTION POINT WHERE YOU
PROTECT SOMEBODY. AND YOU SAY
YOU'RE SIGNING A CONTRACT THESE
ARE THE TERMS. YOU KNOW YOU
NEED A LAWYER OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE BUT THAT'S THE
DETERMINATION AS TO WHENYOU
MAKE THAT DECISION. AND WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY FOR. NOT
MANDATING HOW YOU WANT TO. TAKE
YOUR CUSTOMERS. I THINK THE
IDEA OF HAVING AN OPT OUT
PROVISION. OR HAVING SOME
DISCLOSURE IN A WAY THAT IT WAS
BIGGER PRINT. OR SOMETHING
WOULD BE. ACHIEVE EXACTLY JUST
AS YOU WANT TO ACHIEVE. WITHOUT
TAKING AWAY THE ABILITY OF THE
<c.green>USINESS OWNER TO. PAY WHAT</c>
THEY WANT HOW THEY WANT TO DO
IT BUT YOU REALLY PROTECTING AT
THE SAME TIME HOW DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE TO YOU BY. I THINK
THAT KIND OF HELPS DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR EXPERT. YEAH NUMBER LI
YOU CARE TO RESPOND OR IN YOUR
CLOTHES I WAS ON MY CLOTHES ALL
RIGHT. OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SAYING NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
SEND A COUPLE YEAR ALMOST THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT- YES SIR- HURTS
BIRD. ALL I'M SAYING IS I RAISE
THAT ISSUE I KNOW THAT YOU YOU
YOU WERE VERY GRACIOUS TAKING A
SERIES OF AMENDMENTS. THAT THE
CHAIR ASKED FOR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE YOUR STAFF WORK VERY
WELL WITH THE COMMITTEE. I
THINK WHAT I'LL DO HERE TODAY
IS I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
I'D LIKE TO SEE THOSE CHANGES
SOMEHOW ALONG THE PROCESS SO
VOTE FOR YOUR- MEASURE TODAY
BUT I WANT TO CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING THAT I THINK YOU
SHOULD WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THAT
REALLY ACHIEVE YOUR OBJECTIVE
ON THE ONE HAND AND AVOIDS THE
COMPELLING BUSINESSES HOW THEY
DO THEIR THE OTHER AND ALL WITH
HOLD THE RIGHT TO VOTE AT- AT A
LATER TIME ON THE FLOOR. IN
OTHER INSTANCES THANK YOU- SENT
A COUPLE YEAR THAN ARE ALSO I'M
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT A SECOND WOULD- MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES
SAID I HI THE FIRST. ITERATION
pLITTLE BIT CONCERNED WITH
TELLING PEOPLE WHAT KIND OF
CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIPS THEY
CAN HAVE WHEN IT'S VOLUNTARILY
ENTERED ITO BUT I ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS AND THAT IT'S
NOT AN EQUAL. RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE BUSINESS AND THESE
COMPANIES BUT BUT THERE SHOULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS TO OFFLOAD SOME OF THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING AND I
GOT TO SAY THAT IT'S REALLY
HARD RIGHT NOW BECAUSE- YOU
DON'T KNOW WHO'S OPEN. AND
YOU'RE CALLING AND THEY DON'T
ANSWER THE PHONE BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE NOT OPEN
AND SO IT IT TO BE ABLE TO
OFFLOAD THE NEED TO ANSWER
PHONES- MAY BE A BENEFIT TO A
SMALL BUSINESS AND SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S THAT
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL. THANK YOU
SENT A COPY OF SOME OF RUSSELL
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION.
RIGHT IS SOME OF ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT I LOOK AT THE BILLS
IS TO SEE WHO SUPPORTS AND WHO
OPPOSES OF COURSE. AND I'M
INTERESTED I'M CURIOUS ON THE
SUPPORT SIDE THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION- AND
OTHER CHAMBERS. ALONGSIDE THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION- AND THEN
ON THE OTHER SIDE OTHER-
CHAMBERS SO I'M UNCLEAR AS TO
WHAT THE INTERESTS ARE HERE.
THAT LEADS TO- BUSINESSES US
SUPPORTING AND THEN. BUSINESSES
OPPOSING ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
APPEARED TO BE THE SAME KIND OF
BUSINESSES. SIMILAR MEMBER LEE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION OR SANDRA AT THE THOSE
LISTENERS I THINK THAT'S A VERY
FAIR QUESTION AS A WONDER WHY
CERTAIN BUSINESSES ARE POSES
BILL THEY WERE NOT OPPOSED TO
IN THE ASSEMBLY THEY HAVE
JOINED ON LATER ON BUT I DO
THINK THEY MIGHT BE
MISUNDERSTANDING OUR BILL OUR
BILLS ONLY PROTECTS. THE PEOPLE
THERE WITHIN SMALL BUSINESSES
SMALL RESTAURANTS THAT FOR
REASONS WE DISCUSSED ARE HAVING
PERFECT BARGAINING POSITION AND
SO I'M UNSURE WHY THEY ARE BUT
WE DID ENGAGE IN CALIFORNIA
ASIAN CHAMBER- PACIFIC CHAMBER.
EARLY ON AS WELL. HE'S SORRY
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE BILL HAS EEN MOVED BY SOME
A COUPLE EURO. ALL RIGHT
BENCHING OF WHICH COULD BE
CLOSE YES THANK YOU SENATOR
ALBUM CLOSER BRIEFLY I JUST
WANT TO. CLARIFY TWO THINGS.
ONE IS THAT I DO AGREE THAT
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTRACT WITH THIRD PARTIES AS
THEY WISH. A. N. OPENTABLE
RAZZIE OR ALL THESE OTHER APPS
THAT EXIST OUT THERE FOR
SPECIFIC PURPOSES. IN THIS CASE
ABOUT FOURTEEN CALLS. I WILL
ARGUE MOST BUSINESS PROBLEM DID
NOT GET INTO BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO BE HAVE OTHER
CALLS FOR IT ON ANOTHER LISTING
SERVICE. IN THE CASE OF THIS
BILL IS HAPPENING IS A YELP A
DIFFERENT APP. WAS HAVING FORTY
CALLS OF A GRUB WHICH IS A
PARTNERSHIP ON IT. THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROHIBIT PRESS SMALL
RESTAURANTS FROM STILL
RECEIVING ONLINE ORDERS THE
GROUPON APP RIGHT FOR THE
GROWTH OF BUILT IN APPLE YEP ON
YELP. THAT DOES NOT PROHIBIT
ANY OF THAT THING. AND I WILL
SAY ALSO. WE DO NOT HEAR ABOUT
THE SERVICE OF. LIKE A LIKE A
CENTER. THIS THAT HAS NOT
EXISTED WHEN THIS BILL WAS
PROPOSED THAT DID NOT EXIST YET
SO EVEN WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A WORKER SHORTAGE
ARGUMENT. IF YOUR CALL
FORWARDING A CALL WHETHER BE
THE ACTUAL PHONE NUMBER YOU
FIND ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD
OR YOU TO FORTY CALL IT STILL
GOES TO THE SAME. PEOPLE RIGHT
SO I CALLED THE GOWTH OF
NUMBER AND THE SAME RESTAURANT.
OWNERS THEY STILL PICK UP THE
PHONE SO THERE IS NO HOPE.
WORKER ARGUMENT THERE.
ULTIMATELY IF GRUBHUB DOES
EXPANDING CREEK THIS CALL
CENTER MODEL THAT'S SOMETHING I
CAN DO AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN REFINE IN THE PROCESS BUT
RIGHT NOW I WOULDSAY IS.
RESTAURANTS DID NOT SIGN UP TO
HAVE- THIS PRACTICE OF CALL
FORWARDING AND THEN PUT UNDER
MARKETING SERVICES THEY DID NOT
SIGN UP FOR THAT. WHAT THEY
SIGNED UP FOR THE NEWS THAT.
DURING THE PANDEMIC OF PEOPLE
STAYED HOME. THEY WENT TO THESE
COMFORTING ONLINE APPS AND MANY
OF THEM ESPECIALLY ASIANS
ALWAYS IN MY AREA DID NOT
UNDERSTAND THEM FULLY. BUT HE
KNEW THEY WERE PART OF
SURVIVAL. AND NOW AS WE KNOW
THAT STAYING ORDERING ON APPS
AND ORDERING. REMOTELY IS HERE
TO STAY AND THOSE PROFITS ALSO
SURGING. PEOPLE ARE STILL
DECIDING RIGHT THE PROBABLY
LOCAL BUSINESSES YOU'VE HEARD
EVERY MOVING AWAY FROM YELP
MOVING WE'VE BROUGHT UP AND
THERE'S A LOT MORE OPTIONS NOW
THAN I WAS A BIG MARKET SHARE
BUT THIS ONLY. OTHER APPS. AND
SO NEXT TIME YOU'RE ON. ON YOUR
PHONE YOU PROBABLY SEE THERE'S
A LOT MORE DIFFERENT APPS OUT
THERE I WILL PROMOTE ALL THE
APPS OUT THERE BUT THEY'RE A
LITTLE. MORE APPS OUT THERE
NOW. TO COMPETE WITH IT.
BECAUSE THERE IS A PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW AND TALKING TO HER.
ESPECIALLY MY DISTRICT SMALL
RESTAURANTS. THEY'RE QUITE
ANNOYED AT HOW HOW THEY FEEL
DUPED AND CUT OUT IN THIS
PROCESS WHEN THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE SO. PERFECTLY AFTER I
VOTE AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
REST OF HIM. ALREADY THANK YOU-
AND SHE COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A- B.
FORTY. FOR FOUR BY A FAMILY
MEMBER AT LEAST. WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR KERRY AT ALL
THE MOTION IS DO PASS. BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AMBER AMBER HI
FORGES AHEAD OF. ME AT ALL I
DID I SAW. THAT I THOUGHT I'D
GONE SILAS. AND SILAS I HURTS
BERG. HURTS BERG HI JONES.
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI WHITE KASKY IGHT
WINNER. THAT SEVENTY ZERO SO
FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ONE FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE- WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR TO COME THE
PODIUM WELCOME OUR GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US IN OBSERVING YOUR
LEGISLATURE IN ACTION ALL RIGHT
SIMPLY MEMBER LIVING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
EIGHTY EIGHT ONE FOUR WILL
PROHIBIT EMPLOYEES OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS FROM
CONDUCTING CONTACT TRACING AND
PLEASE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON
DATA COLLECTED FOR CONTACT
TRACING PURPOSES. SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL PROHIBITS DATA
COLLECTED RECEIVER PREPARED FOR
CONTACT TRACING PURPOSES FROM
BEING USED TO MAINTAIN OR
DISCLOSED FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSES. OTHER THAN
FACILITATING CONTACT TRACING
EFFORTS. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
DELETION OF THIS DATA WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS THAT SERVE A PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSE. EXCEPT FOR
CONTACT TRACING REQUIRES THE
SHARING OF SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
INFORMATION INCLUDING THE
PERSON'S NAME PHONE
NUMBER AND OTHER PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING DATA WELL THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE REQUIRED TO
SUCCESSFULLY STOP THE SPREAD.
OF THE CORONA VIRUS IN FUTURE
PANDEMICS THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STATE OF
POTENTIALLY BEING USED FOR NON
HEALTHCARE RELATED PURPOSES
INCLUDING ADVERTISING AND BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE LESS LIKELY TO
WILLINGLY INTERACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. REGARDLESS OF THE
CONTEXT TO DISTRUST AND FEAR
AND HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED AND
AFFECTED BY TWELVE IN NINETEEN
CONTACT TRACING IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE FUNCTION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND UTILIZING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO CONTACT TRACE
WILL CREATE DISTRUST IN CONTACT
TRACING EFFORTS. AND HINDER OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS. THIS BILLIS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CAN TRUST THEIR DATA
WILL NOT BE MISUSED AND WILL
ONLY BE USED FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSE. THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS MY STAFF
AND I HAD ENGAGED WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS BILL AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO MOVING
FORWARD. AFTER THIS COMMITTEE I
PLAN TO WORK WITH AFFECTED
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A
PROCESS WITH APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT FOR EXTENSIONS OF THE
SIXTY DAY DATA DELETION
REQUIREMENT FOR SPECIFIC
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES THAT
NECESSITATE LONGER DATA
RETENTION. EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
FOUR WILL PROTECT THE DATA
PRIVACY CALIFORNIANS AND BUILD
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
CONTACT TRACING PROGRAM NEEDED.
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM FURTHER SPREAD OF
CODE NINETEEN ANY POTENTIAL
FUTURE PANDEMICS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR A LONG
TIME AS A SIMILAR BILL.
AUTHORED BY YOU CAME TO THIS
COMMITTEE- I BELIEVE WAS A YEAR
AGO AND I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
OFFERED TODAY- ALTHOUGH ALL THE
CONCERNS OF STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
NOT BEEN ADDRESSED BUT I TRUST
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THEM. SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE IN
HIM OVER TO THE- I BELIEVE IT
GOES TO THE PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE FROM HERE THAT'S
TRYING TO BALANCE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERESTS OF THE PRIVACY
INTERESTS DIFFICULT TO DO. BUT
I'M CONFIDENT THAT- BY THE TIME
THIS IS THE FLOOR WILL BE NO
OPPOSITION HANDLE BE PEACE IN
THE VALLEY SO MR SURE YOU'VE
GOT MY COMMITMENT FOR THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR NOTING THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR OVER A
YEAR DURING THIS PANDEMIC- AND
CONVERSATIONS- WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ARE ON GOING AS
RECENTLY AS JUST A FEW HOURS
AGO. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU-
YOU HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I BELIEVE BEKAH KRAMER
MILDER AND LINDA- OF. IS IT AND
WHEN. SO RIGHT. IF EITHER OF
YOU ON THE PHONE IF YOU WOULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES. GOOD
AFTERNOON WINDOW WAY BACK A
GRAMMAR MATTER. MEMBERS SO I'M
THINKING MY MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE CELL YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
ONE FOUR AND THE COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO ENSURING THE
APPROPRIATE PRIVACY PROTECTION
FOR CALIFORNIANS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION COLLECTED AS PART
OF CO THEY CONTACTED ME
AFTERWARDS. WHICH I THINK HAS
IS TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF ANY
KIND TRACING PROGRAM. IF PEOPLE
DO NOT BELIEVE THE INFORMATION
THEY SHARE WITH CONTACT RECORDS
WILL BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND
YEARS ARE GOING TO ATTRACT A
PANDEMIC FOR LESS LIKELY TO
PROVIDE COMPLETE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN AND
WHO THEY HAD INTERACTED WITH.
ANY PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC WILL THEREFORE BE
INCOMPLETE AND LACK. PRACTICE
DO NOT LEAVE THIS THING. LAWS
DO NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT FROM
WAYS THAT KHAN YOU CAN OTHER
PANDA REALLY IN. AND IS.
HAPPENING HAVE BEEN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE HEALTH
PARTNERS TO EXTRACT OUR
SENSITIVE INFORMATION FOR THEIR
OWN PROFIT AND POWER. FOR
EXAMPLE OF EVIDENCE BY
PHARMACIES USING COLOR RED BACK
NEW. DATA FOR TARGETED
ADVERTISING. TOM HURRIED HOME
OPPONENTS CALL EIGHTY EIGHT
FOUR NOT HAVE ON. EMPLOYERS
REGULARLY COLLECT FROM THEIR
EMPLOYEES FOR GENERAL
EMPLOYMENT PURPOSES. BENJAMIN
I'M PLAYING HELLO CLIENT
NUMBER. INSTEAD EIGHTY EIGHT
ONE FOUR PUT LIMITS ON WHAT CAN
BE DONE WITH THE INHERENTLY
SENSITIVE AND PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
OBTAINED AS PART OF CONTACT
TRACING. SUCH AS AN EMPLOYEES
MOVEMENT AND LOCATION BUT NOT
ON THE JOB AND THEY'RE NOT
GONNA WORK. RELATED THE ASIAN.
INFORMATION SHOULD BE SHIELDED
EITHER YOU. THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED WHEN I'M- I'VE
BEEN THE PANDEMIC. AND IT IS
INHERENTLY IDENTIFIABLE AND
PRESIDENT. BY ENSURING
APPROPRIATE COMMENTS ON.
ACTIONS SPEAK EIGHT ONE FOUR
NINE ONLY PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
PRIVACY BUT ALSO FURTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH SCHOOL FOR THESE REASONS
YEAH IF YOU HAVE A GREAT
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT ONE FOUR.
RT THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. LINDA GOOD
AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
CONTRACTOR A THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO LIMIT THE
SPREAD OF CODE NINETEEN AND
IT'S MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN
COMPLETE STATUS PROVIDE TRUSTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIKE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITY
WORKERS ARE THE BEST COLLECTORS
OF THE FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
OVER POLICED. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THE VERY COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC ARE LESS LIKELY TO
WILLINGLY ENGAGE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS WE HEAR
REGULARLY FROM OUR PARTNERS
THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE W AFRAID
TO SEEK HEALTH CARE ENROLL IN
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS OR
OTHERWISE SEEK ASSISTANCE.
SIMILARLY MANY PEOPLE OF COLOR
HAVE EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE
INTERACTIONS WITH POLICE EVEN
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CALL
FOR HELP THE BRIDGE HERE IT'S
ABOUT SLOWING THE SPREAD OF
CODE NINETEEN DO CONTACT
TRACING WILL USE ONLY THOSE
COMMUNITY WORKERS THAT ARE
ALREADY TRUSTED FILAMENT
STARTED FIRE SPREAD TO AFFECT
THE CONTRACT MEETING AND
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL HEALTH. DATA
WHICH- DRIVABLE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- OTHERS IN SUPPORTING THE
GALLERY SAYING NONE. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE LET'S KEEP UP THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE. THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF A MOTOR. THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE FOUR YOU WOULD QUEUE UP.
MODERATOR ANYONE IN SPORTS ON
THE PHONE LINE A. B. EIGHT ONE
FOUR. YES WE DO WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR. HELLO
THEY SHOT THE CAPTAIN OF THE
WALKMAN WITH ACCESSIBLE. IN
EUREKA AND NOW WE SEE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN FREE SPEECH
AND PRIVACY SO WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU. CAN WE HAVE ONE MORE CUED
UP HERE WE'RE GETTING A LINE
NUMBER HOLD ON ONE MOMENT. OKAY
THAT PERSON HAS LEFT THE QUEUE
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY IN THE IN
THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW ALREADY
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION I'VE
NO PRINCIPAL OPPOSITION LISTED.
I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY NOR
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANYONE THE PHONE LINE. IN
PRINCIPLE OPPOSITION TO AB.
EIGHT ONE FOUR. THEN WE DO HAVE
ONE NUMBER TWO FORTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROB ROB SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF A V.
EIGHT FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THEN WE GO TO LINE
NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS AT
THEIR LOCAL ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I'M
GETTING A PROJECT THE OTHER
CONTENDERS IN THE CELL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HIM ONLINE. LANGUAGE TO
EXEMPT THE DATA FOR RESEARCH
PURPOSES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EUROPEAN SHARES MEMBERS AND
CARE WOULD BE OKAY IF I PROVIDE
YOU THE ONE MINUTE OF COMMENT.
I'M SORRY. SURE IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE OKAY. GO AHEAD. MAJOR LEAGUE
SECOND DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY
SECTOR THE NATIONAL BIPARTISAN
NETWORK OF TECHNOLOGY CEOS AND
SENIOR EXECUTIVES THAT PROMOTES
THE GROWTH INNOVATION ECONOMY
REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
COMPANIES AND FOUR MILLION
EMPLOYEES. TECHNET RESPECT
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE FOUR BUT ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPEN DOOR DOCTOR'S
OFFICE. WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF OUR CONCERN
RELATED TO BEING AN EXCEPTION
FOR DATA NEEDED TO COMPLY WITH
LOCAL ORDINANCES. THE LATEST
AMENDMENTS THAT DID NOT ADDRESS
THE ISSUE WE HAVE RAISED
PREVIOUSLY WHICH AN EXCEPTION
FOR DE IDENTIFIED AGGREGATED
CONSUMER DATA. WE'RE SEEKING TO
BE IDENTIFIED- AGGREGATED DATA
EXCEPTION THAT WOULD ENABLE
WORKS RIGHT UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEIR SPECIFIC HOT SPOT THE
COPING NINETEEN PER WORKER
SAFETY PURPOSES ADDITIONALLY
THIS NON IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION IS NEEDED FOR
EXAMPLE TO PROVE THAT A
BUSINESS CONDUCTING CONTACT
TRACING. PROVIDE GOVERNMENT ON
THE QUEST DATA THAT CONTACT
TRACING WAS CONDUCTED IN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PROXIMITY TO AN INFECTED
PERSON. HIT EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
FOUR THE REQUIRED DIVISION
ENTRY- THIS PRIVACY PROTECTED
INFORMATION EXACTLY THE SAME
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
IDENTIFIES INDIVIDUALS THIS
RUNS COUNTER TO THE STATED
PRIVACY GOALS IN THE BILL THAT
THE DISCOURAGES THE USE OF
THESE PRIVATE PRIVACY.
PROTECTION PRACTICES. RIGHT
CONCERNS YOUR STAFF AND WE LOOK.
COME YOU CAN WITHIN YOU FOR
YOUR- AND FROM THE CITY. THANK
YOU FOR TEN AND CONSIDERATION.
RT THANK YOU ANYWAY ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT ONE FOUR. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE A LINE OF TWO FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WHICH REMEMBERED THE%
CONSTRAINING HOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CIVIL CHARGES THAT THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
APPROACH UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY- OTHER THAN CUBA
STRICTER ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK HERE TO THE CHAMBER-
LOOKING AROUND THE CHAMBER I
SEE CENTRE LAYERS MICROPHONE
RAISED EARLIER THANK YOU- WITH
THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR I'D
LIKE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
SURE- BECAUSE IN ANY ANALYSIS
AND I THINK YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR- IN YOUR STATEMENT YOU
MENTION THERE CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS ON THE SIXTY DAY. OF
RULE ABOUT DELETION. OF
INFORMATION BUT IT ALSO SEEMS
TO INDICATE YOU WERE STILL
NEGOTIATING ON IT. THE ANALYSIS
SORT OF CALLED OUT TO BERKELEY
LOS THIS IS A PLACE THAT- YOU
WOULDN'T WANT THE INFORMATION
DELETED AND I JUST KNOW FROM.
MY YEARS AS AN AIDS SERVICE
AGENCY DIRECTOR THAT WOULD BE
ANOTHER THING WHERE YOU
WOULDN'T WANT THAT DELETED IT
SIXTY DAYS I JUST WANTED TO ASK
WHAT IS THE PROGRESS IN ANY
NEGOTIATIONS RELATED TO THAT
SIXTY DAY DELETION AND- AND
WHERE ARE YOU HEADING WEST IT
DOES YOU MOVED THE BILL. FOR
PERSONAL THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION HIGHLIGHTING THAT
ISSUE THAT THE ANALYSIS DOES
NOTE AS WELL AS I THINK
IMPORTANT CONCERN RAISED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY'VE BEEN ONE OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH VERY CLOSELY ON
THIS THIS BILL HAS A NUMBER OF
EXCEPTIONS ALREADY TO THE SIXTY
DAY- PERIOD- AND YOU SEE
DELIVERED US SOME LANGUAGE LOOK
OUT THIS MORNING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
WHAT YOU SEE AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO FIGURING
THAT OUT- BEFORE THE BILL HEADS
TO THE FLOOR. AND MISTER JEFF I
CAN FOLLOW UP AND THE UC
CONCERN IS IT DOESN'T MAKE. A
SENSE TO DO WE WHEN THERE MIGHT
BE RESEARCH DONE UP BASED ON IT
IS THAT ONE OF THEIR MAJOR
CONCERNS I THINK THAT THEY HAVE
A NUMBER OF CONCERNS THAT- I
DON'T THINK IT'S JUST LIMITED
TO THAT. IN A IN A BROAD SENSE
STATED HE COLLECTED SOME OF
THEIR OWN DATA- WHICH IS
SEPARATE FROM DATA THAT THERE
MAY BE BORROWING HI I JUST KNOW
WE WERE. WE WERE IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH UC SAN
FRANCISCO ON A RESEARCH PROJECT
WHEN I WAS DOING THAT DECADES
AGO. IN THE COLLECTION OF DATA
REALLY ALLOW THE POINT TO BE
PROVEN ON HIV AND SO OUR VOTE
TO MOVE THE BILL BUT I HOPE YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
BECAUSE- I THINK IT REALLY.
NEEDS SOME WORK YEAH I DON'T
KNOW. I DON'T DISCOUNT YOUR
CONCERN I SHARE AND I DON'T
THAT THE- DID. BETWEEN THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE NOW AND
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE
PRESENTED THIS MORNING WHICH
WERE AGAIN MEETING WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH YOU SEE. TO
RESOLVE WHATEVER THOSE
DISTANCES MIGHT BE IT'S NOT
INSURMOUNTABLE I THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND OKAY. BUT WHAT. ON MY
OWN TIME MISTER CHAIR. AS I
SAID I'D BE WILLING TO DO A-
BOOK TO MOVE THE BILL BUT I'M
GONNA BE LOOKING CLOSELY AT HOW
THAT ISSUE RESOLVED AS IT MOVES
ALONG THANK YOU EARNINGS
PREVIEW CENTER LAST YEAR. CYCLE
WE ARE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I HAVE THE SAME- CONCERNED SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I'M- VERY
CLEAR THAT I'LL SUPPORT IT
TODAY I HAD AN INTERESTING BUT
I. HEAR THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON
SOMEONE TO BE SUPPORTIVE HERE'S
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE THAT I
HAVE AND IT'S- I'M REALLY
CONCERNED WITH US GETTING. DATA
THAT HELPS US TO DETERMINE HOW
WE CAN. SLOW DOWN THE VIRUSES
IT'S COMING IN THE FUTURE AND
THERE WAS DATA THAT WE DID NOT
COLLECT. IN DURING THAT THE
PEAKER AS THIS. AS THIS VIRUS
IS ROLLING OUT THAT I THINK
WOULD HAVE TOLD US. WHERE WE
WERE WE WOULD FIND THAT THE
BIGGEST INFECTIONS- NUMBER ONE
IS WE DIDN'T. WE DIDN'T SK
PEOPLE WHERE THEY WORKED AND
WHAT KIND OF WORK THEYDID- AND
WE DIDN'T ASK THEM- WHAT KIND
WHAT THEIR LIVING SITUATION WAS
WAS WAS LIKE IN OTHER WORDS. IF
WE'RE GOING TO SEND THEM HOME
TO QUARANTINE HOW MANY OTHER
PEOPLE WERE LIVING IN THE SPACE
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT WAS THE
SPACE WHAT DID IT LOOK LIKE.
AND EARLY ON WHEN WE WERE ALL
SENT HOME IT WAS VERY CLEAR TO
ME THAT IF THIS. WAS A
TRANSMISSION TRANSMISSIBLE
DISEASE THAT WAS CARRIED- IN IN
THE AIR THAT TELLING PEOPLE TO
GO HOME. WHEN THERE WERE TEN
PEOPLE LIVING IN A THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT. APARTMENT WHAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A GOOD THING
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT I THINK
THAT THAT WE REALLY NEED THE
DATA BECOMES REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND I DON'T. WE'RE
GONNA HOLD EMPLOYERS
RESPONSIBLE IF THEIR EMPLOYEES
ARE GETTING SICK AND DYING BUT
THEY MAY GO BACK TO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT COMPANIES AND THEN IN
THOSE COUNTIES WE WEREN'T
ASKING YOU KNOW FOR YOU WORKING
WHAT KIND OF YOU'RE WORKING IN
A MEAT PACKING FACILITY OR
YOU'RE WORKING IN A- SOLID FOR
THIS FACILITY WITH PEOPLE
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER- WITHOUT
MASKS. THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THAT I THINK WE- IF
WE HAD. IF WE HAD DONE THE KIND
OF CONTRACT TRACING THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO DO THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN. ITALY-
UNDERSTANDABLE FROM A
CONTAGIOUS CONTAGION
PERSPECTIVE SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER WE'RE DOING
HERE DOES NOT IMPEDE RESEARCH
IF WE GO BACK AND WE START
SAYING OKAY WHAT WHAT COULD WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM THE DATA THAT
WE DID COLLECT AND- AND CAN WE
KEEP IT IN. IN A- THE DATA.
DISAGGREGATED IN A PUBLIC
SPHERE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN DO
RESEARCH SO THAT WE LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE FROM IT SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE AND I WANT TO
SUPPORT IT SO I WILL TODAY. BUT
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT TRUCK
JUST. GETTING RID OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN
PRODUCE PRODUCE. PRODUCE SOME
PRETTY GOOD RESULTS I THINK IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING HOW WE
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD YEAH I
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I SHARE ALL OF YOUR
CONCERNS- AND YOU KNOW ANY
EXCEPTIONS. THAT WE HAVE WHICH
IS WHY I FEEL LIKE WE'RE SO
CLOSE TO DC TO RESOLVING VALID.
ISSUES THAT THEY THEY ARE
RAISING- YOU KNOW STATE AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS CAN
KEEP DATA LONGER THAN SIXTY
DAYS AND WHEN ONE OF THE
EXCEPTIONS HERE. WE ALSO HAVE-
ABILITIES TO SHARE- WHEN YOU'VE
GOT REQUESTS FOR APPROVALS FROM
THE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION
BEING YOU SEE- ALONG WITH THEIR
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
HUMAN SUBJECTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HHS SO THERE ARE.
THERE ALREADY IN THE BILL WAYS
TO MAKE THESE THESE THINGS WORK
BUT WE WANT TO GO AND MEET YOU
SEE A LITTLE BIT CLOSER-
BECAUSE I DO SHARE THEIR THEIR
VALID CONCERNS AS WELL THIS IS.
WHAT IT IS COMPLICATED BUT IT
IT IS COMPLEX AND IT- IT IT IT
CALLS FOR THE ATTENTION THAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR. PARTY THANK
YOU- SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK
YOU CHAIR. I'VE TAKEN A LOT OF
VOTES ON PRIVACY LAW RELATED
MATTERS- JUST LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SPECIALLY
INJURED DISH. AND I'VE TRIED TO
DO FOR THAT. BECAUSE IT REALLY
IS I CAN'T ALLOW FOR THE FULL
X. IN COMMODITIES A OF INFOR.
ON NO CAN YOU. ALLOW THE
PENDULUM TO SWING TOO FAR
WHERE. ESSENTIAL INFORMATION IS
NOT AT. DISPOSABLE AT THE
DISPOSAL OF INDIVIDUALS- THAT
NEEDED AND I'M I'M CONCERNED
AND I VOTED FOR A NUMBER OF
YOUR ITEMS BEFORE THIS ONE I'M
I'M CONCERNED GOES A LITTLE BIT
TOO FAR. AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MOMENTS IN CONVERSATION
STILL ON GOING. BUT I HAVE TO
KIND OF GO BACK TO MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. WHERE SOMETHING
NEW HAPPENS AND WE SPENT THE
NEXT. SIX MONTHS NINE MONTHS
TRYING TO ACCUMULATE
INFORMATION. IN LEARN AS
QUICKLY AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE
WHAT THIS VIRUS WAS ABOUT AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
EVEN IDENTIFIED THAT- WE HAD
MAJOR FAILURES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHEN IT CAME TO CONTACT
TRACING BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO DISCLOSE THE
INFORMATION AND YOU COULDN'T BY
FORCE OF LAW ANOTHER MEANS
PRODUCE THAT FOR SOME PRODUCE
THAT. AND WE ALSO DIDN'T HAVE
THE FOLLOW THROUGH OF PLACES OF
EMPLOYMENT AND CO HABITATION
AND ALL THAT WENT ALONG WITH
THAT SO. WE NOW HAVE A NEW
VARIANT THAT IS APPARENTLY MORE
CONTAGIOUS. THAN ON THE
ORIGINAL THAT WAS INTRODUCED.
INTO THE U. S. YEAR AND A HALF
AGO. AND I JUST BEEN TRYING TO
WRAP MY ARMS AROUND WHY WE
WOULD BE RESTRICTING
INFORMATION IF SAFEGUARDS CAN
BE PUT INTO PLACE IN LEGAL
MEASURES CAN BE PUT INTO PLACE
THAT WOULD DISALLOW THE ABUSE
AND MISUSE OF THAT INFORMATION.
NOW YOUR TICKET LATE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AS BEING AN ENTITY
THROUGH WHICH A LOT OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE OUR ON GOING.
BUT THERE'S PLENTY OF PRIVATE
RESEARCH ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT
AFFILIATED WITH UNIVERSITIES
THAT ARE GOING TO NEED THIS.
AND A LOT F THESE
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD HAVE
COMPLETE ACCESS. OR MORE FREE
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION.
MAYBE THE SEGREGATION IS THE
WAY THAT HE CAN BE MAINTAINED
WHILE IDENTITIES ARE PROTECTED-
BUT I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT WE
ARE ALLOWING THE PRIVACY
ARGUMENT. TO OVERWHELM US WHEN
WE ARE STILL IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC WITH THE NEW VARIANT
ON THE STAGE. AND SO I THINK
YOU KNOW ONE OF THOSE CONCERNS
SO FOR EXAMPLE VACCINATION
STATUS. NOW IS THAT CAN YOU CAN
YOU ARTICULATE OR CONFIRM THAT
VACCINATION STATUS IS A PIECE
OF INFORMATION THAT WILL. B.
DEEMS RECOVERABLE OR WOULD THAT
NEED TO BE DELETED. IN THE
SIXTY DAYS AS WELL. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER WERE JUST
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT VACCINES
THERE IS NOT THE WORD VACCINE
IN THE BILL. SORT OF BORED JUST
AS THAT RESPOND YOUR QUESTION
I'M NOT I'M NOT I'M NOT CERTAIN
IT DOES- IN TERMS OF. WHETHER
OR NOT SOMEONE STATUS AS HAVING
BEEN SICK OR NOT. WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC OR THROUGH
ANY OTHER. ACTUATION IS THEIR
STATUS CONSIDER PROTECTED
PRIVACY MATTERS OR WOULD THAT
BE MAINTAINED IN. THE EXAM TWO
CATEGORIES. SOME I'M NOT. I'M
NOT SURE IF- YOU KNOW IT IF WE
JUST GO BACK TO WHAT THE BILL
IS ATTEMPTING TO DO IT'S
PROHIBITING EMPLOYEES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS FROM
CONDUCTING CONTACT TRACING AND
IT ALSO PROHIBITS THAT DATA
THAT IS COLLECTED- AND RECEIVED
HER PREPARED FOR CONTACT TRICKS
TREATING PURPOSES FROM BEING
USED OR DISCLOSED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES THEN CONTACT TRACING
ITSELF IT DOES OF COURSE HAVE
THE EXEMPTIONS FOR THE RESEARCH
WHICH WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT-
SO IT'S INFORMATION COLLECTED
IN CONTACT TRACING- SAID I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW
FROM A PEOPLE POWER PERSPECTIVE
WHICH I THINK WE ALL WERE VERY
CONCERNED EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC
IF WE'RE DOING A CONTACT PERSON
THAT WE NEEDED TO DO- IF THERE
IS A UNIFORM WAY. THAT THAT WAS
HAPPENING ACROSS COUNTIES- SO
I'M NOT SURE WHAT DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED. OKAY NOW I'M EVEN
MORE CONFUSED. SO THE IF YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED BUT THERE'S AN
EXCLUSIONARY PROCESS. A. B. U.
I THIS BILL RIGHT. AND IT'S
WHATEVER INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED IN CONTACT TRACING SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW IN
THE COUNTY THAT YEAR AND WHAT
WHAT THEY'RE COLLECTING RIGHT
SO YOU'RE ASKING YOU'RE ASKING
ME ABOUT SPECIFIC DATA POINTS.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONTACT TRACING DATA SO
WHATEVER IS BEING CONDUCTED IN
A TRACING. SO IMAGINE. PERSON
ACTS WAS DEEMED TO TEST
POSITIVE. IT THROUGH CONTACT
TRACING IDENTIFIED THAT PERSON
X. HAD A RESTAURANT. OUR
ENGAGEMENT THE DAY BEFORE LIVES
WITH THREE OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
SO ON THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF A
NETWORK OF INFORMATION. THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
CORRECT. BECAUSE THE PATHOLOGY
IN BEHAVIOR HUMAN BEHAVIOR IN
VIRUS PATHOLOGY ARE THINGS THAT
ARE CENTRAL TO ENTER THROUGH
CONTACT TRACING THAT'S WHY
ACADEMICS AND SCIENTISTS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS. DO
THEIR ABSOLUTE BEST TO ASSEMBLE
THIS INFORMATION IN THE
ANALYTICS THAT GO ALONG WITH IT
TO PRODUCE A REPORT THAT
IDENTIFIES TRENDS. THAT ALLOW
US TO PREVENT SIMILAR OUTBREAKS
IN THE FUTURE OR SIMILAR
ENGAGEMENTS IN THE FUTURE. SO
EXACTLY IS YOUR QUESTION. WELL
THE FIRST QUESTION IS
VACCINATION STATUS CONSIDERED-
HE ADDED THAT SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AND PRESERVED OR
DELETED IN SIXTY DAYS YES AS I
MENTIONED THAT VACCINES ARE
MENTIONED IN THE BILL BUT TO
YOUR BROADER QUESTION LOCAL AND
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS CAN
KEEP THE DATA LONGER THAN SIXTY
DAYS HELLO THAT IS NOT ALREADY
AN EXCEPTION IN THE BILL. HOW
LONG CAN THEY KEEP IT. SO THE
SIXTY DAY NUMBER IS WHAT'S IN
THE BILL NOT MUCH LONGER SO I
CAN'T I CAN'T MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR YOU OR I CAN TELL
YOU WHAT THAT NUMBER IS THAT
THEY'LL DETERMINE THAT THEY
NEED IT FOR LOOK LET ME LET ME
LET ME INTERJECT HERE PADDLING
SECOND AS MUCH FUN AS THIS IS
HALF OF IT IN TERMS OF CONTACT
TRACING CONTACT TRACING- CENTER
BOARD IS IF YOU'VE BEEN
CONTACTED BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
IN PROXIMITY TO SOMEONE WHO-
TEST POSITIVE FOR IT AS YOU MAY
KNOW THEY ASK. ABOUT THAT THE
CONTACT THAT RELATIONSHIP
SHOULD TECH TRACING SO FAR AS I
KNOW DOES NOT INVOLVE INQUIRY
AS TO VACCINATION STATUS EITHER
WHETHER ONE'S BEEN VACCINATED
HOW MANY TIMES ONCE VACCINATED
OR NOT VACCINATED OR REASONS
WHY SO THAT DATA WOULD NOT BE
IN THE SIMPLY MEMBER LIVING YOU
CAN CORRECT ME THAT THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE COLLECTED IN
CONNECTION WITH CONTACT TRACING
SO SOME REMEMBER LEVIN CARE TO
COMMENT ON MY COMMENTS. NO
WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
HELPS OR HINDERS THE INQUIRY
CENTER MORICHES SURGEON JUST TO
CLARIFY WHEN INDIVIDUALS WERE
REACHING OUT- ORAS THEY HAVE
FOR THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS-
ARE YOU SAYING THAT NOT. DURING
THE CONTACT TRACING PROCESS
THEY DON'T INQUIRE INTO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S VACCINATION STATUS.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON CONTACT
TRACING BUT THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPERIENCE
YES OKAY THE ASSOCIATION
MODELING THAT GOES IN THE
CONTACT TRACING IDENTIFIES TILL
THERE'S A CONTAINMENT- RATIO
WHERE THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED. UP
A CIRCLE OF INTERACTION. NOW IN
ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD BEEN
VACCINATED BUT STILL EITHER
TESTED POSITIVE OR- EXHIBITED
SYMPTOMS. THE ENTIRE NOTION OF
CONTACT TRACING IS TO
INVESTIGATE THE BREATH IN THE
EXPERT EXPOSURE- THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE GONE THROUGH.
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT-
TRACY CONTACT TRACING
INFORMATION HE CAN INCLUDE. A
WHILE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
ASSORTMENT OF INFORMATION THAT
COULD BE TERRIBLY HELPFUL. FOR
RESEARCH AND ACADEMICS AND
OTHERS IN OTHER. I MEAN MY
MISSING SOMETHING HERE. I MEAN
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR'S ENTHUSIASM I NOTED ON
THAT ISSUE SO UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE LOSING SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BUDGET WHICH WILL
THEY WILL RETURN A NUMBER ONE
POINT NUMBER ONE POINT NUMBER
TWO IS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
IF YOU CARE TO RESPOND TO THAT
EITHER NOW OR IN THE CLOTHES WE
WOULD WELCOME THAT- IT AS TO.
WHETHER OR NOT- THE METHODOLOGY
FOR CONTACT TRACING EITHER DOES
OR DOES NOT INCLUDE VACCINATION
STATUS PRESS YOU TO RESPOND TO
THAT AND IF IT DOES INCLUDE
VACCINATION STATUS WHAT IS THE
IMPACT UPON THAT BASED ON YOUR
BILL. FOR ALL HELL IN MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
YES SINISTER. THANK YOU. I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE TALKED THIS
WENT THROUGH AND I APPRECIATE
HIS FAMILY MEMBERS- RESPONSES
THUS FAR ESPECIALLY TO THE
COMMITMENTS IN THE GOOD FAITH
WORK GOING ON WITH YOU SEE
AMONGST MY COLLEAGUES OF THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THE I MAY NOT BE
I I'VE READ THROUGH THE
ANNOUNCES A FEW TIMES. AND THE
BILL WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IS BEYOND THE SORT OF
RECORD RETENTION ISSUE THAT WE
KNOW YOU'RE- TRYING TO WORK ON
AND SETTLE. AM I MISREADING THE
BILL. TO SAVE IT YOU SEE OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR YOUR CS
YOU. COULD NOT CONDUCT CONDUCT
CONTACT TRACING UNLESS IT WAS
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES OR IS THAT
NOT. NO THAT'S NOT IT NOT THAT
NOT ENOUGH SO EVEN THOUGH THE
DEFINITION OF LAUNCH HI I MISS
READING AT THAT SO THE
DEFINITION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IT SAYS THAT YOU KNOW A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CAN ONLY
CONDUCT CONTACT RACING. FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES AT THE SAME LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. JUST
BECAUSE YOU SEE SEE AS HUMAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE UNDER
THAT DEFINITION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WE'RE STILL
GOING TO LET THEM. DO CONTACT
TRACING ON THEIR CAMPUS BUT
THEY CAN'T HAVE LIKE A- CAMPUS
POLICE BE THE ONE TO VISIT IS
THAT SORT OF THING YEAH
EXACTLY. OKAY SO THEY CAN STILL
CONDUCT THE CONTACT TRACING
EVEN IF IT'S NOT JUST THEIR
EMPLOYEES EVEN IF IT'S-
STUDENTS OWNER KNOWS THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WOULD NOT
YOU KNOW HOW TO DO THAT. ONE
PERSON OFFICE COULD NOT BUT-
YOU SEEN BEFORE EMPLOYEE EARLY.
AND THEN HAVE SOMEONE ELSE
VISIT THAT DORM ROOM OR
WHEREVER IT IS. ALL RIGHT SO
LONG AS IT WAS NOT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. DOING THAT
INTERFACING OKAY GREAT. THANKS
FOR THAT UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MEASURE OF ITS PROPERTY THANK
YOU. FOR THE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SEEING SEEING NONE- I'M
SORRY SIR WINNER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- MR CHECK MISTER
CHAIRMAN I SPOKE TO THE AUTHOR
ON ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL- AND I
APOLOGIZE I WAS OUT TO SENDING
A BILL SO THIS CAME UP ALREADY
WHILE I WAS PRESENTING
APOLOGIZE. ON THAT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE BILL HAS AN
EXEMPTION FOR OUR COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH- AND THAT I DO. BELIEVE
THAT- THAT YOU SEE SHOULD HAVE-
IT'S NOT THE SAME IN SIMILAR OR
SOME SORT OF GUARD RAIL-
EXEMPTION. BECAUSE YOU SEE A
AND THEN WE SAW THIS IN THIS
KIND OF AMERICAN SOME WAYS
FUNCTIONS. LIKE A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT A LOT OF WAYS AND
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF HIS
BASIC. PUBLIC HEALTH WORK
HAPPENING AT OUR UC CAMPUSES
ARE LITTLE DIFFERENT VERY
DIFFERENT THAN A- PRIVATE
ENTITY WHERE I COMPLETELY I.
UNDERSTAND THE PRIVACY CONCERNS
AND SO I WILL I'M GLAD AND I
AGREE WITH THE AUTHORS
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE YOU
SEE I DON'T THINK IT'S A BROAD.
MAJOR AMENDMENT I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY A VERY NARROW
EXEMPTIONS THAT YOU SEE WHEN
IT'S- CAN RETAIN THIS DATA. FOR
RESEARCH AND DATA.
DISAGGREGATED DATA COLLECTION
PURPOSES WITHOUT HAVING TO GET
IT FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT- AND YOU KNOW I GOT
I COME OUT TO US. FROM THE WORK
WE'VE DONE DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHICH REALLY SHOWED SOME OF THE
REAL DEFICIENCIES. ON OUR DATA
COLLECTION- SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
WORKING ON THEIR PROFOUND LACK
OF LGBTQ. DATA COLLECTION
AROUND KOBE BUT IT'S A BROADER
THAN THAT WE JUST DON'T DO A
GREAT JOB. AND THE LGBTQ
CONTACTS WE LEARNED AFTER THE
FACT. THAT THE CDPH AFFECTED WE
WAS REALLY ONLY COLLECTING
CONTACT TRACING RELATED. DATA
WHICH IS. PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
IT WASN'T THE ACTUAL TESTING
DATA BUT AT LEAST IT WAS
SOMETHING- AND SO THAT THE
CONTEXT RAISING DATA WHEN IT'S
DISAGGREGATED SO IT'S NOT
VIOLATE ANYONE'S PRIVACY. CAN
BE QUITE VALUABLE AND I WOULD
HATE TO HAVE TO JUST DELETE
THAT AND- AND SO THAT'S WHY I%
DO THINK INCLUDING YOU SEE
WOULD BE A GOOD THING SO. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
I APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR'S
CONTINUING WORK. OR THANK YOU
SIR- OTHER QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS SAYING NONE- I BELIEVE
SENATOR STERN HAS MOVED THE
BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES
MEMBER LIVING YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN TO
YOU AS WELL AS TO YOUR STAFF
THIS IS BEEN- A YEAR IN IN THE
WORKS- IN A VERY CHALLENGING
YEAR SO THAT'S ONE OF THE OTHER
REASONS WHY I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR.
EVERYONE WHO CONTRIBUTED TO- TO
THIS BILL AND WHO WILL CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE AS WE RESOLVE
SOME OF THE- THE LAST SMALL
PARTS THAT- I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET TO. THE CLOSURE ON
WHAT YOU SEE. VERY GRATEFUL FOR
SENATOR WIENER REACHING OUT TO
ME PERSONALLY I HAD A TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT I WAS AWARE OF-
HIS HIS CONCERNS ON THE BILL.
AND I ALSO THINK- ALSO. TO
CENTER BOARD USES COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW IT. YOU
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF A LOT
OF MY PRIVACY BILLS IN THEPAST
AND I'VE BEEN GRATEFUL FOR THAT
BUT I THINK OUT OF RESPECT TO
YOU- REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU'RE
VOTING TODAY. EVEN HOW YOU VOTE
WHEN IT COMES TO YOU AGAIN AND
I HOPE THAT IT DOES COME TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. THAT THAT I WILL
HAVE MY STAFF REACH OUT TO
YOURS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE. ANY CONCERNS THAT YOU
HAVE. THIS BEING A YEAR. IN THE
IN THE WORKS IN ONE OF THE
SCARIEST YEARS- OF OUR LIVES.
OF ALL HUMANITIES LIVES THOSE
OF US THAT YOU KNOW ARE ARE.
LIVING THROUGH THIS. WE WOULD
NEVER CURTAIL. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ABILITIES OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES FROM.
MAKING SURE THEY WOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
US SAFE AND YOU'VE GOT MY
COMMITMENT FOR THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ADULT.
THANK YOU MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF
YOU CALL THE ROLL THIS IS A. B.
EIGHT FOURTEEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER LIVED IN WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS.
THE PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AMBERG AMBERG BY BURGESS.
GORGEOUS NO PARTY AT ALL DID
ASAL GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG JONES LAYERED STERN. STERN
I WAKE HOUSEKI WINNER WINNER HI
YOU HAVE FOUR TO ONE SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING OR I WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL. NEXT WE HAVE-
WE HAVE SENT TO EXUDE A SIMILAR
MEMBER LEVIN YOUR NEXT BILL IS.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY. VERY GOOD
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY THANK YOU
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY AUTHORIZES
SMALL BUSINESSES TO RECOVER
ATTORNEYS FEES TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES FROM LAWSUITS
ARISING FROM POORLY MARKED AND
SUBSEQUENTLY DAMAGED
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CPUC INITIATED AN
INVESTIGATION TO PG&E PEONIES
LOCATE AND MARK PROGRAM THE C.
P. C. REPORT DETERMINED THAT
PG&E FALSIFIED UP TO ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN RECORDS. THESE MARKINGS
ARE USED BY CONSTRUCTION CREWS
TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE
THEIR DANGEROUS UNDERGROUND
PIPELINES ARE LOCATED THE CPC
ALSO REPORTED SIXTY SEVEN
INSTANCES OF DAMAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A RESULT OF
THESE FALSIFIED RECORDS THE CPC
ULTIMATELY FIND P. JEANNIE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THESE VIOLATIONS THROUGH
THE COURSE OF THE INVESTIGATION
IT WAS DETERMINED THAT PG&E
WOULD LEVERAGE ITS LEGAL
RESOURCES TO FILE CLAIMS
AGAINST LESS RESOURCEFUL OR
LESS RESOURCE EXCAVATION
CONTRACTORS. INVESTIGATION
FOUND THAT P. GINNY CREATED A
WAR ROOM WITH THE SOLE INTENT
TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS AGAINST CONTRACTORS
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY WILL MAKE
UTILITY COMPANIES THINK TWICE
BEFORE FIRING OFF CLAIMS AND
WILL FORCE THEM TO INCREASE THE
ACCURACY OF THEIR UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE LOCATING PROGRAM
INCREASING SAFETY FOR WORKERS
AND THE PUBLIC THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF
SENATE BNP LAST WEEK
UNANIMOUSLY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE AND I DO HAVE
TO IN THIS IS FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHTY- I BELIEVE
HIM STEVE WARD AND GERALD. MO
SIS. MR WARD. ONE MILLION
CANADIAN AND GERMAN. THE
FUNERAL. BONDS TO BE MORE YOU
CAN'T RECYCLE BINS ALSO
CURRENTLY PREGNANT- THEY ASK IF
A. CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M LOOKING TO
KILL MICHAEL STORING ON BEFORE
I JOINED THE RECYCLING SYSTEM
DOES MORE COMPETENT EMPLOYEES
SUBCONTRACTORS- FOR GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION ON A STICK. ISLAND
PROJECT IN TWENTY NINE PALMS.
AARON SPELLING SOME. OF BLOOD
THE HARD LESSON- ARE YOU AFTER
THE PROJECT WHICH IS
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE- GRANITE
CONTACTED ME AND SAID WE WERE
WE GOT A PLANE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SAYING THAT
WE HAVE TO GET ONE OF THEIR
BALLS. WHEN I REQUESTED
PICTURES OF THE DAMAGE MY GOD
IT WAS OBVIOUS- MICHAEL PLAYER
DID NOT DO THAT THE PROJECT IS
STILL ONGOING GOOD START OUR
COUNTRY AND I WILL REMEMBER.
THIS MALL COMPANY- STORY ON THE
UNITED PLANET THE LONG WITH THE
BAND AND FIND CLAIM AND
CORRELATIONS SIGNALS THEN WENT
TO COURT. AND ON- WE PREVAILED
IN COURT WE WON THE CASE AND
WAS NOT OUR FAULT-
UNFORTUNATELY. THE CLAIMS FOR
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A
CONSTANT BATTLE WITH THE
HOMEOWNERS AND- SO. I FELT
COMPELLED TO GET THERE. ARM AN
ISLAND ONCE AGAIN THAT IN THE
FUTURE I GOT A SMALL PARTY AT
TWENTY THOUSAND ALL THE CLAIMS
EVEN THOUGH IT'S DIFFICULT TO
DO ARMS. THE PLANE AND NOT GO
TO COURT ANDI BELIEVE THAT THE
ALL OF THE FUTURE HELLO AND NOT
JUST AT THE CENTER OF GENE-
THEY REALIZED SLOWLY TURNING.
TO FIND OFFICE. AND THE- THE
PAY NINETEEN OF THEM ALL WITH
YEARS- THANK YOU GOOD
PARTICULAR. THE YOU CLICK YOU
KNOW VERY VERY HAPPY ON THEIR
MORTARS ON THE HIGHER MORE- IF
THE REAL LINING RIGHT SIR MR A
THANKS IF YOU GO WRAP IT UP.
FINAL ROUND WITH ON URGE YOU
KNOW ON. LEVEL PLAYING FIELD-
IT MAKES IT CLEAR FROM THE
LITTLE GUY. AND WILL PRESENT
YOU ALREADY KNOW THANK THANK L.
STRING ON. RT THANK YOU MR.
WARD- MISMOS THESE- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S GERALD
MOUSE'S I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
LAW IN CALIFORNIA FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS AND THEN THE
MANAGING PARTNER OF THE MOUSE'S
LAW FIRM. IN TUSTIN- WE
SPECIALIZE IN CONSTRUCTION LOAN
AND CONSTRUCTION RELATED ISSUES
I'M ALSO A BOARD MEMBER OF
SCCA- TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT
ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISIONS HAVE
ALWAYS HAD A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT
IN CURBING ABUSES. AND IN
REDUCING FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION.
WE FOLLOW THE AMERICAN RULE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA MEANING. ALL
PARTIES PAY THEIR OWN WAY ONCE
IT COMES TO LITIGATION. BUT
THERE ARE TWO MAIN EXCEPTIONS
ONE IF THERE IS A CONTRACTUAL
PROVISION WHERE THE PARTIES
NEGOTIATED AND ATTORNEYS FEES
PROVISION AND SECONDLY BY
STATUTE- IN THESE TYPES OF
LAWSUITS THERE IS NO CONTRACT.
BETWEEN THE UTILITY AND THE
EXCAVATOR THEREFORE WE HAVE TO
RELY ON STATUTE AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. IT'S NOT
DISSIMILAR TO WHAT OTHER
STATUTES- THE PAST BY- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE HAD IN
THE PAST THE CALIFORNIA FALSE
CLAIMS ACT- MODELED AFTER THE
FEDERAL FALSE CLAIMS ACT.
ENACTED IN THE EIGHTEEN SIXTIES
DURING RECONSTRUCTION TO CURB
ABUSES- INCLUDED IN THE A. ONE
WAY ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISIONS
FOR THE PROSECUTING AUTHORITY
COULD GET ATTORNEYS FEES IN
ADDITION TO THE PENALTIES. OUT
OF A CONTRACTOR WHO SUBMITTED A
FALSE OR FRAUDULENT CLAIM AND
THEN WHEN THERE WERE SOME
ABUSES BY THE AUTHORITIES AND
THAT. THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT
BUT WITH THE CONTRACTOR HAD TO
SHOW WAS FRIVOLOUS WE ARE
PROMPT PAYMENT STATUTES-
CALLING FOR ATTORNEYS FEES
WHERE PAYMENT IS WE AT THE END
SLAPP STATUTE OR ATTORNEYS
FEES. CAN BE AWARDED TO A
PREVAILING PARTY WAS WINSTON
MOUSE'S IF YOU COULD WRAP IT UP.
I WILL SIR THANK YOU- IT JUST
CAN IN CLOSING EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
POLICY BEHIND ALL OF THESE
STATUTES- AND IS THE UNDERLYING
STATUTES THAT THIS BODY IS
PASSED BEFORE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
PARTY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
TODD BLOOM STEIN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION SPONSORS OF THE
BILL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHERS I SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ON
THE PHONE LINE THOSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU LIKE TO COME AND SUPPORT
IN THE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO WINNING QUEUE ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION- I SEE
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION AT LEAST
LISTEN IN OPPOSITION- AND I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY NO NO NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB. NINE THIRTY. THE COMMON
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE THIRTY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT
THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S COME
BACK TO THE CHAMBER CENTER
BOARD JUST. CLICK TO MOVE THE
BILL. CENTER BOARD JUST MOVES
THE BILL SAYING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED. SEVEN
MEMBER LEVIN WHO CARE TO CLOSE
RESPECT LAST FOREVER THANK YOU
TO FULL BEAUTIFUL CLOTHES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- THE MOTION BY
CENTER BOARD JUST MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS THE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY BY A FAMILY MEMBER
LEVINE WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR FOR JUST THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST TO BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI. AMBER
GUY BURGESS. BURGESS I CARRY IT
ALL. DID ASAL. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ BY HERTZ BERG. JOHNS
LAYERED. STERN STERN I WAKE
OWSKI WINNER. WINNER I SO FAR
YOU HAVE FIVE TO ZERO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL ALL RIGHT.
NEXT WE HAVE VIOLATED HIM LET'S
SEE NUMBER TWENTY TWO A. B.
FIVE SIX TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW I THINK WE HAVE JUST
CROSSED THE HALFWAY MARK. AND
IT'S ONLY FOR FORTY FIVE. SO.
THERE WE GO THE SERVER NUMBER
LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
TWO MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
DIDN'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SOME NEW
MEMBER LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR EXCELLENT PRESENTATION
ALL RIGHT I SEE THAT- ANTONIO
HERNANDEZ CONDE A DOCTOR
ANTONIO AND IN THIS COUNTRY IS-
QUEUED UP TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR ANTONIO HERNANDEZ
TALKING ON A CARDIAC
ANESTHESIOLOGIST AT THE KAISER
PERMANENTE A LOS ANGELES
MEDICAL CENTER I AM ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
LEGISLATIVE AND CRACKED AT THE
FAIR CONDITION. THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
THAT'S PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
PROVISION ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ARE
GUARDIANS OF PATIENT SAFETY IN
THE OPERATING. IN DELIVERY ROOM
IN INTENSIVE CARE UNIT IN PAIN
MANAGEMENT CLINIC AND ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OF PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WE UNDERGO
OVER TWELVE YEARS OF EDUCATION
AND TRAINING TO NAVIGATE
CRITICAL LIFE AND DEATH MOMENTS
IN THE OPERATING ROOM AND
MULTIPLE PROCEDURAL AREA. WE
ALSO PROVIDE EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND SERVICE EARLY MANAGEMENT
EXPERTS FOR THE TICKET THAT
PATIENTS DIAGNOSED. WITH AND
STUFF- CODE NINETEEN. OUR
POSITION LIKE A NURSES ANOTHER
FOR LINE WORKERS HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY STRESS
DURING THE PAST YEAR WORKING
LONGER HOURS DAY AFTER DAY. IN
TOP CONDITION NEVER BEFORE. THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THEY ALL HAVE ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVE AND CONFIDENTIAL
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESOURCES IF NEEDED. WE NEED
DIVISION ANESTHESIOLOGIST IN
ALL OF OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS
AND PROVIDERS TO STAY
PHYSICALLY HEALTHY AND MENTALLY
STRONG SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. THE BEST CARE POSSIBLE
FOR EVERYONE. THEREFORE THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS STRONGLY
BELIEVE EIGHTY FIVE THE TWO
WILL CREATE NEW TOOLS TO MANAGE
BURNOUT. ENTRY PROLONGED STRESS
AND TRAUMA THE BEAUTY OF IT
BEING FIRST HAND THE
DEVASTATING EFFECT THE COVE
NINETEEN. OFF ON MINE WORKERS
DESERVE TO RECUPERATE AND MOVE
FORWARD WTH RENEWED RESILIENCY
AS WE ALL RECOVER FROM THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA.
SCHLAFLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
ESPECIALLY THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SLOW AND FLORA FOR THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU DR- NURSE. DENISE
DUNCAN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. HI X.
THIS ERIC WILL BLITZ ON BEHALF
OF. DUNCAN AND THE UNITED
NURSES I'M SORRY. THE
CALIFORNIA UNION MR ALMOST GO
AHEAD DO YOU KNOW HOW CAN YET
YES. I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN- IF
THIS IS THEIR RELIGION I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS THAT
YOU ACT AS WELL AS THOSE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THAT SHARE
OUR CHALLENGES AND CONCERNS- IT
HAS BEEN A POP HERE IT'S VERY
SCARY YEAR FOR MANY OF US-
THEIR STORIES OF EXHAUSTION
LOSS OF PATIENT AND FAMILY
MEMBERS HAD LED TO DEPRESSION
SUICIDE. IN ESPORTS NURSES AND
OTHER PROVIDERS TO LEAVE THEIR
PROFESSION WHICH SHORTAGES AND
RETIREMENTS IN MOTION WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO LEAVE OUR REMAINING
WORKFORCE WITHOUT THE
APPROPRIATE EMOTIONAL. AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SUPPORT AS WE ALL
KNOW THE PANDEMIC IS STILL WITH
US. WITH THE COMMUNITY DIVIDED
AROUND VACCINATION ANY MORE
CONTAGIOUS AND FASTER SPREADING
VIRUS. THIS ADDS TO CONCERNS
AROUND THE FUTURE OF MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR WORKFORCE AND FOR
MANY AN INABILITY TO COPE AND
MOVE ON WE NEED YOUR HELP AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHTS OF OTHERS ON THE FORCE
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE GALLERY NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF. AB FIVE SIX TWO. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FIVE SIX TWO TO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FIRST YOU GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR MEMBERS POINT
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
AFFILIATE SHANTI PAPPU THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LAURIE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN FRONT OF HORRIFIED. IF YOU
THINK YOU THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
CHAIR MEMBER CHRISTOPHE BERRA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FINALLY LET ME HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL MEETING
B. DIFFICULTY AGENCY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION
I'VE NO OPPOSITION LISTED- I
SEE NO ONE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THE GALLERY NOR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATE IS
ANYONE. FIVE SIX TWO. HE WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON A PETITION
TO MAYBE FIVE SIX TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
JUST A MOMENT ALL RIGHTY.
WE GO
TO LINE TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI ACTUALLY CALLING- THE
COURT WITH A GRANDPA THE
NATIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA HEARING FOR PART OF
IT SO FAR. ALREADY THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
MR MODERATOR- IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THE- AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE FLOOR C. CENTREBOARD DISS
MICROPHONE UP CENTER BOARD
JUST. MOVE THE BILL SUPPORTERS
MOWS THE BILL I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED THE SEVEN
MEMBER LOW I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN MATCH YOUR VERY ELOQUENT
OPENING BUT GO AHEAD GIVE IT A
SHOT. PERFECT YOU DID SO ALL
RIGHT. THEN CHIEF COUNSEL.
WOULD CALL THE ROLL YES THANK
YOU- THIS IS EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
TWO BY A FAMILY MEMBER LEVEL
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
BOARD JUST THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. AND
BURKE I BURGESS. BURGESS I
CARRY IT ALL. IT ALSO. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTS BURKE. JOHN
LAYERED STERN. STERN I WAKE
OWSKI WHAT CASKEY I WINNER.
WINNER I YOU HAVE SIX TO ZERO
TO FOUR WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL PUT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
A. B. FOUR ONE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS. IN FACT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS HERE
IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SO AFTER WE HEAR FROM.
SIMPLY MEMBER RADIUS. THEN. WE
HAVE- ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB ONE
ONE THREE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. YEAH WE
HAVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER S.
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
HUMAN RIGHTS TO SERVE AS AN
ADVISORY BOARD TASKED WITH
REVIEWING THE STATUS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ENSURING HUMAN RIGHTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IS A CORNERSTONE
OF CALIFORNIA VALUES. ALTHOUGH
THEIR AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
REVIEWING ISSUES MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES FACE. THERE IS NO-CENTRALIZED ORGANIZATION THE
LOOKS AT THE OVER ARCHING HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUES. AS A LEADER IN
SOCIAL JUSTICE. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A FORMAL STATE
EIGHT THIRTY PM TO T. BUTTON
THE PRICE HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
CONCERNS OR SHORT COMINGS
INCLUSIVE OF THE INTERSECTION
OF VARIOUS FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. ILLUSTRATES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AB FOR TWELVE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GUIDE INNOVATIVE NEW POLICIES
BY CENTRALIZING THE
CONVERSATION ON HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND BRINGING TOGETHER LEADERS
EXPERTS AND LEGISLATORS TO
PRODUCE REGULAR REPORTS FOR
BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. R. AMOR RECEIVED FROM
CARE CALIFORNIA AND JOSEPH
SWAYS FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
COMMISSION ON HUMAN RIGHTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE AMIR
RASHID AND JOSEPH JOSEPH SUIS
ARM IN SUPPORT. IF- THE GO
AHEAD IS THIS AMIR RASHID. YES
SIR THANK YOU BYE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KAREN PATTERNS OF THE
COMMITTEE- FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND THANK YOU MAJORITY LEADER
RAY AS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
PROMOTING HUMAN RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS BY JAPANESE AB FOR
TWELVE. MY NAME IS AMBER SHE'S
REPRESENTING CHAIR CALIFORNIA
THE LARGEST MUSLIM RIGHT
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY AND
WE ARE PROUD TO BE THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ALONGSIDE
CHARLOTTE AND THE WORKING
CENTRE ALONG POVERTY SHOULD
ENGAGE IN WHICH OUR SOCIETY IS
BEING INCREASED PAY TARGETING
AN ARRAY OF COMMUNITY IN
RENEWING CONVERSATION
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS AND IDENTIFYING AN
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY TO HAVE
BANNED AND MANY KIDS CAN
CONTINUE TO BE FORGOTTEN.
EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE THE
TIMELINESS OF THE WHICH
PROVIDES A MECHANISM FOR
HERITAGE HUMAN RIGHTS CENTER.
CONVERSATIONS AND POLICY
SOLUTIONS. TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO THE LACK OF A- OR
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS OFTEN
DEALING WITH THE HARSH BUT
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
SAME POLICY CONSTRUCTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THERE'S NO
ENTITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SEOUL COCKPIT IS. TO
REVIEW THE RIGHT TO CALIFORNIA
ACROSS ALL SECTORS. IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY MITIGATE. WHEN
NECESSARY. EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE
WOULD PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR INCREASED PARTNERSHIP AND
DIALOGUE ACROSS THE STATE. W.
Q. FIVE THREE ROLE IN
IDENTIFYING THESE JOBS AND
HUMAN RIGHTS UNDER COLLISION
FOR WHICH THE MOST MARGINALIZED
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE. ENTITY
WHICH WOULD BE MADE UP OF HUMAN
RIGHTS EXPERTS FROM CALIFORNIA
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THE
COMMISSION ON HUMAN RIGHTS CAN
CONNECT ACROSS SECTORS. AND
IDENTIFY AND TACKLE LARGE SCALE
TO MY TISSUES WHICH. IMPEDE THE
RIGHT ALL CALIFORNIA. IN
CALIFORNIA. AFTER THE RIGHTS
THE GLANDS AND MAN LIKE HOW.
UPLIFT AND PROTECTED IF WE
DIRECT COMMUNITY. AND LEAD THE
NATION IN THE PROTECTION
ELEVATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS. IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE- I VOTE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER. SHE TELLS OF SWISS.
THANK YOU SHARE AND SENATORS
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND THINK
YOU'LL GET A RAISE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS JOSEPH SLIDE BEHIND THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION. I'LL
BE BRIEF AS A COMMISSIONER I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WITNESS FIRST HAND
THE INCREDIBLE WORK BETTER
HUMAN RIGHTS FOCUSED ENTITY CAN
ACHIEVE WITHIN GOVERNMENT. BY
RESPONDING TO INEQUITY AND
DISCRIMINATION. AND FACTORING
TO SPECIALLY DIFFICULT TIME FOR
OUR STATE PUBLIC HEALTH. SAFETY
AND ECONOMY THE HRC HAVE BEEN
INVALUABLE PARTNER IN SAN
FRANCISCO STAFF WERE INTEGRAL
TO THE CITY'S COVERT COMMAND
pSHIPPING POLICIES AND
INFORMATION WERE VIEWED WITH AN
EQUITABLE LAND. THIS IS ONE OF
THE REASONS AFTER THE SCHOOL
WAS A MODEL CITY FOR THE REST
OF THE NATION AND COVERT
RESPONSE AND OUR RECORD
BREAKING BACK THE DISTRIBUTION.
MAKING US ONE OF THE HIGHEST
VACCINATED POPULATIONS IN THE
WORLD. IT'S NO COINCIDENCE.
CITY WIDE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS AND FUNDING INITIATIVES
FOR BY PARKING L. G. B. T. Q.
PLUS COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
REPORTING MECHANISMS ARE JUST
SOME OF THE HRC SCOPE THESE
DAYS THE ON BUTTON THAT GETS
LORI AND MEDIATION FUNCTION.
THIS CRITICAL WORK WHILE
INVALUABLE AND EXHAUSTED IT'S
NOT ENOUGH AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
CONVERSATION CENTERING HUMAN
RIGHTS. AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO
UPLIFT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION ARE NECESSARY BUT
BECOMES INCREASINGLY COMPLEX.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR INCREASED
PARTNERSHIP AND DIALOGUE ACROSS
THE STATE AND SERVE AS A KEY
ADVISORY WALL ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE SEE OUR COBIT. CLIMATE
CHANGE AND OTHER ISSUES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT ARE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THAT
NUMBER RADIUS THAT. CENTRALIZED
STATEWIDE ENTITY POPULATED BY
EXPERTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO TARGET THESE ISSUES THAT
THEY ARRIVE WILL. BENEFIT ALL
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES. AND
THE HRC THE IN. WITH EXTRA
AGENTS AND OTHER CAL. NEW YORK
AND BEYOND BUT WE A STRANGE.
STATE BODY THIS WORK THE PART.
AND SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE
WOULD ONLY STRENGTHEN AND
BETTER SERVE OUR LEGISLATURE
LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY. THAT'S
WHY THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
YOU ARE STATE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE HAS FORMALLY APPROVED
TO SUPPORT THE P. FOUR ONE
ZERO. IN ORDER TO CALL IN TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
IPHONE. OUR TIME. THANK YOU MR
SWIPES ALL RIGHT- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I SEE NONE
OF THE GALLERY NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON THE PHONE. WHEN THIS
IS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
THOSE IN SUPPORT. PEOPLE LIKE
TO COME IN AND SUPPORT A BABY
FOR ONE TWELVE. S. ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FIRST WE GO TO LINE
TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CATHERINE CAMPBELL WITH
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO CLIMBED TO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TO SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR
CURRENT EVENING MRS JOHN POPPED
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN ACCORDANCE WITH THEM
THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION I SEE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THE GALLERY THERE ARE NONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE ARE NONE.
ON THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. FOUR ONE TWO.
IF YOU LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR ONE TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE FLOOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
FLOOR I SEE NO ONE- I SEE
AMERICAN DOLLARS MOST OF BILL-
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS-
ASSEMBLY. MAJORITY LEADER
RESCUE CARE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ALL RIGHT- MEANT TO
CANCEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL-
YES THIS IS EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE
FAITH FAMILY MEMBER RAY IS-
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR.
FOLLIS THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI AM BERG HI BOARD YES.
ZERO THE RUSSELL THE REST SO I
DON'T SELES CONSULATES I HURTS
BERG. JONES LAYERED AIRED I
STERN. STERN HI MIKE HOW SKI MY
CASKET I WINNER WINNER I YOU
HAVE SEVEN TO ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING PARTY WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU STILL IN
THE RACE ALL RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE.
I AM TWENTY FIVE AB ONE ONE
THREE EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY. MEMBER
RUBIO. YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO- DO YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED ON PAGES
NINE AND TEN OF THE ANALYSIS
YES I DO ALL RIGHT GO HEAD
CLOSURES I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SANDERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY.
ON ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT AN ACT RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT OF UNLICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK ON THIS MEASURE
AMBER REALLY ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY CLEARLY
AND EXPLICITLY PROTECT LOW
LEVEL EMPLOYEES IN THE TEXT OF
THE BILL. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT AN INDIVIDUAL
MUST BE PROVEN TO BE AND I
QUOTE OWNER OFFICER CONTROLLING
SHAREHOLDER OR ANY SIMILAR
POSITION OF AUTHORITY ALLOWING
THEM TO MAKE COMMAND OR CONTROL
DECISIONS REGARDING THE
OPERATIONS AND MANAGEMENT OF
THE UNLICENSED CANNABIS
ACTIVITY. IN ORDER TO FACE
CIVIL PENALTIES. SENATORS
CURRENTLY AT THE BOTTOM CURRENT
ESTIMATES PUT THE VALUE OF THE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AT
AROUND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION AND THAT'S WITH THE B.
DOLLARS PER YEAR. ACCOUNTING
FOR ALMOST 80% OF TOTAL
CANNABIS SALES IN THE STATE ALL
OF THE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IS
BOTH UNTAXED AND UNREGULATED.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS A SERIOUS THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AS PRODUCTS SOLD
AT THESE LOCATIONS EVADE. THE
TESTING REQUIREMENTS THE BILL
HAS ENJOYED THE SUPPORT OF
LABOR UNIONS WHO REPRESENT
THESE EMPLOYEES THE LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ANDLAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE BILL HAS ALSO RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO
THE POINT TO THIS POINT IN THE
PROCESS WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A
BIRD. A BIRD TOOK THE LEGAL ON
BEHALF OF THE U. F. C. W. THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS AND MARTIN PINEDA ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED CANNABIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE SORRY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE SATIRICAL ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE PROCEED. THE
ADDRESS FOR THE RECORD NUMBER
TO TRY TO GO. VIRTUAL WORKERS
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE CANCEL. THREE
YEARS AGO WE HAD BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THE LEGALIZATION OF
CANNABIS FROM I'LL CHECK WITH
OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE BEING TO
LOOK FOR STUDENTS LOOKING FOR
THIS EMERGING INDUSTRY IN THIS
EMERGING WORKFORCE. THE NEED TO
APPROACH EACH CHARACTER HAS
BEEN. EXPLOITED BY SOME REMOVE
YOUR- ARE YOU A HOMEOWNER FOR
THE ONE EVERY. AND LEGALIZE-CANNABIS OPERATOR. THERE'S BEEN.
IT'S BEEN UNFORTUNATE THAT A
LOT OF REPORTS FROM THE LIKES
OF YOUR COMPUTERS AND- INDUSTRY
IN THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE TAKING A
PARTIAL TRANSPOSITION. YOU KNOW
WILL PLAY IT NOT A SMALL PARK
YOU CAN BRING IN A CRACKDOWN ON
THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE AND
HELP. THE CUSTOMERS IF YOU LOOK
AT A LIVING WAGE IN ADDITION TO
THAT I WOULD NOT WANT TO. GO TO
PENN SHARED IN THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT- PROTECTING WORKERS
OBVIOUSLY W. WHAT WHEN AND
WHERE YOU NEVER GONNA PUT OUR
MEMBERS NORMS LAY. STILL
MANAGED IT'S BEEN IN THE WORKS
FOR TWO YEARS NOW WE HAVE
LEARNED MUCH IN THE PUBLIC AND
DROPPED. IT IN THE- FROM
DIFFERENT. LIKE THAT EIGHT
YEARS OFF. VARIOUS DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF THE
LAST YEARS AND REALLY TO LIKE
BELL WHO IS SIMPLY OVER AND
PROBABLY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT. OUR OPPOSITION RATHER
THAN CONTINUE TO OPPOSE OUR
EFFORTS TO BRING BRING THESE
OPERATORS THE LEGAL MARKET
PLACE THEY SHOULD SUPPORT US IN
OUR IN OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
BRING TEMPORARY SPONSOR EQUITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE COMPANY
IS A CAR ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM
CANNABIS THE STATE BUDGET
REFLECTS THAT AT THE DISCO
WHICH ARE QUESTIONS THAT. WILL
HELP FIND SOMEONE HELP UNDER A
BRIDGE TOWARDS EQUITY WITH ALL
THAT WE CAN JUST. BUILD OUR OWN
PEOPLE. HOW PRODUCED RISK OF
MARK PLACE THERE- IN. POWER TO
USE COLOR OF THE NEW DISCUSSION
WITH THE FIRST. RESPECTFUL
ASTRONAUT SAND. THANKS THANK
YOU SIR THREE CALL OF MISTER
MARVIN P. YEAH I'M THE TEN
MEMBER- YOU KNOW ON BEHALF OF
THE NECK AND HAS BEEN LOCATION
THE POOR BABY LET THIRTY EIGHT.
AM AT THE MACROSCOPIC FOUR DID
NOT INCLUDE PROVISIONS TO STOP
ON BY CANADA OPERATORS WHICH
HAS RESULTED IN A LARGE NUMBER
OF OPERATORS FROM CULTIVATION
MANUFACTURING TO RETAIL I'VE
BEEN LET ME TO GET APPROVED
THEY CAN- MAKE SURE TO VISIT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE SEVEN BUT AT THAT TIME IN
GETTING THAT. KIND OF
REGULATORY AGENCIES AUTHORITY
TO IMPOSE THE PENALTIES I. DID
NOT GET THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. DO IS WHAT THE BILL
DOES THAT IN A LOT. OR I. GOT
TO BRING I. SAT WITH. TO COMBAT
THAT AND IF THE MARKET ARE WE
NOT THERE THEY LET THE MARKET
PUTTING PRODUCT OUT THERE THAT
IS CONTAMINATED. I HADN'T BEEN
TESTED. AND IT'S HARMING
CALIFORNIA. I ASK WHY THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENT SEVERAL TIMES TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS- THAT.
HAVE HAD CONTINUAL PUBLIC. I'LL
WE. WE THINK THAT THIS IS VERY
REASONABLE. AND NOT OUR GOAL
AGAIN IS AN THE ONE CROWD BUT
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS A LOT OF
THAT REVENUE IS GENERATED BY
LEGAL CANNABIS OPERATORS WE SAT
IN THE BUDGET I'VE BEEN HERE. I
ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS I
WAS THE CHILD CARE FOR ONE
WOULD LIKE TO UNION MEMBERS
YEAH YOU. WE HAVE I DID CALL
TRADERS ARE HARMING THE
ENVIRONMENT I AND THE LAD
BEHIND THE AGENCY. HI THERE I'M
NOT REALLY IN CANADA HAVE A
TOOLS TO STOP WITH THE EIGHTY
ODD THAT BILL- WE REACH THAT
PLAYED WITH THE BILL I THINK I
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL. ON AND WE
BUY WE ASK FOR AN IPHONE AND
NOT WE THANK YOU WE THINK TAT
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL WHICH- THEY THEY WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND. TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT OUT. TO DRAFT OUT TO
PATIENT CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- OTHER IN
SUPPORT THE GALLERY SEEING NON
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NON ON
THE PHONE LINE. LOTTERY OR ARE
THERE ANY CALLS ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. A. B. ONE
ONE THREE EIGHT. JULY TWO
COMMENTS SUPPORT OF A. B. ONE
ONE THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. FIRST WE GO TO
LINE TWO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG KOHLI
OF A VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
CANNABIS COMPANY FROM CHULA
VISTA TO BRISBANE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
TWO MORE JUST A MOMENT.
THANKS
TO GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
YOUR NUMBER TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT CAN WHIRLING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND WATER ALLIANCE.
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AND A
CURRENT DRIVER RIGHT THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE TO FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. POSTED MAR HOW
THE AMOUNT OF REPRESENTING THE
SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ONLINE ON THE LONG
BEACHCOLLECTIVE PERSECUTION
BOTH IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHERS AND NEXT TO THE TO LINE
TO FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
ARMSTRONG OF THE HALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION
WE STAND IN THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION I SEE- TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTEN OPPOSITION MR
GLAND BACCHUS AND MISS KATHY
SCHEER. MR BACCHUS ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. MR KERRY COMMITTEE
GOING BACK AS A DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU FOR HEARING
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE DIMMER
CAN I- DON'T OPULATED NOT
PROFIT FROM THE SALE OF
CANNABIS WE WORK FOR THE
PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR. THE
STOCK CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING
ARRESTED INCARCERATED. ANOTHER
USE FOR GROWING SMALL AMOUNTS
OF CANNABIS. WE ALSO WANTED TO
FUND DRUG TREATMENT HARM
REDUCTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND TO REINVEST IN
COMMUNITIES THAT THEN
DEVASTATED BY THE DRUG WAR AND
MASS INCARCERATION. I THINK WE
SPONSORED AND SUPPORTED BILL TO
BRING ON MORE EQUITY LICENSES.
FOR EQUITY LICENSEES AND
LEGISLATION TO ASSIST STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND BRINGING
ON MORE EQUITY LICENSES AND
OTHER TYPES OF LICENSES. WE
DON'T WEIGH IN ALMOST A
REGULATORY BILLS. HOWEVER WE
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. CURRENT
LAW ALREADY PUNISHES THE
UNLAWFUL SINGLE CAMPUS. WITH UP
TO SIX MONTHS IN JAIL PERFECT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE SAME
PROSECUTOR COULD THREATEN LOCAL
CONVICTIONS THAT RESULTED IN
CONSERVATION AND TO THREATEN
MASSIVE CIVIL PENALTIES AS WELL
BASED ON SAMETIME SHOCKS.
PREHISTORICAL PLEA BARGAIN THE
DEFENDANT MIGHT HAVE TO ACCEPT
IT ON JUST JAIL SENTENCE. AVOID
CRIPPLING GAP OR ALTERNATELY
EXCEPT CRIPPLING DEBT TO AVOID
THE DANGERS OF COUNTY JAIL.
SCREAMING IN FACT BE PUNISHED
WITH BULLS BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE ELECTED TO GIVE
THIS POWER THE PROSECUTORS AND
COURTS. PROSECUTORS SHOULD
SIMPLY HAVE TO CHOOSE CRIMINAL
OR CIVIL BUT NOT BOTH THIS THIS
BILL GIBSON BUT- WE DON'T
OPPOSE THE PROVISION ALLOWS
PROSECUTORS TO BE REIMBURSED
FOR THE COST OF ENFORCING THE
LAW. WE BELIEVE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT FUNCTIONS SHOULD BE
FUNDED FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUDGETS. NOT FROM
FINES LEVIED BY THE SAME LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. WE KNOW
FROM HISTORY ABOUT THE
FORFEITURE THAT WHEN AN AGENCY
MAY LEGALLY PROFIT FROM THE
TYPE OF ENFORCEMENT. THAT SOME
AGENCIES NOT ALL BUT SOME WILL
INEVITABLY DIVERT RESOURCES
FROM OTHER EFFORTS THE ONE THAT
PAYS FOR ITSELF AND PERHAPS
PROVIDE A LITTLE EXTRA TO BE
ABLE TO COME. THIS IS A
MISTAKE. THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
THAT INCENTIVIZING PROSECUTIONS
IN THIS WAY AND BY ADDING HIGH
CIVIL PENALTIES ON TOP OF
CRIMINAL PENALTIES. IT'S GOING
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF THE
LEGAL STORES. OR OTHER CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES AND WATCH AS WELL AS
ANY PLACE ELSE. WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL OKAY MAYBE YEARS TO
PUNISH. LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF
COLOR HAS IT ALWAYS BEEN THE
HISTORY OF EVERY PENALTY IN THE
CONTEXT OF MARIJUANA OR OTHER
DRUGS. NO MATTER WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. THAT'S HOW
IT GOES WE DO KNOW ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS MARGUS
MISCAVIGE HERE. YES GOOD
EVENING KATHY SHARED RADIO YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTIONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON OUR
CONCERNS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE SET OUT.
THE ANALYSIS. SO THE MEMBERS
ARE AN ENORMOUS IMPROVEMENT AND
WILL HELP TO KEEP THE LAW FROM
BEING USED TO TARGET THE LOW
LEVEL. LOW INCOME EMPLOYEES WHO
HAVE LITTLE CONTROL OVER THE
ILLEGAL OPERATION RUN BY THEIR
EMPLOYER. HOWEVER WE HAVE
REMAINING CONCERNS AND MUST
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION. I JOINED
IN THE COMMENTS OF MR BACK
INSIDE TO THE DANGERS OF
ALLOWING. THE SAME AGENCY THIS
BECAUSE SEVERAL AND CRIMINAL
PENALTIES AGAINST AN INDIVIDUAL.
SECONDLY WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
BECAUSE THE AG COUNTY COUNCIL
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE CITY
PROSECUTORS WILL BE ABLE TO BE
REIMBURSED FROM THE FINES
GENERATED BUT THIS WILL GIVE
THEM AN IMPROPER INCENTIVE. TO
USE THE PROSECUTION OF THE CASE
BECAUSE THE GENERATE REVENUE
FOR THEIR OFFICE. WE REMAIN
UNCONVINCED THAT THE ONEROUS
PENALTIES PERMITTED IN THE CELL
WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF UNLICENSED ESTABLISHMENTS
OPERATING IN THE STATE. INSTEAD
WE FEAR THAT THOSE WHO WILL BE
HURT MOST OF THE PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME PLACES. AT
WHICH- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
COLONEL. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE OF THE
GALLERY NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
ONE TWELVE. ON THE PHONE LINE
DOES AN OPPOSITION MATER IF YOU
PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP. IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. SORRY
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE FLOOR US AND A COUPLE
EURO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT THIS IS- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING THIS BELL- I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION- ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION. THAT THAT THAT
THAT I THINK- I THINK THEY
REALLY RESOLVE IT AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT- BYE BYE
ADDING THAT THE PERSON HAS TO
BE AN OWNER OFFICER OR
CONTROLLING SHAREHOLDER. IN AS
PART OF THE ANALYSIS AS TO
WHETHER THEY- THEY HAD A AND A
COMMAND OR CONTROL DECISION- I
THINK WE SHOULD RESOLVE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT THAT WERE
RAISED IN REGARDS TO HOW IT
GETS USED IN AND INTERPRETED UP
OUT IN THE REAL WORLD AND-
QUITE FRANKLY PART OF THE-
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE. IN
LEGALIZING CANNABIS IS WE
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH TO STOP THE
ILLEGAL TRADE IN THE IN THE
STATE SO IF THE ILLEGAL TRADE
IS EASILY ACCESSIBLE AND CHEAP.
THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE WILL GO
INSTEAD OF THE LEGAL TRADE AND
SO ON THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO
TO PUT TO PUT TEETH IN THE LAW
SO THAT WE CAN. START TO DRIVE
THE ILLEGAL TRADE OUT OF THE
STATE AND INTO SOMEBODY ELSE'S
STATE- THE BETTER OFF WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE AND WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE AND LIKE TO
MAKE THE MOTION. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO THE COVER GIRL
SENATOR CHARLES. YEAH THANK
YOU- I TO HAVE THE SAME ISSUES
AS MY COLLEAGUE- CENTER CAPITAL
HAD JUST MENTIONED ABOUT-
INSURING THAT WERE REALLY GOING
AFTER THE BIGGER GUYS AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS AND FOR
WORKING. ON THIS BECAUSE IT IS
A REALLY BIG ISSUE- YOU KNOW I
STILL I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANY MAYBE WHEN I'M ADDING YOUR
CLOSING REMARKS BUT- I STILL
HAD ISSUES WITH THE- OPPOSITION
I MEAN IN THE GLOBAL CONTACTS
AND I DON'T THINK THIS BILL
DOES THAT BUT IN A GLOBAL
CONTEXT I KNOW. THIS IS A
LARGER ISSUE WITH CONTINUING
TO- CRIMINALIZE- THIS SPECIALLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR FOR MARIJUANA-
AND THAT'S NOT. WHAT TRYING TO
TACKLE HERE THIS IS NOT YOUR
INTENTION WHATSOEVER. BUT I GET
YOU KNOW WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS
SAYING IN THAT SENSE SO- OF
COURSE WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD BUT I.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOUR
MANAGER IN THE CHORUS BRITAIN'S
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND I
REALLY- I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE CLEAR WE'RE
GOING AFTER THE- THE
RINGLEADERS NOT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE. LOOKING AT A LOWER LEVEL
IN THE ORGANIZATION ARE CAUGHT
UP IN IT I DO. NOT SEE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION- IN TERMS OF NOT
REALLY. ATTENDING PEOPLE'S
LIVES BECAUSE THEY'RE CAUGHT UP
IN. AN ILLEGAL OPERATION I
THINK IS A MAN IN SCHOOL A LONG
WAY. TO ADDRESSING THAT. YOUR
BIG PICTURE HERE. WE HAVE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES. WHO ARE
TRYING TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
THEY'RE SPENDING. A LOT OF
MONEY. AND IBM THIS IS
SOMETHING I SAY THIS AS A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT WHO. YOU KNOW
BUT FOR A LOT OF TAXES AND
REGULATIONS. WE HAVE SO HEAVILY
REGULATED AND- IMPOSE VERY HIGH
TAXES ON THIS. INDUSTRY THAT IT
HELPS IN SOME WAYS FUEL AN
ILLICIT MARKET- AND APART FROM
THE TAXES THAT THEY'RE PAYING I
THINK IT'S- BETWEEN THE
CULTIVATION AND USE TAXES LIKE
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. PLUS ANY
LOCAL TAXES. BEST OF ALL SORTS
OF SECURITY AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE. AND FOR THE BIG
OPERATORS THEY CAN ABSORB THAT.
BUT FOR THE ESPECIALLY THE
SMALL LOCAL OPERATORS WITH A
LOT OF THEM IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND LONG BEACH IN OTHER AREAS
TOO AS WELL. THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE REALLY STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE AND- WE HAVE AN EQUITY
PROGRAM SO WE HAVE A LOT OF.
FOLKS WE'VE- IT'S BEEN GREAT TO
GET INTO. WHO WHO SUFFERED THE
MOST DURING THE PROHIBITION. ON
CANNABIS SOME. ME IN NOW AND
MAKE SURE THEY CAN- PARTAKE IN
THE LEGAL BUSINESS- AND IT'S
REALLY UNFAIR. WHEN THEY ARE
BEING UNDERMINED. BY THESE
ILLEGAL OPERATIONS AS A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO WE
NEED TO DEAL. WITH SOME OF THE-
REGULATORY AND TAX STRUCTURES
AS WELL AS SOME OF THE LOCAL
LAND USE STRUCTURES THAT.
EFFECTIVELY BANNED THESE
BUSINESSES AND MOST OF
CALIFORNIA- BUT THIS IS ONE
APPROACH AND SOME HAPPY. TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR
WE ARE OTHER COMMENTS- THE
LAYERED AND SENT AWAY CAL SKI.
THANK YOU MR. FROM THE I REALLY
APPRECIATE SENATOR WIENER'S
COMMENTS AND I WANT TO ADD ONE
THING AND THE- THERE IS AN
ISSUE GOING ON ARE WE AS A
LEGISLATURE DECIDING WHETHER OR
NOT TO EXTEND THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES ARE LOCKED AT SUNSET.
AND THEN THERE ARE CERTAIN
COUNTY STATE CAN'T PROCESS ANY
OF THE PERMITS IN ANY EXPEDITED
WAY. AND WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF
KICKING PEOPLE OUT WHEN WE NEED
TO GET THE MAN AND WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE THE BLACK MARKET AND
THERE'S ONE PARTICULAR CASE IN
POINT. WHICH IS MONTEREY COUNTY
WHICH SENATOR CAFIERO AND I
SHARE. AND THERE WAS A
OF SUPERVISORS THAT YOU COULD
ONLY DO THE GROSS AND
GREENHOUSES AND IF YOU HAPPEN
TO BE ONE OF THE- LEGACY
FARMERS IN BIG SUR THAT'VE BEEN
THERE FOREVER. THEY DON'T HAVE
GREENHOUSES THEY CAN'T COME IN
AND THEY'VE JUST MODERATED THIS
REQUIREMENT IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND PEOPLE ARE STARTING
TO STRUGGLE TO GET THEIR
LICENSE BUT- IF WE SUNSET THE
PROVISIONAL IT MIGHT SUNSET THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO COME IN TO
THE LEGAL POINTS THAT WE WANT
THEM ALL TO BE. BANNED SO
ENORMOUS SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ITIS THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BECAUSE THE REAL QUESTION IS.
IS DO IT PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
PEOPLE TO BE LEGAL AS OPPOSED
OTHERWISE I THINK WE JUST HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T DO OTHER THINGS WERE
PUSHING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM AND THEN PICKING UP IN
FORT SMITH SO- I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT THERE ARE.
THIS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE WITH
LOTS OF MOVING PARTS RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU SAID EARLIER SO MY
CASKET A MYSTERY BOOK QUESTION
OF THE OPPOSITION EITHER MR
BACCHUS SERMONS HERE BECAUSE-
OF ONE THAT COULD WIN THE
OBJECTIONS WAS. THAT IF YOU
HAVE TO D. A. GOING AFTER THE
CIVIL PENALTIES N. AT LEAST
FROM WHERE I WAS SITTING I
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS A
HORRIBLE IDEA BECAUSE HE COULD.
PRESSURE PEOPLE INTO TAKING A
COP INTO THIS THREE HUNDRED OR
THIRTY THOUSAND. A DOLLAR
PENALTY BUT NOW THAT'S THAT'S
REMOVED WITH THE AMENDMENTS AS
I UNDERSTAND IT AND YOU HAVE.
COUNTY COUNCIL AND BIG CITY-
CITY ATTORNEYS SO DOESN'T THAT
ALLEVIATE THE CONCERNS ITSELF
RIGHT IN. THEIR OPPOSITION. LET
ME POSE THE QUESTION WITH A
QUESTION POSED THE OPPOSITION
MR BACCHUS OR MACHINE- ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. I DEFINITELY CARE WE
CAN CLIMB BACK IN THANK YOU
SENATOR WHITE COUNTY. THE BILL-
DOES NOT PROVIDE FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO BE ABLE TO
BRING MISDEMEANOR CHARGES AND
CIVIL CHARGES IT PROVIDES FOR
THE CITY ATTORNEY. IN LOS
ANGELES SATURDAY. LET'S JUST GO
IN THE AREA AND THEY PROSECUTE
MISDEMEANORS INCLUDING THE
POSSESSION SALE OR POSSESSION
FOR SALES CANNABIS. AND PENALTY
IS SIX MONTHS IN JAIL. THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE FOR EACH. AVERAGE
CONNECTION. YOU COULD MAKE A
CHARGE MULTIPLE CHARGES FOR
MISDEMEANOR SALE AND PURSUE THE
CIVIL C. AS WELL SO THAT THE
EXAMPLE OF AGENCY GIVEN THAT
POWER BUT NOT THE
DISTRIBUTARIES OFFICE. I GUESS
THE PROBLEM WAS HE SAID IF YOU
ORIGINALLY THE BILL GAVE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THAT POWER SO
THEN I'M I'VE GOT YOU IN COURT
I'M PROSECUTING YOU. EMILY AND
IT IT SEEMS LIKE THESE ONEROUS
FINES WAS AN OVER REACHING BY
SEPARATING THEM. AND GIVING A
DIFFERENT ATTORNEY AN ATTORNEY
CITY ATTORNEY OF SAN JOSE'S
THEN OF THE BIG REPUTATION
ABOUT GOING AFTER PEOPLE BUT
MAYBE IT COULD HAPPEN THIS N.
THAT. LESSEN SOME OF THIS- THE
AGGRESSIVE ACTIVITY SET UP
CONCERN OF. FULL OF COLOR THAT
MAY BE PROSECUTOR MAYBE PUT IN
A BAD SITUATION WHEN THE WHEN
THE DA'S GOT THEM ON A CRIMINAL
CHARGE. MR BACCHUS SECURE
RESPOND. ZURCHER YES GOOD THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR OWN BERG.
B. I'M GOING TO TAKE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND IN THE FEDERAL
JUDICIARY LIMITED THE NUMBER OF
AGENCIES THAT COULD BRING
SIMULTANEOUS CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT. THE BILL STILL
WILL PROVIDE WITH AMENDMENTS
THAT THE CITY ATTORNEY FROM THE
FOUR LARGEST CITIES WOULD BE
ABLE TO PERSON ALL CIVIL
PENALTIES AND CRIMINAL
PENALTIES. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PART HELPFUL- THERE MAY BE
CONCERN THAT ACTUALLY FOR
CAPITAL THERE ARE MORE. LIKE
CALIFORNIA FOR CITIES ARE
MENTIONED- AND GIVEN HIS POWER
IT'S JUST THAT. BUT THE BILL
DOESN'T HAVE THE ELEMENTS THAT
WILL CREATE MORE LICENSED
STORES INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
MECHANISM AGAINST ONLINE
CONSTRUCTED STATION DOESN'T
DEFINE HOW SMALLER OPERATION
MIGHT BE THERE'S STILL A DANGER
THAT THIS FINDING STUDENTS
CAN'T IT WILL EVENTUALLY BE
USED AT ALL GOOD PENALTIES HAVE
BEEN. TO PUNISH LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR. MR HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION AT THE
OPPOSITION IT APPEARS TO ME
THAT THE AMENDMENT ANOTHER
AMENDMENT TO SORT OF FOCUS ON
THE OWNER THE OFFICERS THE
MAJORITY SHAREHOLDERS. TAKES
AWAY THESE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE AN EQUITY STAKE JUST A LOW
LEVEL. M. EMPLOYEES AND I GUESS
MY CONCERN WITH THE OPPOSITION
CONTINUING ON WITH THAT IS THAT
THIS AIDING AND ABETTING. ONE
OF THE FACTORS ARE OUTLINED ON
PAGE SEVEN OF OUR STAFF REPORTS
TALKS ABOUT PROVIDING
SUBSTANTIAL ASSISTANCE OR
ENCOURAGEMENT. ARE THEY
CONCERNED THAT- OF JUST A
REGULAR EMPLOYEE COULD BE FIRED
BY THE FACT THAT THEY'RE-
WORKING IS THAT. MEET THAT
THRESHOLD FOR ENCOURAGEMENT%
THAT WOULD WOULD CATCH HIM
UNDER THE NETWORK. IT SEEMS
THAT THE AUTHORS TRYING TO
SEPARATE THE BIG CHEESE FROM
THE SMALL SMALL CHEESE- IS THAT
A CONCERN OF THE OPPOSITION. MR
BACCHUS. YOUR ACCOUNT PLEASE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION B.
COMMENT HAVE NARROWED THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL IF YOU'RE MANAGING
A STORE WITH TWENTY EMPLOYEES
IT WOULDN'T CAPTURE THE PERSON
WORKING THE COUNTER FOR THE
PERSON- PUSHING A BROOM OR WHAT
SECURITY HOWEVER HERE IN
BEIJING A STOREFRONT ACCOUNTS
TWO OR THREE PEOPLE WHO IS THE
OWNER THE OPERATOR. OF THE
SHAREHOLDERS THE PERSON WITH
THE WITH THE FINANCIAL INTEREST
THERE ARE DEFINITIONS THAT WILL
PROTECT SMALL DRIVES. ARE BEING
CAUGHT UP IN. SIX OF THE TO
PEOPLE FOR. CAROUSEL OUR GOAL
IS TO SEE MORE LEGAL STORES
OPEN SO THAT THE CONSUMERS AND
GO WHERE THAT. PRODUCT IS SAFE
CONVENIENT. AND COMPETITIVELY
PRICED THEM STILL DOESN'T GET
TO THAT GOAL IT ONLY SEEKS TO
CREATE A CUDDLE AND WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF ALSO
REIMBURSING AND CRIMINAL
CHARGES FOR AGENCIES TO GO
AFTER SUPPORTERS. ORDINAL ROSE
FROM UNDERSTANDING THE FOURTH
FACTOR THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
CONSIDER IS WHETHER THE
PERSON'S CONTACT WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR IN
FURTHERING THE UNLICENSED
CANNABIS SECTOR ACTIVITY SO
THEN IF YOU HAVE A REALLY
SMALL. FOR PERSON OPERATION AND
TWO OF THEM ARE JUST REGULAR
EMPLOYEES. VERSUS A TWENTY FIVE
PERSON OPERATION AND TWENTY
THREE PEOPLE ARE JUST REGULAR
EMPLOYEES. IS THE IS THE
CONCERN OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
THAT THAT MAY GET THE CITY
ATTORNEY- EVIDENCE THAT THEY
WERE VERY HALF OF THE EMPLOYEES
SAID THEY WOULD BECOME. THEY
WOULD SIGNIFICANT FURTHER THE
ON LICENSING- CANVAS ACTIVITY
VERSUS THE PERSON WORKS FOR A
BIGGER FIRM WOULDN'T BE.
CAPTURED IS TAT BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECTABLE LIGHTING.
IT'S THE I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE WHAT THE THIRD. YES
MISS PARKER'S RESPONSE. DON'T
OF THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO AND
ANY ACTIVE SHOOTER OKAY SO YOU
AS WELL. THERE'S NO DEFINITION
THE BILL ON THE SIDE THE
OPERATION ON THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY TRADERS. SO I THINK A LOT
OF GOING DOWN TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
SIMPLY ARE ARE WORKING IN A
STORE THAT THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
KNOW WHICH PHONE LICENSE BUT
THEY'RE STILL- WHICH ROOM FOR.
FORD BECAUSE WE'LL BE USING
EXACTLY THE POINT OF THE
BUILDERS TO INCENTIVIZE MORE.
PUNISHMENT INCENTIVIZE MORE
ENFORCEMENT BY MAKING THE
FLYING SIZEABLE AND PROVIDING
FOR REIMBURSEMENT TO THE- THAT
BRINGS THE ACTION. SO THAT IS
THE PURPOSE IS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ENFORCEMENT AND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT IT WILL GET EVEN
SMALL OPERATORS ARE SMALL- LOW
INCOME PEOPLE COLOR MIDDLE
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. IT
CANNOT BE EDUCATED AND IT'S NOT
THE MAIN PURPOSE OF THE GOAL
BUT THE BILL IS WRITTEN HOUSE
ADDRESS. I'M SORRY THANK YOU
SEMI KELSEY'S AT RESPOND YOUR
QUESTIONS YEAH I'M RIGHT. MR
I'M STILL A LITTLE NERVOUS I
THINK I'M GOING TO. FIVE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I AM I
WAS IN. A SORT OF HANG ON THAT
ARE ON THE FENCE BUT I THINK-
I'LL DO SOME MORE STUDY OF THIS
BUT I THINK THEY'LL GIVE THE
AUTHOR. A CHANCE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE NEXT LEVEL. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS CONCERNS
OF WAS OUR MOTION IS THERE A
MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR CAFIERO
DO YOU CARE TO CLOSE- IN BEFORE
YOU CLOSE THE SEVEN MEMBER
RUBIO- YOU HAVE BEEN- QUITE
DILIGENT IN. YOUR EFFORTS ON
THIS BILL AND AS YOU CAN SEE
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN SEE
YOU'VE COME A LONG WAY OF THE
BILLS COME A LONG WAY SINCE IT
FIRST ARRIVED THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THE BILL AS WELL
AS TO YOUR- FLEXIBILITY TO
ACCOMMODATE THE CONCERNS OF
VARIOUS STAKE HOLDERS ALL RIGHT
YOU CAN CLOSE THANK YOU KNOW I
JUST APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
FROM THE CONVERSATION. AND THE
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT THE
INTENT OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD LIKE
TO INCREASE AND I CANNOT TELL
YOU HOW MANY AGENCIES I GOT
CALLS FROM. OUR STORE THAT SAID
HE HELP US GET MORE MORE
LICENSES AND UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AT A- I GOT
SEPARATED- BILL OR A PACKAGE OF
BILLS BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF CHALLENGES WITHIN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND THE- THE
LACK OF. LICENSES FOR FOLKS
THAT ARE WILLING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING- IS NOT AVAILABLE
AND I WISH WE COULD ADDRESS
THAT WITH THIS BUT WE CAN'T
HELP WITH THE OTHER CONCERN
THAT I HAD THE MAJOR CONCERN
WAS THAT. SOME OF THIS ILLEGAL
OF FACILITIES ARE PROVIDING TO
THE SAME BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
THEY'RE PROVIDING CANNABIS THAT
HAS NOT BEEN TESTED BY THE
STATE. THEREFORE PUTTING HIM IN
DANGER OF YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS
WHAT IS IN THOSE- WHEN THEY
SELL THOUGH THAT THAT TOP
PRODUCT. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE CALL CERN'S FROM. FROM THE
OPPOSITION. BUT THAT'S WHY I
WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNEW THAT MY INTENT IS NOT
TO PENALIZE BUT TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS AND ALSO. DO THE MAKE
OME HEADWAY SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE TO THE BUT TO MOVE FORWARD
AND REALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES
OF MORE LICENSES. AND EQUITY
WITHIN THOSE LICENSES SO AGAIN
I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR. FOR GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
WORK THROUGH THESE ISSUES AND
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS. YOU KNOW I CAN
I'VE DONE ALL THAT I COULD- TO
MAKE SURE THAT I ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE IS FAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE. THAT I'M NOT
GETTING NO MATTER WHAT I DO-
THE FACT IS THAT THE BILL IS
NOT WHAT THE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WANTS AND I
APPRECIATE. THEIR ADVOCACY BUT
AT THIS POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE. REALLY BEING HURT BYE
BYE THE LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
QUOTE FOR YOU. THANK YOU
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLE THERE WAS A MOTION BY
SENATOR COVERING IT UP SENATE
CAREER YES. ABC AT THIS IS A B.
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BY A FAMILY
MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
AT THE MOTION IS THE MOTION WAS
MADE BY SEND A COPY OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS.
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AMBER HI. AMBER GUY
BURGESS. ZERO ZERO I DID I SAW.
THAT I THOUGHT I'D GONE SILAS.
BRONSON LISTED BY HERTZ BERG.
HER BY JOE. JONES I LAYERED.
LAYERED I STERN STERN HIGHWAY
CASKEY WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WINNER. WINNER HI THEY HAVE TEN
TO ZERO WITH A MEMBER MISSING
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL- NEXT IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
STONE HERE AS WELL- AFTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE IS UP AND
HE WILL BE OUR LAST AUTHOR OF
THE DAY. THANK YOU. ABC
THIRTEEN OH FOUR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SO MEMBER SANTIAGO- YES
THINKING IT'S CURTAINS- IN THE
INTEREST OF THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME I WILL TELL DOWN MY FIVE
MINUTE SPEECH. TO A COUPLE OF
SENTENCES THAT TO GET A CHAIR.
I'VE HEARD IT BACK HERE. THEN
HAVING SAID THAT- EIGHTY
THIRTEEN- FORMER CLARIFIED THE
OBLIGATION OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
GOT THEIR- AFFIRMATIVE RELIEF-
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING AND ALL
COMMUNITY FIRE L. HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT RELATED
ACTIVITIES AND MISTER CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BUT
WE HAVE A- WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
WHO WILL HOPEFULLY BE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- AND-
LET'S SEE- UNDRESSED ROMMEL'S
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH BIG PICTURE- GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS FROM OFFICE TO FINALLY
HAVE PUBLIC ADVOCATE- THIS BILL
BUILDS UPON THE B. SIX EIGHTY
SIX WHICH WAS A FAIR HOUSING
BILL ENACTED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- THAT REQUIRES PUBLIC
ENTITIES. CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING IN THEIR ACTIONS
RELATING TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- THAT KFH
OBLIGATIONS IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT DECISIONS ARE
UNDERTAKEN IN A MANNER THAT
DISMANTLES PATTERNS OF
SEGREGATION BUT AT THE STORE
CLEAN DENIED MEANINGFUL HOUSING
CHOICE TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES- THE
OBLIGATION IS IMPLEMENTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. IN PART
THROUGH A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HOUSING ELEMENT FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCY IDENTIFIED THE
JURISDICTIONS FAIR HOUSING
ISSUES. AND PRIORITIES AND THEN
LAYS OUT ITS STRATEGIES AND
ACTIONS TO IMPLEMENT WAS PRIOR
TO. THE ENACTMENT OF EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
WE HAVE FOUND SEVERAL PLACES
WHERE HE LAWN NEEDS
CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE THAT
THAT EVEN COUNTIES ARE
MEANINGFULLY IMPLEMENTING AND-
FFH OBLIGATION NUMBERS
CONCERTINO. POUR WILL PROVIDE A
CLEAR CASE. FOR EXAMPLE THIS
WOULD. THAT LOCALLY TO YOUR WE
NEED TO LOOK HER HOME SHOOTING
THEIR TRYST THROUGH JOSE LOCAL.
AND LET. ABOUT ME OR CLERK.
IT'S BEEN A WILLIS LOCAL SHOULD.
OUT THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER-
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX. AND
THEREBY EXPAND FOR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR THESE
REASONS WE AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR ROSS- OTHERS IN SUPPORTING
THE GALLERY SEEING NON ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. BUT IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THREE ZERO FOUR. WE WOULD ALL
BE VERY GRATEFUL. DO YOU LIKE
TO COME IN SUPPORT OF A. B. ONE
THREE ZERO OR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
OFFICE TO GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON A LAWLER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT AND HELPING CALIFORNIA
ALL TRANSPORT. THANK YOU. GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
MEMBERS YOU CAN SEE ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR
AND OUR DRIVER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SOMEONE ELSE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR SCOTT
OPPOSITION I KNOW NOPE. OP NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WHEN THIS IS
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM. ONE
TWELVE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY-
LET'S GO THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE UP. THOSE
IF ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
ONE THREE ZERO FOUR. I FEEL
LIKE A COMMON OPPOSITION OF A.
B. ONE THREE ZERO OR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME.
EDITOR'S NOTE WINNING QUEUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S BRING
BACK THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
MICROPHONES RAISED- CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT- SALOON OR SANTIAGO WOULD
YOU CARE TO CLOSE AFTER THAT
OPENING. THAT WAS A PRETTY HIGH
BAR SO. I HEAR MY CUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT BEN
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL. YES THIS IS A B.
THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AMBERG HI AMBER
I PURCHASE. A VEHICLE. I DID
ASAL THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG.
HERTZBERG I'D JONES JONES NO
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN STERN I
WAKE HOUSE SKI MY CASSIE I
WINNER WINNER HI YOU HAVE ONE
TOOTH OR- NINETY ONE SO FAR
WITH A MEMBER MISSING. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT ON CALL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN
TO FILE AND NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE THIS IS
THE LAST AUTHOR. SENT TODAY-
THANK YOU SSEMBLYMEMBER STONE
AND I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
BILL THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE IT
FAIR AND MEASURED- TAKING MA'AM
IT'S BOTH FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND IN THE COMMITTED TODAY TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS THE CALIFORNIA-BANKERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS. THEY ARE STILL BOTH
IN OPPOSITION BUT I KNOW YOU
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO SEE IF YOU
CAN'T RESOLVE SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AT LEAST. AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONVERSATIONS
ARE CONTINUING I SUPPOSE I WANT
TO CONFIRM THAT AND THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS YES WE ARE IN
FACT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT I'M ACCEPTING TODAY THANK
YOU THANKS FOR THE- THE GOOD
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL. ARE IN
FURTHERANCE OF TRYING TO WORK
WITH THE ISSUES. SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES WHAT WHAT HAPPENS
WITH A LOT OF THIS IS ONLY. FOR
PRIVATE SCHOOL STUDENT LOANS.
MOST THESE. THESE WHO TAKE
THESE LONG IN THEN IF THEY HAVE
RUN INTO. WITH THE LOAN. WE'LL
GET A NOTICE OR MAY EVEN A CASE
AGAINST HIM IN COURT. N. OR
MOSTLY. NOT EVEN REPRESENT BY
pKEN. AND WHAT HAVE IS THEY'LL
MISS. OR NOT UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
INTO COURT DOCUMENTS. IN THE
SERVICES OF THESE LOANS AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT AND IT'S LIKE A- LIKE A
MIDDLE OF THE DAY JUST RUN
THROUGH THESE LAWSUITS. THAT'S
A LOT OF DEFAULT JUDGMENTS THAT
GET ENTERED IN AND ONE THAT IT
FILTERS AND GET CENTERED. AND
DEFECTS IN WHAT LED TO THAT
JUDGMENT OR NOT EXPLORE UNLESS
AN ATTORNEY IS HIRED AND
THERE'S A LOT OF PROCESS TO GO
THROUGH SO ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR
IN THIS BILL REALLY. IS
INCREASING THE EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD SO THAT IN THESE CASES
ARE PRIVATE STUDENT LOANS IF
THEY WANT TO BRING A CASE
AGAINST. A BAR WHERE THEY HAVE
TO PROVE AND SHOW THAT THEY OWN
THE LOAN. THAT THEY PROVIDE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
DOCUMENTATION. TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH THAT FOR THE QUARTER
BEFORE THE COURT ENTERS A FULL
TOUCH MEANT. THAT IT IS THE
PROPER. ACTION AND WHAT SOME OF
THE ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING THIS HAVE FOUND. WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES TO THEM AND SAYS
I'M IN REAL TROUBLE NOW. AND I
NEED YOUR HELP IS THEY WILL
FIND SIGNIFICANT DEFECTS IN THE
ORIGINAL FILINGS. AND
OFTENTIMES THE SERVICER OR THE
PARTY WITH A DEFAULT JUDGMENT
CAN'T EVEN ESTABLISH THAT THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT. TO GET THAT
DEFAULT JUDGMENT THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THESE ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES ALL WE'RE DOING. IS
ENSURING THAT THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
DOCUMENTATION AND EVIDENCE
BEING BROUGHT TO THE COURT. IF
THAT KIND OF A PROCESS IS GOING
TO BE ENTERED INTO. THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COLLECTORS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THE BANKERS BECAUSE
WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO. IS
TO. PREJUDICE LEGITIMATE
COLLECTION ACTIONS BUT WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
PROCESS AROUND. THESE PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN IN THE COLLECTION
ACTIONS THAT HAPPEN. THAT WE
CAN PROTECT THOSE CONSUMERS.
AND THAT THE JUDGMENTS THAT
HAPPEN OR THE CORRECT
JUDGEMENTS THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT YES WE'RE
WORKING. WITH THE OPPOSITION
WE'VE GOT WE'RE TRYING TO. HOME
TO SOME SOME OF THE BIT BETTER
AGREEMENT I THINK WERE MOSTLY
THERE WAS SOME OF THESE SO.
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
WE OFFER ABSOLUTELY CAN. KEEP
TALKING TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
SOME OF THESE EVENTS. IT N. TO
BE ABLE TO SATISFY SOME OF THE
CONCERNS HERE SO THAT THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS CAN GO
FORWARD AND THE THIS SORT OF
FACTORY OF LAWSUITS REALLY GETS
ADDRESSED IN A MORE APPROPRIATE
WAY. SO WITH ME I HAVE MY
COMPUTER FROM THE STUDENT
BORROWER PROTECTION CENTER AND
CARAMEL GREW FROM THE LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND THEY
REALLY DESCRIBE THE LANDSCAPE
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH VERY
WELL. AND THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER STONE-
MR PEERS SO YOU BILLABLE. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST THE BY DAY
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN A REALLY
LONG AFTERNOON FOR EVERYBODY
SO- YOU NEED TO KEEP. MOVING I
CERTAINLY WON'T PRESCRIBE BUILT
UP AGAIN TODAY I THINK THAT
JUST DON'T GET THE GREAT JOB-
BUT- THANK YOU SHARE THANK YOU
BYE. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS MIKE
PIERCE ON THE POLICY RECORD
STUDENTS ARE PROTECTED THERE.
WERE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
COMMITTED TO ENDING THE STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS- AND WE'RE ALSO
SPONSORING A SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR. I DO
WANT TO GIVE A- SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE ABOUT WHY EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR IS NECESSARY.
BEFORE I CO FOUNDED THE STUDENT
BAR PROTECTION CENTER I SPENT
SEVEN YEARS AS AN ATTORNEY AT
THE FEDERAL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. WE BROUGHT
IN FORCE NOW ACTUALLY GET THE
BIGGEST ABUSER OF CALIFORNIA
COURTS. THE NATIONAL COLLEGIATE
STUDENT LOAN TRUSTS. NPSL P.
ALONG WITH BIG OUT OF STATE
NONBANK CREDITORS LIKE NAPPING
IN. A FILE THOUSANDS OF
WASHINGTON. CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS. THE LANDMARK
LAW AGAIN ANTI. P. THE BUREAU
FOUND THE TRUCK. FULL
AFFIDAVITS AND THE COURT. AND
WHACKED OUT. TO BACK UP THE
DEBT DOWN CASES. THE LAWSUIT
MILK BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO ACT.
BY RECENT RESEARCH BY OUR
PARTNERS AT THE UC IRVINE
CONSUMER LAW CONNECTIONS IN
ACTIONS BROUGHT BY NCLT. AND
ITS PEERS FULLY 90% OF CASES-
IF. 90% OF CASES. FARMERS LACK
LEGAL COUNSEL. THESE TWO WHICH
ISN'T. THE LACK OF THE OKAY.
AND YOU USED TO HELP COURTS
CREATE AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
BORROWERS. TOO MANY YOU CAN
DISCOVER AFTER THE FACT THAT
THE REGIONAL PARTNERS FOR DEATH
THE GREETER AND DOCUMENTED READ
OUT. I UNDERSTAND THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION HERE
TODAY- JUST AS THAT YOU NOTED
MISTER CHAIR. DON'T KNOW THAT.
YOU'RE NOT POSITION BUT I ALSO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE'RE
ENGAGED IN A CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CORRECTED DISCUSSIONS.
ALONG WITH OUR CONVERSATION
WITH THE COLLECTORS AFTER THAT
AND I WANT TO CONCLUDE BY
EMPHASIZING THAT THE MAJOR
DRIVERS OF THE PIECES ARE NOT
CALIFORNIA BANKS AND THEY'RE
NOT CALIFORNIA CREDIT. I
THOUGHT HE WAS NOT BACK AT ALL
BUT THE LOAN STOCKED INTO THESE
TRUCKS WERE MADE BY THE BIGGEST
BANKS IN THE WORLD. ORGAN CHASE
BANK OF AMERICA AND YOU EXPECT.
THE BANK MADE SUBPRIME STUDENT
LOANS WERE PASSED ON TO
INVESTORS BARBER STRUGGLE TO
REPAY IN DECADES LATER THESE
CASES CONTINUE TO CLOG
CALIFORNIA COURTS AND HURT
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE BOXES FOR
ME I A LEGACY OF PREDATORY
LENDING BY OUT OF STATE AND
NATIONAL BANKS FORTUNATELY
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR AND THE
TWO PIECES JUST AS MR
SOUNDTRACKED WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL ORDERED AN
ITEM ON EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LONG LOAN
BORROWERS CANNOT AFFORD THANK.
YOU MISS PEARCE IF YOU COULD
WRAP IT UP. I'M SORRY I'M ABOUT.
IF YOU COULD WRAP IT UP. HE
THOUGHT OKAY THANK YOU. MISS
MCGRAW. HI MY NAME IS PARAM
ACROSS AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
THE LEGAL AID FOUNDATION OF
WALKING IN JULY OUR OFFICE HAS
BEEN REPRESENTING BORROWERS AND
PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN COLLECTION
ACTION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND HANDLE CASES
INVOLVING PLAINTIFFS INCLUDING
SECURITIZED LOAN PRODUCTS LIKE
THE NATIONAL COLLEGIATE AND NOT
IN THE LONG SHOT THAT FIRES AND
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
GUARANTEE PAYMENT ON PEOPLE
WELCOME THE COLLECTION OF
BEAUTIFULLY AT THE INTERCOM TO
CROSS THE PICKET LINES AT.
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR WHAT
WILL PREVENT PRIVATE STUDENT
LOAN HOLDERS MISUSING THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS BY FILING TAX
COLLECTION OFFICE WHEN THEY
LACK THE MOST BASIC EVIDENCE
NECESSARY TO MAKE A PAYMENT
FEATURE CASE FOR BREACH OF
WRITTEN CONTRACT I'M HERE'S ONE
STORY TO ILLUSTRATE THE HARM
BUT IF YOU COULD WALK BECAUSE
AND THAT EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR WOULD PREVENT I WE CAN'T
NAME TO PRESERVE
CONFIDENTIALITY. ALREADY THE
PEOPLE MOTHERS ACCORDING TO
CHILDREN. WITH A LOW WAGE JOB.
HE AT THE FRONT. OF THIRTY
THREE FIVE DOLLARS AND YOUR
AGAIN AFTER FOR A PRICE STUDENT
WHEN HE OBTAINED A KIND NOT WHO
UNIVERSE INTO THE- SEVEN EVEN
THOUGH THE- LACK OF. THAT IT
ONLY HAD A THE CALL I ON THE
WELL. OVER IN OUR BECAUSE HER
EMPLOYER HAD BEEN GARNISHING
25% OF THEIR DISPOSABLE PAPER
OVER TWO YEARS AS A RESULT HE
WAS STRUGGLING TO PAY. FOR
BASIC LIVING EXPENSES WE
DISCOVERED THAT HER EMPLOYER
HAD A FIGHTING INCORRECT
FORMULA AND ILLEGALLY CURRENT
OVER NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WELL WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
REFUNDED AND STOP YOUR
GARNISHMENT. SO WE JUST NEED TO
BE GARNISHED IN BECAUSE YOUR
PAYMENTS AREN'T LIKELY TO COVER
THE ANNUAL INTEREST AS IT
ACCRUES. THE DOT WILL GROW OVER
HER LIFETIME SHE CANNO RESTART
THE DECK WITH A SAFETY HAD A
BANKRUPTCY. EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR IT'S CRUCIAL TO ENSURING
THAT LOW INCOME BORROWERS. WHO
ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTAION DO NOT GET THE
RIGHT KIND OF WAGE GARNISHMENT.
HE FELT THAT. THAT. THEY DO NOT
LEGALLY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. ALL RIGHT- OTHER IN
SUPPORT I SEEN WANT TO GO. NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. OTHERS
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. FOUR TWO FOUR. HE LED THE
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FOUR
TO FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE OF
ZERO. FIRST TO GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY MATERIAL WE HAVE
EXPOSED. CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER OF AB FOUR TWO FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MEXICO
CLIMBED TO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHUCK BELL FROM
ADVOCACY DIVISION FOR CONSUMER
REPORTS- SPONSOR AND WE URGE
IPHONE FOR A. B. FOR TWENTY
FOUR TO PROVIDE COMMON SENSE
EVIDENTIARY PROTECTIONS FOR
DATA INTO COLLECTIONS. THANK
YOU NEXT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY SAMANTHA THING WITH
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE
OF MAYOR LONDON BREED IN PART
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LIVE TO
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSE OF
PARKED EVERYWHERE SINCE
INTERNAL PARTY ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MISSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MIX OF THE TWO LINE
TWO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ON MY
NAME IS JASIM PRASAD ON BEHALF
OF THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND WE ARE IN HI THE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. 32% HELLO
CLIENT TWO SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DANIELLA RODRIGUEZ. CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR TO
FOUR. AN EXCELLENT ALIGNED TO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS KIRTI CANADIAN CALLING
REPRESENTATION OF OUR STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS AND THEIR TWO
MILLION SUPPORTERS ACROSS
COUNTRY LENDING STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A. B. FORTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE TIP LINE
TWO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. UNDER A. I MEAN. FOR
THANK YOU. I JUST FEEL FREE. BY
THE TIME THE SOMEONE CALLS IN
QUEUE. LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION MR CLIFF BURGER YOU
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN CLOSE BERG HERE WITH
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS WE
ARE OPPOSED AB FOUR TO FOUR AT
THIS POINT- TWO MAJOR AREAS OF
CONCERN THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION- EIGHTY FOUR TO FOUR
IS REALLY ONE OF THREE BILLS
THIS YEAR. THAT SEEK TO EXTEND
PROVISIONS OF THE FAIR DEBT
BUYERS ACT- TO COLLECTION
AGENCIES AND YOUR CREDITORS-
THAT ACT PROVIDES A UNIFORM
REGULATORY SCHEME OF
DOCUMENTATION NOTICE FOR DEBT
BUYERS- EXTENDING INTO DEBT
COLLECTORS IT IS CERTAINLY-
DOABLE AND- WE'RE NOT OPPOSED
TO DOING THAT HOWEVER WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT BILLS ONE
STUDENT DEBT HERE ONE ON
MEDICAL DEBT BY- SOMEONE WHO'D
FRIEDMAN. AND OTHER BILLING
GENERAL CONSUMER DEBT ACROSS
THE BOARD THE SENATE BILL WENT
THROUGH THIS COMEDIAN IS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I BELIEVE WAS UP THIS
MORNING- YEAH WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK OUT ALL THOSE CONCERNS
WITH THE OTHER TWO BILLS WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS WE WOULD LIKE
IT TO GET IT STANDARDIZED
NOTICE AND DOCUMENTATION AS
POSSIBLE RATHER THAN HAVING.
CONFLICTING REGULATORY SCHEMES
US DOCUMENTATION AND NOTICE WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS WITH MR
STONE WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH
HIS STAFF AND THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. WE. THINK IT IS
THAT THAT IS DOABLE. ASSUR TRY
TO GET THE STANDARD THESE KINDS
OF DOCUMENTS THREE REQUIREMENTS
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
CONCERN THAT I WANT TO BRING TO
THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION IS
THE- PENALTY PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT A
PROVISION THAT HAS A PER
VIOLATION- STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD- GENERALLY WAS
REQUIRED ABILITY IT'S PER
ACTION. AND THIS BILL IS
EXTENDING AN EXCELLENT
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS FROM
THE WINDOW BUILDING CERTIFIERS
ACT- THAT WAS PER ACTION NOT
PER VIOLATION I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION ALSO
THAT. THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR SB
NINE AWAIT JUST ABOLITION IS
ALL LICENSING OF DEBT BUYERS
DEBT COLLECTORS AND- COLLECTION
ATTORNEYS BY THE NEW DEPARTMENT
OF THE FBI WHICH PROVIDES A
GREATER FORCE MAGNETIC
MECHANISM WHAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD
IS. THAT THERE ARE BAD ACTORS
OUT THERE AND NONE OF WHOM ARE
MEMBERS WHO NEED INSURANCE TERM
BAD ACTIVITY I THINK IF THE
AUTHOR IN HIS STAFF LOOKS AT
THE- NEW LICENSING LAW IN THE
IN THE POWERS THAT HAVE BEEN
GIVEN TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THERE'S REALLY A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD PATH TO GETTING
THE BAD ACTORS WHICH IS TAKING
AWAY THEIR LICENSE FOR A DEBT
COLLECTION IN CALIFORNIA SO
ANYWAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR CONCERNS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. AND
HIS STAFF ON THE SPONSORED ON
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BERG ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP.
THE COMMON OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. FIRST WE
GET TO LINE TWO EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AFTERNOON-
MATURE NUMBERS IT'S EXTREMELY
HOT FROM THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
PENALTY PROVISION IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
TWO MORE JUST ONE MOMENT. CEMEX
ARE GONNA GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
I HAVE MISTER CHAIR YOUR
COMMENTS WERE ACCURATE WHILE WE
DO FIND EACH JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
AMENDMENT HELPFUL WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE AND
YOU'RE CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROPONENTS ARE CONCERNED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE
TO LINE TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
SENATOR ROB WILSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
SPONSORS AND STAFF FOR THE
CONVERSATION LOOK FOR THEM ON
GOING BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE MADE
A POST ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT- SEE
NO ONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO
COMMENT. ADULT CENTER WACO SKI
YES THERE WERE KELSEY. MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD MAKE THE ARGUMENT
THAT THIS BILL IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT THE STANDARD OF PROOF. FOR
THE EVIDENCE FREE PROOF MUST BE
HIGHER WHEN AS- PLAYERS GO INTO
CALIFORNIA COURTS TO GET
JUDGMENTS AGAINST CALIFORNIANS
TO COLLECT ON THE DEBT. AND I
WOULD ARGUE THAT ANY DEFECT IN
THE PLEADINGS ARE SOME I OR T.
THAT'S NOT CROSS SHOULD. SHOULD
R. STAHL THE JUDGMENT AGAINST
CREEK CALIFORNIA DEBTORS AND
THE REASON IS AND SHE IT'S
ILLOGICAL BUT- BUT THE FEDERAL
LAW MAKES A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
STUDENT AT AND ALL OTHER DEBT.
AND IT'S A FREAK OF OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM THAT THAT HAPPENS BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE. PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT WAS THIS
CHARGEABLE IN BANKRUPTCY SO
THERE WAS A BALANCE THAT WENT
ON BETWEEN THE AGGRESSIVE.
COLLECTION IN A DEBTOR'S
ABILITY TO PLAY AND BY SOME BAD
TOOTH. STROKE OF LUCK NOW
STUDENT PRIVATE STUDENT LOANS
IS NOT THIS CHARGE WILL END IN
BANKRUPTCY COURT BUT A MEDICAL
DEBT IS A CREDIT CARD DEBT IS
AND ALL THESE OTHER TICKETS TO
WIN SO WHEN THE ACTIVITIES
GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA COURTS
TO COLLECT THESE DEBTS AGAINST.
OUR CONSUMERS WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THE RISING COSTS OF STUDENT
LOANS BUT THEY THEY HAVE NO
OTHER BACKDROP EXCEPT FOR THIS
LONG FOR THIS VERSION OF AB OF
FOUR TO FOUR TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING IS CORRECT BECAUSE
THAT. IS NOT LIKE THE OTHER DID
YOU HAVE IT FOREVER SO I THINK
WE HAVE A DUTY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS EVIDENCE YOU STAND
THERE IS HI IT'S HIS. IS IT
COULD BE N. N. IT'S CAREFULLY
CRAFTED NIGHT APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT NOW
MOVED TO FILL. ALL RIGHTY THANK
YOU SIR WHAT KOWSKI ANYONE ELSE
I SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES
RAZOR WHAT COUNTS HE HAS MOVED
THE BILL- SOME REMEMBER STONE
KNOWLEDGE CENTER WHITE HOUSE
GIVES DONE YOUR CLOTHES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COMMENT FURTHER. I
ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- ALL RIGHT. THEN SHE
CAN ALSO IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A B. FOR TWENTY
FOUR BY A FAMILY MEMBERS DOWN
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR RIGHT
HOUSE GIVE THE MOTION IS DEEP
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AMBER HI AMBER GOODBYE BOARD
YES. ZERO ZERO I DID AWESOME
THE RUSSELL I'D GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG.
HERTZBERG HYATT JONES LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN STERN I WAKE
HOUSE SKI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER WINNER I YOU HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
THAT ONE MEMBER MISSING. SORRY
LET ME GO BACK. BARGES. JONES
JONES NO- SO YOU HAVE A NINETY
ONE WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL-
WE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THIS PHONE
HAS TWO MORE MEASURES AND THEY
WERE GONNA LIFT ALL THE CALLS
SO THEN THEY SHOULD NOT BE
PARTICULARLY LONG SO. ALL RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR- NEXT IS A B. ONE
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT- THE AUTHOR IS
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. BUT IT
IS SIMPLY. SENATORS EVERY YEAR
WE DO A JUDICIARY CIVIL ALL OF
US BILL THIS IS THAT BILL
VANCOUVER CONTROVERSIALITEMS
CLEAN UP IS WHAT IT PRIMARILY
IS IT'S A LITTLE BIGGER THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF COATED. AND WE
TRY TO COMBINE ALL OF THESE
TYPES OF THINGS BUT AGAIN NO
OPPOSITION NOTHING IN HERE
CONTROVERSIAL PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD I ASK FOR YOUR
ITEMS ALL RIGHT- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THEY WITNESSES
SUPPORT- THE WE DO HAVE STEVE
CALLING ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT- I DON'T THINK WE
NEED FOR THE WITNESSES FOR ****
ALL RIGHT WELL. JUST BECAUSE
I'VE BECOME USED TO THIS I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY NO IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. OTHERS ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT. IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
AND SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S NO PRINCIPAL
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MAR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. WHO'S IN
OPPOSITION TO THE OMNIBUS BILL.
BY THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OF
THE ASSEMBLY. IF YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE POSED SEMI COLONS
VERSUS COLONS SO. ALL RIGHT-
CENTER LAYERED MOVES THE BILL
ALL RIGHT A MAN IN. G. ANY
COMMENTS NO COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
MADAM SHE COUNTS OF YOU CALL
THE ROLL. HELLO YOU WANNA CLOSE.
S. FOR LABOR ALL RIGHT THERE WE
GO. THIS IS A THIS IS A HEAVY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT TO FIVE
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR LEHRER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI. AMBER I'M FORGES. I
DON'T. HAVE YOU KNOW I DID I
SO. DID I SO I. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HEARD BURKE HURTS
BURGER I JONES. JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN. STERN
I Y. CASKEY. WHAT HAS THE I.
WINNER. WINNER I YOU HAVE TEN
TO ZERO WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT CENTER BOARD
THIS IS ANOTHER COMMITTEE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ONE LAST
MEASURE THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO AG ARE TWELVE THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY ON CONSENT IS NO
LONGER ON CONSENT. SO REMEMBER
STONE YOU COULD PROCEED. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AND ENSURE TWELVE SO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MEXICANAS
TOOK SOME ACTION TO PROTECT THE
GI BILL. AND THEN. IT WAS VERY
WELL CONSIDERED AND IT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE STEP. BUT WHAT THEY
MISSED WAS THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE GI FUNDS FOR
EDUCATION ONLY GO TO ABA
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOLS. AND
WHAT THEY DID NOT REALIZE IS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY HIGH
STANDARD FOR CALIFORNIA
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOLS. IN FACT
A LOT OF CALIFORNIA CREDIT LAW
SCHOOLS THESE ARE NONPROFITS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE WERE VERY
VIABLE OPTIONS FOR. ATTORNEYS
IN AS WE HAVE IS BOTH OF OUR
COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY HARD. TO PROVIDE DIVERSITY
IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION AT THE
BENCH AT THE BAR. AND THROUGH
THE SCHOOLS THESE. CALIFORNIA
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOLS FILL
THAT FUNCTION AND THE BAR PASS
RATE IN MOST OF THE SCHOOLS IS
HIGHER THAN MANY. NATIONAL ABA
ACCREDITED SCHOOLS SO WE THINK
IT WAS A MISTAKE OR A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF THE QUALITY OF
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS. THAT LED TO THE
DECISION TO PRECLUDE THEIR
ABILITY TO HAVE THEIR STUDENTS.
BE FUNDED BY THE GI BILL SO
THIS RESOLUTION IS JUST SAYING
CONGRESS HEY. TAKE A LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY I UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
ACCREDITED. LAW SCHOOLS THESE
ARE NOT. THE DIPLOMA THESE ARE
NOT THESE FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT TAKE
PEOPLE'S MONEY PROVIDED
SUBSTANDARD EDUCATION. AND THEN
THEY CAN'T PASS THE BAR THE
CAMP PRACTICE THAT IS
COMPLETELY WRONG WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE LAW SCHOOLS THIS IS
JUST A NATURE ENCOURAGING
CONGRESS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SITUATION. AND THINK ABOUT
CHANGING WHAT THEY HAVE DONE SO
THAT CALIFORNIA'S HIGH QUALITY
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOLS CAN TAKE
IN STUDENTS WITH. WITH GI BILL
FUNDING. AND WITH THAT I HAVE
FOR MY ROOM. THANK YOU SO IN
MEMBER STONE- WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT IT WOULD DOESN'T
SUPPORT- I BELIEVE WITH A MIKE
OR I'M SORRY MITCHELL WINNING
IN SET THREE OF ONLINE. MR
WINICK. YEAH YES SIR MR HERE
THANK YOU MR STONE AND THE
SENATORS OFFERED TO LAST MINUTE
TIME WHAT IS THAT A VERY VERY
LONG DAY THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH I COME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A J. R. TWELVE APR TWELVE
URGES CONGRESS TO RESTORE GI
BILL EDUCATION BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA VETERANS AND THEIR
DEPENDENTS WHO WISH TO STUDY
LAW ONE OF THE TWENTY THREE
LOCATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOLS. MY NAME
IS MITCHEL WINNER CAN FOR THE
PAST SIXTEEN YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS
PRESIDENT AND DEAN OF MONTEREY
COLLEGE OF LAW A NONPROFIT
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOL THAT HAS SUCCESSFULLY
SERVED OUR LOCAL VETERANS UNDER
THE GI BILL FOR MORE TAN FORTY
YEARS I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A
J. R. TWELVE BECAUSE FOR
DECADES STATE ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS LIKE MINE ARE COLLEGE
OF LAW HAVE SUCCESSFULLY SERVE
VETERANS UNDER THE PROTECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT. THE STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION PALS AT
AND STATE OTHERS HAVE RECENTLY
ARGUED THAT CALIFORNIA VETERANS
WOULD NOW BE BETTER SERVED BY
REJECTING THE STATE PROTECTION
AND DENYING CALIFORNIA VETERANS
THEIR RIGHT TO USE THEIR EARNED
GI BENEFITS ON A CALIFORNIA LAW
SCHOOL OF THEIR CHOICE THIS
ARGUMENT IGNORES THESE DECADES
OF VETERANS SUCCESSFULLY
ATTENDING CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED
LAW SCHOOLS UNDER THE GI BILL
AND IN FACT- NEEDED THE
CONGRESSIONAL RECORD NOR THE
RECORD SUPPORTING H. A R.
TWELVE PROVIDES ANY EVIDENCE OF
COMPLAINTS FILED. BY VETERANS
USING THE GI BILL TO ATTEND A
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOL I WILL CONCLUDE BY
EMPHASIZING THAT IT IS
INCORRECT A. J. R. TWELVE
REPRESENTS AN EFFORT TO UNDO
THE GI BILL PROTECTION ACT
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED
LAW SCHOOLS AND AJ OUR SUPPORT
HR TWELVE SUPPORT EXPANDING THE
RIGHTS AND. PROTECTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA VETERANS I INCLUDING
SUCH. AND NOT ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOL. UNDER THE PROTECTIVE.
OF THE BILL PROTECTS ACT I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ARTICLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA VETERANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEAN NEXT SET. THREE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR
PROBLEM CONTACT BACK FOR TWO
POINTS AGAINST IN IRAQ IN THE
YEAR. TWO THOUSAND FIFTY
THOUSAND SEVENTY THOUSAND EIGHT
I'M REPRESENTING AMERICAN
LEGION DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CLEARLY THAT THE CARD IN A
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA SO SHE
SHOULD COME BACK FROM SERVICE
OFFICERS CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL-CHAPTERS IN VIETNAM VETERANS.
OF AMERICA. CALLING OUR A J. R.
KEL. WE FEEL THAT COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN SEARCHED PROPERLY BY THE
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS THEY'RE ALL OVER FORTY
YEARS OF SERVICE. TODAY TODAY
WE HAVE. YET TO FIND A SINGLE
ACTION THAT HAS BEEN NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY CAL. OFTENTIMES IN
VETERANS RETURN TO CALIFORNIA
AFTER THE CLAIM SERVICE. THEY
HAVE FAMILIES AND THEY HAVE TO
WORK FULL TIME JOBS. CHOOSE
FROM RURAL AREAS WITHOUT ACTIVE
NBA SCHOOLS. AND LOW. INCOME
VETERANS NEED THE FLEXIBILITY.
TO PROCEED AN AFFORDABLE AND-
J. ARE TWELVE SEEKS TO PROTECT
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS DEDUCTIONS
HAVE EARNED BY VIRTUE OF THEIR
SERVICE. I UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO PROTECT THE
ACTUAL AND COMPENSATORY FOR
PROFIT AND NOT FOR PROFIT
SCHOOL. HELD BY YOUR BEDROOM
WOULD NOT WORK. EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. I WILL AFTER
SUPPORT I WILL ON A JAIL. RT
THANK YOU MYSTERY- OTHERS A
SUPPORT THE GALLERY SEEING NON
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE
OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE THOSE
ON THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IF
YOU QUEUE THEM UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE. TWELVE THE
COMMENTS SUPPORT OF H. A. R.
TWELVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE THE
WINNING QUEUE ALL RIGHT I SEE
NO ONE NO PRINCE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- LOOK AT THE GALLERY
SAYING NONE SAYING NOT A ROOM
ONE TWELVE MATER IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE TO AJ ARE. TWELVE
YEAH MR SHERIFF I MAY HAVE A
MOMENT. SURE. THANK YOU SIR
AND- TO THE HONORABLE MEMBERS
AND YOUR STAFF I COME TO YOU
ABOUT ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
NUMBER TWELVE AND WISH TO
REGISTER THE STRONG OPPOSITION
OF MANY VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS
NEARLY TWENTY MORE THAN FORTY I
HAVE WORKED WITH CONGRESS TO
ACT TO PROTECT THE GI BILL ACT
WHICH ENSURES VETERANS HAVE
ACCESS TO EDUCATION RESPECTED
NATIONWIDE IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
I JOINED THE MARINE CORPS THE
STEP THAT LANDED ME A RECRUIT
DEPOT SAN DIEGO BENNETT CAMP
PENDLETON THE TRAINING WAS
EXPECTEDLY ARDUOUS BUT I GREW
FOND OF THE BEAUTY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. TODAY I SERVE AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED VETERANS
EDUCATION SUCCESS AND I LIVE IN
WORK IN VIRGINIA WITH MY FAMILY
IN AN ECONOMY THAT SWITCHES ON
A DIME THE MOBILITY OF PATRONS
AND OUR FAMILIES IS PARAMOUNT
THE PROTECTED YEAH THE LACK IN
ITS ENTIRETY ENSURES THAT THE
GI BILL BENEFITS LEAD TO A
DEGREE TO HAVE MOBILITY THE JOB
MARKET THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE MILITARY
FAMILIES WHO FREQUENTLY
RELOCATE ACROSS STATE LINES APR
TWELFTH IS A RESOLUTION TO
PROTECT THE LAW SCHOOLS OTHER
STATES U. S. UNACCREDITED IT IS
NOT A RESOLUTION TO PROTECT THE
INTERESTS OF THAT ORANGE. THESE
ARE NOT INSTITUTIONS ACCREDITED
BY A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
ACCREDITOR AND THEIR NUMBERS
TELL YOU THAT ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW OVER 25% HAVE BEEN PLACED
ON PROBATION THROUGH JULY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DUE TO A NON
COMPLIANT MINIMUM PASSAGE RATE
OR HAVE LOST ACCREDITATION
ENTIRELY NONE OF THE SCHOOLS
MET THE MINIMUM AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION PASS RATE OF
SEVENTY PART 35% THIS PAST
YEAR. AND ONE FINAL EXAMPLE THE
UNIVERSITY WEST LOS ANGELES
ACCORDING TO THE STATE PARK
PUBLISHED EXAM STATISTICS UW LA
AS THEY REPORTED BAR PASSAGE
RATE OF JUST 9% IS THIS THE
KIND OF QUALITY THAT WE EXPECT
FOR VETERANS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU STAND WITH
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS
NATIONWIDE NOT WITH THE LAW
SCHOOLS PROTECTING WHAT AGREE
DOT COM IS ONE OF THEIR OWN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU AND I
MISSPOKE OBVIOUSLY. THERE WAS
SOMEONE IN OPPOSITION I THINK
THE THAT MISTER HUBBARD. IT
THAT YES THERE ARE RIGHT THANK
YOU JUST TO IDENTIFY YOU SIDE
YOU ALL RIGHT OTHERS IT UP
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
KNOWN ROOM ONE TWELVE- ON THE
PHONE LINE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT I SEE
CENTER BARDS MICROPHONES RAISE
CENTER BOARD JUST. THANK YOU
CHAIR. I'D LIKE TO EXTEND-
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE- FOR AUTHORING A J. R.
TWELVE. I THINK THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT SPOKE A MOMENT AGO AND I
HAD OCCASION TO READ AN EMAIL
THAT HE SENT OUT- HAS BEEN VERY
SELECTIVE IN FRANKLY
DISINGENUOUS. ABOUT THE MOTIVES
IN REPRESENTATIONS ON THE VALUE
THE CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS HAVE TO OUR MILITARY
COMMUNITY. MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT FOLKS IN THE MILITARY.
FOUR OUT OF THE MILITARY I HAVE
TO RESIDE. IN PLACES WHERE
THERE MAY NOT BE AN ABA
ACCREDITED LAW SCHOOL. AND I
JUST TALK ABOUT MONTEREY OR
FRESNO OR A LOT OF THESE OTHER
PLACES ESPECIALLY RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE THAT LEGAL
EDUCATION CAN ONLY BE GOTTEN-
BY THE CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED-
ALL INSTITUTIONS IN THE AREA.
SO FOR THIS INDIVIDUAL AND
OTHERS TO CHALLENGE- WHETHER OR
NOT MILITARY FOLKS SHOULD BE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE OUR GI
BENEFITS TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL IN THESE CALIFORNIA
CREDITS- SCHOOLS. I THINK IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE LET'S TAKE-
SOME OF THE METRICS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED EARLIER 75% BAR
PASSAGE RATE WAS REPRESENTED AS
THE MINIMUM WELL WITH THIS
AUTHOR ON OR THIS OPPONENT
FAILED TO MENTION THAT'S ON A
TWO YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE. AND
EVEN SOME ABA ACCREDITED
SCHOOLS DON'T HIT THAT NUMBER.
AND SO I THINK THIS INDIVIDUAL
IS CATEGORIZING ALL CALIFORNIA
ACCREDITED SCHOOLS IN THE LAW
WHO IS A- LAW DEGREE DOT COM
SITUATION I THINK THAT'S WHAT
HE WAS SAYING. BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF FINE INSTITUTIONS
THAT PROVIDE A SERVICE TO FOLKS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE- HAVING GONE
INTO THE MILITARY OR RETIRED
FROM IT. AND IF ANYBODY CARES
ABOUT PROVIDING LEGAL EDUCATION
TO FOLKS IN- LESS POPULATED
AREAS- OF RURAL AREAS. THAN
THEY KNOW THE VALUE THAT THESE
THESE THESE SCHOOLS PROVIDE LET
THE INDIVIDUAL MAKE THE
DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO GO TO A SCHOOL THAT
WILL BE RECOGNIZED. IN ANOTHER
STATE BUT FOR THOSE THAT KNOW
THEY WANT TO PRACTICE AND LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT SHOULD BE
THEIR DECISION SO WE'RE
HONORING THE MILITARY IN THEIR
SERVICE- THROUGH THE GI BILL
AND THE FUNDING THAT GOES ALONG
WITH THAT. THESE INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITYAND- BE
ABLE TO WORK PURSUE THAT LEGAL
EDUCATION IN THEIR OWN RIGHT SO
I WAS FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY OUR
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS. WE'LL
LOOK UPON THE MERITS OF THE OF
THIS POSITION INTO CALIFORNIA
SERIOUSLY ON HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. OF THE SERVICE IN
THE EDUCATION IS PROVIDED SO
SIR BOARD JUST MOVES A BILL-
ALL RIGHT OTHER DISCUSSIONS A
SINGLE MICROPHONES RAISE- I I'M
SORRY SIR WE'RE JUST MOVE THE
RESOLUTION- MAN CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL- I'M
SORRY WOULD LIKE CLOSE. NOT TO
BELABOR THE POINT THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
LOOKING AT THE CORRESPONDENCE
THERE'S A REAL LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING THERE A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT. THE SCHOOLS THAT
FAIL TO GET A VISA CREDIT ATION
AND ASSUMING THAT THAT MEANS
THAT THEY BECOME CALIFORNIA
CREDITED NOT CASE AT ALL. THESE
ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE CHOOSING
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITATION NOT
FAILING AT ABA ACCREDITATION.
THERE'S A REAL DISCONNECT
THERE. THAT'S THE POINT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE. THESE ARE HIGH
QUALITY SCHOOLS MANY OF WHOM
HAVE A HIGHER BAR PASS RATE.
THAN SOME ABA ACCREDITED
SCHOOLS. IN OTHER STATES SO.
THERE'S A DISCONNECT AND A LACK
OF INFORMATION WE'RE TRYING TO
FILL IN THE LACK OF INFORMATION
WITH THIS RESOLUTION ON ADS FOR
YOUR ITEMS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER BOARD
JUST MANAGING COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL YES THIS IS
AN ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE. THE MOTION IS TO BE
ADOPTED. OUTSIDE MOTION BY
CENTER FOR JUST AND THE MOTION
IS TO BE ADOPTED UMBERG. AMBERG
BY BURGESS BURGESS HI BY THE
END OF. IT ALL I DID I SAW.
THAT I SAW I. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HURTS BERG. HURTS BERG I
JONES. JONES I LAYERED LAYERED
I STERN STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY Y.
CASKEY FIVE WINNER WINNER HI
YOU HAVE A LIVE IN TWO ZERO
WITH EVERYONE VOTING.
CONGRATULATIONS SEVEN MEMBERS
STONE THE FIRST MEASURE WITH
EVERYONE VOTING ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA NOW LIVE CALLS- BEFORE
THE CALLS I HAVE GOOD NEWS AND
BAD NEWS THE GOOD NEWS IS NEXT
TUESDAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
DINNER- PROVIDED THE BAD NEWS
IS WE'RE PROBABLY ALL GOING TO
BE HERE LONG ENOUGH TO EAT THAT
DINNER. SO ALL RIGHT- BANTAM
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD-
LIFT THE CALLS. SO IT MEASURES
OUT LEVEL ZERO. S. OKAY ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. UMBERG HI
NUMBER HI BY THE END OF.
ABIERTO I HURTS BERG HURTS BERG
I STERN. STERN I WINNER WINNER
HI THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO
EVERYONE VOTING ALL RIGHT
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
OKAY. GROWING UP FILE ITEM ONE
A. B. TWO SIXTY THREE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER ADAM- THAT-
AMBERG HI UMBERG I HAVE A
YELLOW. VIETTEL I. HURTS BERG
HERTZBERG BY STERN. STERN I
MEAN- WINNER HI THAT'S ELEVEN
TWO ZERO EVERYONE'S VOTED THAT
FILLS OUT. THE NEXT MEASURE IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
BOARD JEFF. YEAH FOR JUST NO.
GONZALEZ I'M SORRY HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG BY JONES JONES NO
STERN. STERNI BET NINETY TWO
WITH EVERYONE VOTING. THE BILLS
OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
THREE AB SIXTY SIX BY A FAMILY
MEMBER BURNER OR BACK WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI HURTS BERG
HURTS BERG HI JONES JONES I.
STERN. STORY I THAT'S ELEVEN
TWO ZERO WITH EVERYONE VOTING.
ELEVEN ELEVEN TWO ZERO WITH A
LITTLE SALT THANK YOU- THE NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO AB
FOUR EIGHTY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING BY BOARD JEFF. BRIDGES
NO PITTSBURGH PITTSBURGH HI
JONES JONES NO STERN STERN HI
YOU HAVE NINETY TWO WITH
EVERYONE VOTING BILLS OUT NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING BY BURGESS. PORTIS
NO HERTZBERG HERZBERG HI JONES
JONES NO STERN. STERN I BET
NINETY TWO WITH EVERYONE VOTING
FILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS FOR
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. FOUR
FIVE ZERO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONE SILAS. UMBERG HIGH. NUMBER
I BARGES BARGES HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG BY JONES JONES I.
STERN. STERN I THAT'S ELEVEN
TWO ZERO WITH EVERYONE VOTING
ROLLS OUT. FILE ITEM. TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. UMBERG HI
AM BERG HI PORGES OR JUST NO
JONES JONES NO. STERNSTERN BYE
BYE CASKEY WHITE HOUSE SKI HI.
THAT'S NINETY TWO WITH EVERYONE
VOTING BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. ONE
FOUR FOUR FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I BOARD YES.
PORGES HI JONES JONES NO STERN.
STERN I WINNER. WINNER HI THAT
TEN TO ONE EVERYONE VOTING
BILLS OUT THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. EIGHT ONE
FOUR BY A FAMILY MEMBER LIVING
WITH THAT SHARE VOTING HI
DEBBIE AT ALL. W. DON'T I DID I
SO DID I SO I. HERTZBERG
HERZBERG FIVE JONES. THIS IS
EIGHT FOURTEEN WHICH IS FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN. JONES. JONES NO
LAYERED LAYERED I WAKE HOUSE
SKI Y. CASKEY I THAT'S NINE TWO
TWO. FEDERAL CREDIT THANK YOU
THE NEXT ITEM IS- FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B. NINE
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN
THAT MOTION WAS BY SENATOR
PORGES. AND THE CHAIR VOTED
VOTING I HAVE YET- COMING AT
ALL I DID ALSO. THE REST SO I
HURTS BERG HERZBERG HI JONES
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED
HIGHWAY CASKEY Y. CASKEY HI
THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO EVERYONE
VOTED FILLS OUT NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. EIGHTY
FIVE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING HI.
ZERO W. AT ALL I DID ALSO DID
ASK THOUGH HI HERTZBERG
HERZBERG HI JONES. JONES NOT
VOTING LAYERED LAYERED HI
THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO EVERYONE'S
VOTED BILLS OUT THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR ITEM
TWENTY FOURS AB FOR TWELVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER ADDRESS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI GORGEOUS. OR
JUST NO ABIERTO CARRY IT OUT HI
HURTS BERG HURTS BERG HI JONES.
JONES KNOW THAT NINETY TWO WITH
EVERYONE VOTING. BILLS OUT THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO WITH
THAT CHAIR VOTING. HI BORDUAS
BRIDGES HI THAT'S ELEVEN TWO
ZERO EVERYONE VOTED BILLS OUT
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
GORGEOUS- JUST KNOW THAT NINETY
TWO WITH EVERYONE VOTING BILLS
OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS A. B. FOUR
TO FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE
CHAIR VOTING I BURGESS. PORTIS
NO THAT'S NINETY TWO AND
EVERYONE HAS VOTED THOSE OUT.
AND THE LAST ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY. WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI THIS IS EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT- BURGESS.
THAT'S OKAY THE OMNIBUS BILL M.
S. SENATOR JONES VOTED I IS
WELL THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE. HI I'M
SORRY BURGESS IT IS HI THAT'S.
ELEVEN TWO ZERO. EVERYONE VOTED
THAT BILLS OUT WE ARE ADJOURNED
UNTIL NEXT WEEK JULY THIRTEENTH
FOR OUR LAST REGULARLY
SCHEDULED MEETING OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE EVERYONE
HAVE A GOOD WEEK.